THE
SENATE BUDGET FISCAL REVIEW
COMMITTEE TO WILL COME TO ORDER
GOOD MORNING IN RESPONSE TO THE
COVERT NINETEEN EMERGENCY AND
TO PROTECT THE PUBLIC
LEGISLATORS AND EMPLOYEES WE
MUST LIMIT NONESSENTIAL
GATHERING SAID HERE TO SOCIAL
DISTANCING A FACE COVERING
GUIDELINES AND COMPLIANCE WITH
THOSE ORDERS THE SENATE HAS
MADE NECESSARY. ADJUSTMENTS TO
NORMAL PRACTICES IN ORDER TO
ENSURE THE PUBLIC CONTINUES TO
HAVE ACCESS TO THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS WE ARE HOLDING OUR
COMMITTEE HEARING. HERE IN THE
CAPITAL BUT WITH SOME MEMBERS
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY TODAY.
THREE MEMBERS OF THE
SUBCOMMITTEE WILL BE HERE IN
THE ROOM AND ONE CENTER WILL BE
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY- ALL OF
THEM ARE ENOUGH COMMITTEES NOW
SO WILL CALL THE- MAKE A QUORUM.
AT THE APPROPRIATE. THOSE
PROVIDING TEST BEFORE THE
COMMITTEE- ARE ALSO
PARTICIPATING. FAR REMOTE
PARTICIPANTS PLEASE MUTE YOUR
PHONES OR COMPUTERS. THIS WILL
GREATLY AID IN ELIMINATING ANY
ACOUSTIC BACK FEET I S. IT
EVERY TIME YOU WISH TO BE
RECOGNIZED THAT YOU. USED TO
RAISE YOUR HAND FUTURE OF THE
PROGRAM EACH TIME YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK A POP UP
WINDOW WILL APPEAR ASKING YOU
TO. IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO I NEED
PLEASE SELECT A MINUTE BEFORE
YOU BEGIN SPEAKING R. I. T.
PERSONNEL WILL. PUT YOU BACK ON
MUTE WHEN YOU'RE DONE ONCE
RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK PLEASE MAKE
SURE YOU CAN BE SEEN ON THE
SCREEN STATE YOUR NAME. AND
THEN WE ARE READY TO. OUR
TRUSTY. COMMITTEE WORLD.
WISHING TO PROVIDE PUBLIC. THE
PER. TOLL FREE NUMBER NEXT
CODES PER. ON OUR COMMITTEE WEB.
WILL BE THIS ON THIS AND I WILL.
IT NOW TO THIS PER. NOW IS A
FOUR FOUR TWO NINE ONE. FOUR
EIGHT ONE FIVE AND X. SIX CODE
IS SEVEN THREE ONE FOUR FOUR OF
NINE. THIRTY TWO INSTRUCTIONS
ON HOW TO TELL- CONFERENCE.
WORKS PLEASE REFER TO THE
SENATE AND ARE- COMMITTEE
WEBSITE PLEASE NOTE THAT IN
ORDER TO. FOR US TO HEAR YOU.
CLEARLY TO AVOID ACOUSTIC FEET
THAT. YOU TOO MUST MEET THE
DEVICE YOU'RE WATCHING THE-
HEARING THAT PRIOR TO GIVING
TESTIMONY OVER THE PHONE. IT'S
IMPORTANT WE HEAR FROM YOU AND
WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE
I WILL MAINTAIN DECORUM DURING
THE HEARING. AS IS CUSTOMARY
IN. ANY INDIVIDUAL WHO IS
DISRUPTED- MAY BE REMOVED FROM
HER. MEETING SERVICE OR HAVE
THEIR CONNECTION TO THE PUB
COMMENT WILL BE HEARD AFTER
ALL. DISCUSSION ITEMS HAVE BEEN
PRESENTED WELL EVERY EFFORT HAS
BEEN MADE TO STREAMLINE THE
HIRING PROCESS AND CONDUCT OUR
HEARINGS. IT IS CLOSE TO THE
SAME MANNER AS IS CUSTOMARY.
THERE MAY BE SOME BLACK TAX
RETURNS PARTICIPANTS. WHO ARE
ADJUSTING TO THE NEW USE OF ON
LINE TECHNOLOGY. TECHNOLOGIES
AND TOOLS. PLEASE BE RESPECTFUL
IMPATIENCE TO ALL INTERESTED
PARTIES. CAN BE HEARD LASTLY.
FOR EVERYONE PHYSICALLY HERE
TODAY. PLEASE KEEP YOUR ASK ON.
COVER YOUR NOSE. AND MOUTH ALL
TIMES- WE- WILL PROCEED AS THIS
COMMITTEE. OF BECAUSE WE DON'T
HAVE A- THIS IS YOUR QUORUM- WE
HAVE TO I ON AGENDA TODAY JUST
RIGHT CENTER BLUE. WILD WOULD
YOU LIKE 2% FONG ITEM NUMBER
ONE WHICH IS THAT THE OF TOXIC
SUBSTANCES CONTROL. RIVERWOOD
THANK YOU AS J. WHITE HOUSE DE
AND OTHER MEMBERS AS YOU JOINED
HAVE SAYS WARNER REALLY
APPRECIATE YOU PRESENTLY FOR
YOU'LL COMMITMENT TO THIS
PARTICULAR ISSUE- THAT I'M
GONNA FRAME OUT WHICH IS.
DEPARTMENT OF TOXIC SUBSTANCES
CONTROL- REFORM AND FEES AND
ACCOUNTABILITY- YOU'VE BEEN
YOU'VE BEEN WORKING ON THIS A
LONG TIME FROM FROM MY
PERSPECTIVE THIS IS THE YEAR TO
GET IT DONE- I ALSO WANT TO
ACKNOWLEDGE YOU FULL THE NEXT
ITEM- WHICH IS DROUGHT- WHICH
IS SPENDING A LOT OF TIME ON SO
BOTH TWO VERY VERY IMPORTANT
ISSUES- FOR THE RECORD MY NAME
IS JARED BLUMENFELD I'M THE
SECTION OF THE CALIFORNIA
ENVIRONMENTAL PROTECTION
AGENCY. AND REALLY YOU HAVE
THIS PRIORITY OF WORKING
TOGETHER TO FIX FUND AND ENSURE
ACCOUNTABILITY AND TRANSPARENCY
OF D. DS C. HAS TO BE A TOP
PRIORITY- YOU CAN IMAGINE IF
YOU LIVED IN A COMMUNITY AS
MANY DID. WHETHER FACILITY ALL
OUT OLD ABANDONED SITE THAT'S
TOXIC THAT RIGHTLY BECOMES
YOU'LL COMMUNITIES TOP CONCERN
AND NOW IT'S OUR TIME TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE CLEAN UP THE MORE
THAN A HUNDRED AND FIFTY
THOUSAND TOXIC SITES THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA. I BELIEVE AND I
THINK YOU KNOW WE HAVE SHOWN
THAT WE CAN TEN A LEGACY OF
BLIGHT INTO NEW OPPORTUNITIES
INTO JOBS INTO HELPING HEALTHY
FOR THRIVING COMMUNITIES. WE
ALSO NEED TO CONTINUE TO LEAD
THE WAY TO ELIMINATE CANCER
CAUSING AND OTHER HARMFUL
CHEMICALS FROM PRODUCTS SOLD
TODAY- IN GROCERY STORE SHELVES.
ACROSS OUR STATE. WHEN I THINK
ABOUT THE ROLE OF GOVERNMENT-
AND WE HAD TO DO. I CAN THINK
OF MORE IMPORTANT ROLE THAN TO
PREVENT AND RE HIGH. AND IS AN-
THAT REALLY HAS BEEN LEFT. TO
FUNCTION NOT AT FULL TILT FOR
TOO LONG AND I THINK TOGETHER
WE CAN RESOLVE THAT. SAYS TO ME
THIS THIS IS OUR TIME THIS IS
THE OPPORTUNITY TO LIVE UP TO
OUR ROLES AS STEWARDS OF
CALIFORNIA'S HEALTH. I'M AS
REAL NARROW AND UNFORTUNATELY
RECOGNIZED AS AN UGLY. LEGACY
OF STRUCTURAL RACISM WHICH
MEANS THAT ACROSS OUR NATION
AND OUR STATE. ONE'S PROXIMITY
TO A HAZARDOUS WASTE SITE. IS
TIED TO THE COLOR OF YOUR SKIN.
THE ARE VERY REAL AND PRESS IN.
AND THEY MUST AND- AND WE NOW
THROUGH THIS EFFORT IN FRONT OF
US TODAY HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY
TO DO SOMETHING ABOUT IT. THE
GOVERNOR'S JANUARY TENTH BUDGET
INCLUDES THREE HUNDRED MILLION
TO DO SITE INVEST EIGHT SITE
INVESTIGATIONS AND AEGEE
COMMUNITIES GROUNDS AND WALK
WHAT FORCE PROGRAMS ALL WITHIN
EACH A FOCUS. A VOTE FOR REFORM
IS A VOTE FOR INVESTING THREE
HUNDRED MILLION. DOLLARS IN THE
COMMUNITIES THAT HAVE BEEN
WAITING A VERY LONG TIME THAT'S
SOMETHING. THAT IS FUNDAMENTAL
TO ALL OF US WE JUST WANT TO
LIVE IN SAFE CLEAN PLACES AND
UNFORTUNATELY FOR TO LONG.
WE'VE OVER PROMISED AND UNDER
DELIVERED TO ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE IMPACTED COMMUNITIES
THIS IS A CHANCE TO COME UP
WITH A CLEAR PROMISE. AND THEN
TO DELIVER. ALL WHILE BEING
HELD ACCOUNTABLE. I KNEW OF THE
SITE BOARDS. I'M PROUD TO WORK
EVERY DAY ALONG DOC MEREDITH
THE HAVE NECK AND THEY HAVE.
LEADERSHIP AT THE- AND I
PERSONALLY WOULD. DAY IN OUT
THANK. TO ACTIVELY AND REFORM
THEY'RE NOT WAITING PERMISSION
TO IMPAIR. THAT DOING IT BY AND
OR- WE- THAT. THIS IN PACK NEED
TO GO FOR- IN. THE TRY BILL.
I'M AS ONE. WE CON RATE OUT.
THE FUNDING FROM THE REFORM
FROM- THE ACCOUNTABILITY THEY
ONLY TO HAPPEN AT THE SAME TIME
AND I'M REALLY PROUD OF THE
WORK THAT WE'VE DONE WITH THE
USE SENATE- I'M AND THE
LEGISLATURE GENERALLY GOING. TO
WEEKLY MEETINGS- WITH WITH YOUR
STAFF WITH STAKEHOLDERS. I'M
AND TO MAKE SURE THAT WE BEEN
RESPONSIVE TED THAT VERY LARGE
VOLUME OF SUGGESTIONS THE
PEOPLE SENATE THE INDEPENDENT
REVIEW PANEL. WE'VE MADE SURE
THAT EVERY SINGLE ASPECT WE'VE
BEEN RESPONSIVE TO- AND WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT WHEN WE TAKE
ACTION TO ADDRESS THE LONG
STANDING CONCERNS OUT FROM MY
PERSPECTIVE DEPARTMENT IS
RUNNING BAD- BUT AS THE WHITE
LIGHT ANALYSIS THAT THAT WAS
PAINSTAKINGLY DONE BY FRANCESCA
NAY GREEN HAD AMAZING TEAM
SHOWS. THERE'S A BIG GAP
BETWEEN WHAT WE'VE BEEN ASKED
TO DO IS THE DEPARTMENT AND
WHAT WAY FUNDED TO DO.
COMMUNITIES CANNOT WAIT- THAT
ECONOMIC RECOVERY NEEDS TO BE
EQUITABLE AND I BELIEVE THAT
THIS ENTIRE PACKAGE MOVES US IN
A VERY REAL WAY TOWARDS
CLEANING OUT THE LEGACIES OF
THE PAST. PROVIDING COMMUNITIES
THAT HAVE A NOSE FULL OF THEIR
OWN- BEEN SITED NEXT TO
HAZARDOUS WASTE FACILITIES AND
TODAY WE CAN DO SOMETHING ABOUT
IT AND I JUST WANT TO THANK YOU
AGAIN FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP. AND
TEN OUT OF THAT TO THE DIRECTOR
DR MEREDITH WILLIAMS I HAVE.
INTRODUCTION SOME DOCTOR
WILLIAMSON I MEAN THIS I OF.
NOT HAVING A LACK OF
SUGGESTIONS IS- FERTILE HERE IN
THE LEGISLATURE AND THE IDEA OF
OVER PROMISING AND UNDER
DELIVERING I KNOW THAT WE
HAVEN'T HAD A ADJUSTMENT ON THE
FEES. HAVE SET FORTH IN OUR THE
REPORTINTO THREE YEARS BUT WE
MAGICALLY BEEN ABLE COME UP
NINETY TWO STATURE. AND THINGS
THAT YOU YOUR SHE BE DOING
INCLUDING GREEN KEVIN. WHICH IS
ONE OF THE YOU KNOW ONE OF THE
HIGHLIGHTS OF LEGISLATORS LIKE
TO TALK ABOUT I REMEMBER WHEN I
FIRST GOT HERE TO GET THAT.
GREEN ADVISORY BOARD BACK
TOGETHER AND TRY TO GET IT SET
UP AND THERE WAS NO CHECK
COMING FROM THE LEGISLATURE SO
IT'S- IT'S A- IT READS LIKE
EITHER A NIGHTMARE OR ADD- WELL
IT'S A CALL TO ACTION SO PLEASE
PROCEED. YEAH IT WAS A GOOD
MATCH. ARE THAT HAPPENED IN.
EVEN GETTING THE. I WAS VERY
REGULATION SPECIFIC PRODUCTS
PROGRAM ESTABLISH AND THEN
GETTING OUT OPEN RUN. SO THANK
YOU CHAIR OSCAR THANK YOU THE
OTHER OF THE COMMITTEE ON FOR
THE RECORD AGAIN NAME IS
WILLIAMS AND- OF THE OF TALK
STUFF CONTROL. AND WOMAN FILLED
WITH CAN COME CONVEY THAT SENSE
URGENCY ABOUT TRAILER BILL. AND
UNDER THE TIME SINCE THE OUT
GETTING THIS DURING THE BUDGET
CYCLE. THE FOR IS STRONG IN.
THOSE THREE FUN COME OF THE
PART THE NEED FROM TRAINS.
ACCOUNT AND- STABILITY THE
CHEST YOU- WAIT WAIT POINT
HONESTLY DECADES THE MAKING. IT
COMPREHENSIVE IN ADDRESSES ALL.
IT'S NOT SAME PROPOSAL LAST
YEAR WE THINK THIS YEAR'S BOOK.
FOR STRONGER AND ONE OF THE
REASONS FOR IS WE A GREAT DEAL
DURING THE DEVELOP. AND JUST GO
ARE. EIGHTEEN NINE. AND SO WHAT
SEE THIS YEAR THERE ARE PROVIDE.
FOR ACCOUNT. FOR INSTANCE
STRONG WORK FOR DECISION. AT
HAND FOR RECORDING OUT ON A
PROGRAM ON ON MAKING PERMIT- WE
ARE. HOLDING POLLUTERS MORE
WITH STRONGER FINANCE SURE
MACINNES. I DON'T REALLY TALK
QUITE A STORY ABOUT WHERE OUR
GAPS ARE. AND THAT ALLOWS US IN
THIS YEAR'S PROPOSALS TO FUND
TO REALLY HAVE THE BASIS TO SAY
WE NEED NOT JUST CLOSE THE
STRUCTURAL DEFICIT BUT ALSO
CLOSE SOME CRITICAL GAPS SO
THAT THE DEPARTMENT CAN MORE
CLOSELY NEED ITS MISSION. ALL
OF THESE CHANGES CAME AS A
RESULT OF STAKEHOLDER
ENGAGEMENT PRECIADO THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TALK TO YOU ONE
ON ONE OTHER COMMITTEE MEMBERS
EITHER PAST OR UPCOMING- WILL
ALSO BE GIVING THEIR THEIR
PERSPECTIVE ON THE DEPARTMENT
WHAT WE NEED TO BE DOING THEIR
THOUGHTS ON THE REFORM EFFORTS.
AND WHAT THE PRIORITIES ARE AND
THAT'S BEEN AGAIN TREMENDOUSLY
HELPFUL IN STRENGTHENING THE
PROPOSAL. AS JERRY TALKED TO
POINTED OUT WERE MEETING WITH
LEGISLATIVE STAFFERS WE- ARE
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE AND
COMMUNITY D. MEMBER
REPRESENTATIVES WITH ALL
MEMBERS OF THE REGULATED
COMMUNITY AND ALL OF THIS.
TRANSFORMING OUR UNDERSTANDING.
OF WHERE. THIS PROPOSAL NEEDS.
THERE AS A RESULT THAT GREAT
CAN YOU THERE ARE JUST GAS BUT-
THE TRAILER PROPOSAL IN. ONE
BUT I DO TO HIGH JUST A COUPLE
THOSE- ONE WOULD BE THE
DECIDING. THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION ALSO GIVES TO
THE BOARD THAT SHE SETTING.
WITH BE SUB TO LEGISLATIVE
APPROVAL THROUGH THE BUDGET
PROCESS AND I THINK THAT'S AN
IMPORTANT THING TO HIGHLIGHTS.
ALSO WE WELL BOTH PROPOSALS
INCLUDE A MODERNIZE HAZARDOUS
WASTE MANAGEMENT PLAN THERE'S A
DIFFERENCE IN THE TIME AND THE
REASON FOR THAT IS THAT THE
DEPARTMENT. IS RELYING ON THOSE
INCREASED REVENUES TO FUND WILL
WORK ON A HAZARDOUS WASTE
MANAGEMENT PLAN AND SO WE THINK
IT'S RESPONSIBLE IMPROVE A LOT
TO MOVEMENTS NOT TO TAKE ON
THAT WORK. ON UNTIL WE. HAVE
THE RESOURCES IN PLACE TO DO IT.
AND THEN- WHAT WEEK AB ONE DO
STILL CONTAIN A PROVISION FOR
ANY. TASK FORCE AND I WOULD
SAY. THAT GIVEN ALL THE WORK TO
BE DONE TO. CONSIDER DIFFERENT
SCENARIOS AND DIFFERENT
STRUCTURES WE WERE VERY
CONFIDENT IN. THE STRUCTURAL
PUTTING FORTH IN TERMS OF ITS
FUNDAMENTAL COMPLIANCE
CONSISTENCY WITH THE COMMUTER
PAYS HER WHICH AND WITH ITS
ABILITY TO MEET THE REVENUE
TARGETS. AND MORE EQUITABLE WE
JUST DISTRIBUTE THE COSTS OF
BOTH FOR THAT THE HAZARDOUS
WASTE CONTROL ACCOUNT AS WELL
AS FOR THE TRUCKS TOXIC
SUBSTANCES CONTROL HELPED.
HELLO ARE I COULD GO ON WITH
THE DETAIL OF THE PROPOSAL- BUT
I WILL WRAP UP MY COMMENTS SO
THAT WE HAVE TIME FOR YOUR
QUESTIONS AND I WILL JUST-
TURNED IT OVER TO AGAIN SHE
STAFF DEPUTY DIRECTOR FRANCESCA
DEGREE. AND TAKE THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO THANK HER FOR
ALL HER LEADERSHIP IN BRINGING
THAT WORKLOAD ANALYSIS TO
FRUITION TRANSFORMS DISCUSSION
THANK YOU DEPUTY NAY GRIEF HOLD
THAT SECOND. A MISS ROY IF WE
COULD ESTABLISH A QUORUM IF YOU
COULD PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ONE
CASKEY HERE WHAT KASKY HERE
DOLLY. DOLLY HERE MCGUIRE. HERE
MCGUIRE HERE STERN. OKAY A
PHARMACIST IS AS PRESENT. OKAY.
WE HAVE NUMEROUS HEARINGS ARE
GOING ON RIGHT NOW SO- THE
DEADLINE IS UPON US- WE WILL
LET'S CONTINUE WITH OUR TOXIC
THIS DISCUSSION A DEPUTY MAKERS.
WELL THANK YOU SO MUCH CHAIR
AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK TO YOU
TODAY ABOUT THE T. S. C. FISCAL
AND GOVERNANCE REFORM AND I
WOULD JUST SAY THAT- BUT THE
REFORM ITSELF BUILDS ON AND
YEARS OF IMPLEMENTING A CULTURE
OF CONTINUOUS IMPROVEMENT. THIS
IS BEEN DONE UNDER THE
LEADERSHIP OF SECRETARY
BLUMENFELD AND DIRECTOR
WILLIAMS AND HAS BEEN
ILLUSTRATED IN THE WORKLOAD
ANALYSIS IN ADDITION TO THE
GAPS WE TO LOOK AT HOW WE'RE
USING OUR RESOURCES AND-
ILLUSTRATED THE IMPROVEMENT
INITIATIVES TO DEMONSTRATE OUR
INCREASED SEWARDSHIP OF THOSE
RESOURCES FROM DECREASING
PERMITTING TIME FRAMES TO.
STREAMLINING THE SAFER CONSUMER
PRODUCTS PROGRAM TO-
STRENGTHENING OUR ENFORCEMENT
PROGRAM AND- STREAMLINING OUR
VOLUNTARY CLEANUP PROGRAM ALL
OF THESE PROGRAMMATIC
IMPROVEMENTS HAVE SET US UP I
THINK FOR BEING READY FOR
FISCAL AND GOVERNANCE REFORMS
AND HELP TO BUILD- TRUST IN OUR
ABILITY TO. TO MANAGE INCREASED
RESOURCES. AND TO- THE
SUCCESSFUL WITH- THE GOVERNOR'S
INITIATIVE TO INCLUDE THREE
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS IN THIS
PROPOSAL THAT PROTECTS PEOPLE'S
IMPACT PEOPLE AND STRENGTHENS
COMMUNITIES- IT WILL BUILD THE
INFRASTRUCTURE- THAT WAS
IDENTIFIED AS BEING DEFICIENT
WITHIN DGSE TO CONDUCT. SITE
DISCOVERY AND INVESTIGATION AND
THE FEE STRUCTURE THAT'S BEING
PROPOSED WILL PROVIDE ONGOING
SUSTAINABLE FUNDING FOR THAT
PROGRAM. IT ALSO INCLUDES A
WORKFORCE AND DEVELOPMENT
PROGRAM THAT WILL- PROVIDE
ECONOMIC AND JOBS ECONOMIC
OPPORTUNITIES AND JOBS FOR
COMMUNITY MEMBERS THAT ARE HAVE
BEEN IMPACTED BY A
DISPROPORTIONATE BURDEN. OF
ENVIRONMENTAL TOXIC SUBSTANCES-
THE OUTCOME WILL BE SAFER-
AFFORDABLE HOUSING WHEN I TALK
ABOUT THESE COMMUNITIES I'M
TALKING ABOUT ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE COMMUNITIES SUCH AS THE
ONES THAT- SECRETARY BLUMENFELD
MENTIONED THAT ARE IN THE TOP
TWENTY FIVE OF OUR CALOMBARIS
SCREEN- THE SYSTEM AND- ALSO
HAVE BEEN- IDENTIFIED AS
NEEDING HAVE HAVING VERY HIGH
HOUSING NEEDS- WE'VE BEEN
CONDUCTING IN ADDITION TO THE
SESSIONS- WITH YOUR TEAMS AND
OTHER STAKEHOLDERS ON THE
REFORM PACKAGE ITSELF. WE'VE
BEEN CONDUCTING LISTENING
SESSIONS ON THE- ON THE THREE
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS IN
TALKING ABOUT- OUR PLANS- IF
THIS PROPOSAL IS APPROVED- FOR
HITTING THE GROUND RUNNING AND
STARTING WITHIN THE FIRST SIX
MONTHS WE INTEND TO. CONDUCT
SITE DISCOVERY- IN THE FIRST
SIX MONTHS OF THE FISCAL YEAR
I'M CONDUCTING URGENCY OPTIONS
DEPENDING ON WHAT WE FIND IN
CONDUCT RESPONSIBLE PARTY
SEARCHES- WILL BE PROMOTING
THAT THE GRANTS PROGRAM THAT'S
INCLUDED IN THE THREE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS. PROVIDING
EDUCATION ON THAT PROGRAM AND
OPENING UP THE APPLICATION
PERIOD- IN ADDITION- WILL
CONDUCTING LISTENING SESSIONS
ON THE WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
PROGRAM AND I DID FIND NEED TO
COMMUNITIES TO MATCH SKILL SETS
AND- AND- ARCHER. OPPORTUNITIES
WITH THE WORK BEING PERFORMED
IN THOSE COMMUNITIES HAPPY TO
PROVIDE YOU WITH MORE DETAIL ON
ON THAT PLAN BUT JUST WANTED TO
LEAVE YOU WITH- THE THOUGHT
THAT THIS THREE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS AS PART OF THAT LARGER
REFORM EFFORT THAT. DIRECTOR
WILLIAMS DESCRIBED THAT
INCLUDES A FISCAL PACKAGE TO
STREAMLINE OUR OUR HAZARDOUS
WHERE HE STRUCTURE HAS JUST
WEST CONTROL ACCOUNT AND ALIGN
IT WITH THE POLLUTER PAYS
PRINCIPLE TO MAKE SURE THERE'S
ADEQUATE FUNDING OR TOXIC
SUBSTANCES CONTROL ACCOUNT. TO
ADDRESS THE MOST CRITICAL
NEEDS- THAT WERE IDENTIFIED IN
THE WORKLOAD ANALYSES AND TO
PROVIDE- SUSTAINABLE FUNDING
FOR- A BOARD THAT WILL-
STRENGTHEN ACCOUNTABILITY AND
TRANSPARENCY IN THE DEPARTMENT.
SO WITH THAT- AND MY COMMENTS
AND BE HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS THAT YOU HAVE. THANK
YOU DEPUTY **** YOU CAN'T SEE
MY FACE BECAUSE I'M I'M
RECALLING ONE AND TEN YEARS AGO
IN TWENTY ELEVEN I WAS IN THE
ASSEMBLY AND I DID IT
OVERSIGHT. OF THE T. S. C. N.
IT OUT MY GOD IF THE IF. THE
PLAYERS COULD SEE OUR STAFF
REPORT AND REALIZED THAT THE-
PROGRAM'S REFORMS IN THE PROBE
PROGRAMMING WE'RE- ALL IN LINE
WITH YEAH WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
WHETHER. THE APPOINTEES REPORT
TO KELLY P. A. R. D. T. S. C.
OR DO WE HAVE- THE SENATE
APPROVED THEM IT'S REALLY
MINUSCULE COMPARED TO THE THAT
THE STEPS THAT WE'VE TAKEN AND-
IN THE DECADE- BUT I'M NOT
GOING TO STEAL THE ALEJO'S.
THUNDER I WILL- RECOGNIZE
MISTER BROWN'S. OR DO I HAVE
FINANCE FIRST. LET'S HAVE THIS
OF LA- FOR ANIMAL HAVE FINAL.
THEY CAN DO RE. MISTER MISTER
BROWN. GOOD MORNING MR CAN
MEMBERS PRIME BROWN WITH L. A.
L. I. MEXICAN TO TURN IT OVER
TO MY COLLEAGUE FRANK MENACE.
GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN VERS
FRANK MENACE AT THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE- OUR OFFICE
HAS PREPARED A PRESENTATION
TODAY AND I'M GOING TO GIVE
THAT UP FOR YOU GUYS. GOT IT.
THANK MISTER CAN YOU SEE THAT.
YES I CAN MYSTERY MENACE
PERFECT OKAY SO- YEAH SO ONE
THING ABOUT THIS PROPOSAL THERE
ARE FOUR MAJOR COMPONENTS- THE
FIRST BEING THE ESTABLISHMENT
OF THE BOARD OF ENVIRONMENTAL
SAFETY WITHIN THE DEPARTMENT- A
PROPOSAL TO ADDRESS THE
STRUCTURE SHORTFALL WITHIN THE
HAZARDOUS WASTE CONTROL
THE STRUCTURAL SHORTFALL WITHIN
THE TOXIC SUBSTANCES CONTROL
ACCOUNT AND THREE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS IN ONE TIME
GENERAL FUND- FOR BROWNFIELD
CLEANUPS ACROSS THE STATE- FOR
THE BOARD ENVIRONMENTAL SAFETY
PROPOSAL WE RECOMMEND THAT THE
LEGISLATURE APPROVED THE
ESTABLISHMENT OF THE BOARD- WE
FIND AT THE BOARD SUCH AS THIS
CAN- IMPROVE ACCOUNTABILITY AND
TRANSPARENCY FOR THE
DEPARTMENT. OUR WRECKING
RECOMMENDING THREE
MODIFICATIONS TO INCREASE
LEGISLATIVE OVERSIGHT. THE
FIRST BEING THAT THE SENATE AND
ASSEMBLY EACH HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY- TO APPOINT A BOARD
MEMBER- THAT GUBERNATORIAL
BOARD MEMBERS ARE SUBJECT TO
SENATE CONFIRMATION. AND AT THE
BORDER BOARD ANNUALLY TO THE
LEGISLATURE ARE- ON THE
DEPARTMENT'S PERFORMANCE. FOR
THE PROPOSAL TO ADDRESS THE
STRUCTURAL DEFICIT WITHIN THE
HAZARDOUS WASTE CONTROL
ACCOUNTS- WE RECOMMEND THAT THE
LEGISLATURE PROVE ONE TIME
GENERAL FUNDS OF TWENTY TWO AND
A HALF MILLION- IN THE BUDGET
YEAR THIS WOULD SOLVE THE THIS
WOULD KEEP THE FUND SOLVENT IN
THE BUDGET YEAR WHEN ALLOWED
THE DEPARTMENT TO CONTINUE.
WITH ITS CURRENT PROGRAMMATIC
EXPENDITURES- WE RECOMMEND THAT
THE LEGISLATURE ADOPT THE H. W.
C. H. R. TREE STRUCTURE AND
INCREASES WE FIND THAT THE
RESTRUCTURE- HAS BENEFITS OVER
THE CURRENT ONE. AND AT THE
INCREASES TO THE FEES WOULD
PROVIDE SUFFICIENT REVENUES
BEGINNING IN TWENTY TWO TWENTY
THREE THEY'RE DRESSED THE
STRUCTURAL DEFICIT BUT ALSO
ALLOW FOR. INCREASED
PROGRAMMATIC EXPENDITURES
RELATED TO THE DEPARTMENT'S
FROM REGULATORY PROGRAMS AND WE
FIND THAT THE INCREASE
PROGRAMMATIC EXPENDITURES
RELATE SAID THE DEPARTMENT'S
WORKLOAD ANALYSIS WHICH FOUND
DEFICIENCIES WITHIN THESE
PROGRAMS OUTSIDE OF JUST THE
STRUCTURAL DEFICIT. WE ALSO
RECOMMEND THAT THE LEGISLATURE
APPROVED THE GOVERNORSHIP
ALTHOUGH TO GRANT THE BOARD
WITH THE ABILITY TO ADJUST
CHARGE LEVELS IN FUTURE YEARS.
THIS WOULD ENSURE THAT
REVENUES- MATCH EXPENDITURES
THAT ARE APPROVED EACH YEAR IN
THE BUDGET ACT BY THE
LEGISLATURE. FOR THE ROLE THE
TO ADDRESS THE STRUCTURAL
DEFICIT WITHIN THE TOXIC
SUBSTANCES CONTROL ACCOUNT.
SIMILAR WE'RE RECOMMENDING THAT
THE LEGISLATURE APPROVED A ONE
TIME GENERAL FUND OF THIRTEEN
MILLION IN THE BUDGET YEAR-
THIS WOULD KEEP THE FUND
SOLVENT AND ALLOW DEPARTMENT
CAN YOU ITS EXISTING
PROGRAMMATIC EXPENDITURES.
HOWEVER FOR THIS ONE ARE
RECOMMENDING THAT THE
LEGISLATURE ADOPT A TAX PACKAGE
THAT RACES SUFFICIENT REVENUES
TO PAY FOR DESIRED EXPENDITURES
THAT REFLECT LEGISLATIVE
PRIORITIES. I'M SIMPLY WHAT IT
SHOULD BE SAFER TASK- THE
MINISTRATION IS PROPOSING TO
INCREASE THE TAX THAT SUPPORTS
THE ACCOUNT- SAYS SOLVE THE
STRUCTURAL DEFICIT BUT ALSO FOR
INCREASED PROGRAMMATIC
EXPENDITURES. HOWEVER WE FIND
THAT BECAUSE- TOSCA IS FUNDED
BY A BROAD BASED BUSINESS TAX
AND- FUNDS A VARIETY OF
DEPARTMENT ACTIVITIES OUTSIDE
OF REGULATORY ACTIVITIES. WE
THINK THAT THE EXPENDITURE AND
TAX INCREASE SHOULD REFLECT
LEGISLATIVE- PRIORITIES. AND WE
ALSO RECOMMEND THAT THE
ULTIMATELY WE RECOMMEND THAT
THE LEGISLATURE APPROVED. AT
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL TO
ALLOW THE NEW BOARD SUGGESTS
THAT TAX IN FUTURE YEARS. THIS
WOULD ENSURE THAT REVENUES-
MATCH EXPENDITURES THAT
APPROPRIATED BY THE LEGISLATURE
IN EACH BUDGET ACT- ONE
THINKING ABOUT THE TAX INCREASE
FOR TOSCA TO ENSURE THAT. I'M
SUFFICIENT REVENUES ARM ARM
CREATED TO MEET LEGISLATIVE-
PRIORITIES FOR EXPENDITURES- WE
pSHOULD ALSO REFLECT LEGISLATIVE
PRIORITIES. THE FIGURE ON THE
LEFT INDICATES THE LEGISLATURE
AREN'T THEY MINISTRATIONS
PROPOSAL. AS YOU CAN SEE-
SMALLER BUSINESSES WOULD NOW BE
EXEMPT FROM PAYING THE TAX.
MEDIUM SIZE BUSINESSES WOULD
ESSENTIALLY BE PAYING THE SAME
AMOUNT IN TWENTY TWO TWENTY
THREE. AND MOST OF THE INCREASE
WOULD BE PLACED ON LARGER
BUSINESSES. I'M IN THE
MINISTRATION AS INDICATED THAT
THESE EXEMPTIONS ARE LARGELY
BECAUSE OF OUR IN RESPONSE THE
PANDEMIC. IN OUR ANALYSIS WE
PROVIDE TO- OVERARCHING POLICY
QUESTIONS FOR THE LEGISLATURE
WHEN CONSIDERING THIS INCREASE.
THE FIRST BEING AS IF AND
DEMOCRAT LATED RELIEF MEASURES-
SHOULD BE INCLUDED. WE FIND
THAT THIS APPROACH ISN'T THE
MOST TARGETED WAY TO- ADDRESS
IMPACTS RELATED TO THE
PANDEMIC. WE FIND THAT THE SIZE
OF BUSINESS WON'T NECESSARILY
RELATE TO NEED IT'S GOING TO
VERY INDUSTRY TO INDUSTRY-
HOWEVER THE LEGISLATURE WHERE
TO FIND THAT- TAX INCREASE IN
STRUCTURE SUCH AS THIS WERE
REFLECTED ITS PRIORITIES- A
SECOND QUESTION WE RAISES.
WHETHER THERE SHOULD BE A
MECHANISM IN THE FUTURE- TO
BRING IN. TO REMOVE EXAMS
BECAUSE THE EXEMPTIONS THAT ARE
CURRENTLY PUT FORWARD WOULD BE
PERMANENT. SO HAVING A
MECHANISM IN PLACE FOR WHEN THE
STATE HAS ENTERED ECONOMIC
RECOVERY- TO REVIEW THESE AND
BRING THESE BUSINESSES BACK
INTO PAYING THE TAX. WELL WHAT
DO YOU ALSO THINK ABOUT THERE'S
A LOT OF. YOU KNOW WHEN YOU
YOU'RE PICKING UP A BIGGER FEE
FROM PEOPLE AT A COST OUT FOR
THE AMOUNT OF WORK THAT YOU
HAVE TO DO A ONE OF THE- ISSUES
IT'S RACES THAT THE SMALLER.
BUSINESSES IT IT SPEND MORE
TIME AND MORE MONEY CHASING
DOWN THE FEE THEN IT'S THEN IT
THEN IT ACTUALLY BRINGS INTO.
BRINGS INTO THE FUN- YEAH THAT
THAT'S THAT'S AN ARGUMENT AND I
GUESS YOU KNOW EVERYBODY HAS
THEIR OWN IDEA OF WHAT A SMALL
BUSINESSES BUT- ID ONE
DEFINITION IS LESS THAN A
HUNDRED PEOPLE SO THAT. SEEMS
TO BE. THE MILLION DOLLARS THAT
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT WITH THIS
THE NUMBER OF EMPLOYEES BETWEEN
FIFTY AND NINETY NINE IS THAT.
WHAT IT WOULD HAVE TO SAY ABOUT
BUT- THAT I MEAN I KNOW THAT
ARGUMENT IS FOR THE PEOPLE
UNDER FIFTY TWO SMALL. SPECIFIC
UP IT IS IT IS IT WORTH OUR
TIME. WE'RE DOING THIS REFORM-
IN SPEAKING WITH THE DEPARTMENT
WE HAVEN'T SEEN ANY INFORMATION
TO INDICATE THAT- EXEMPTING
THESE BUSINESSES WOULD PROVIDE-
SAVINGS AND THAT ESSENTIALLY WE
WOULD BE. PAYING MORE TO
COLLECT THAN REVENUES WOULD BE
BROUGHT IN SO WE HAVEN'T SEEN
ANYTHING ELSE BEGIN DEPARTMENT
IN TERMS OF WHETHER. IT'S WORTH
IT TO EXEMPT AND CONTINUE TO
EXAM SO- THAT WOULD BE MY
RESPONSE AND WHETHER. ACCEPTING
THESE BUSINESSES IS WORTH THE
STATE'S- EFFORTS IN TRYING TO
COLLECT RIGHT NOW AND I GUESS
IF IT IF WE JUST. ARGUMENTATIVE
POLICE SAY WE ACCEPT THE
PANDEMIC AFFECTING PEOPLE
TRYING TO GET ON THEIR FEET AND
ALL THAT. WOULD BE S. EXEMPTION
THAT YOU WOULD SAY- AND ENDED
SUNSETS IN FIVE YEARS OR
WHATEVER WHATEVER WHENEVER WE
THINK PEOPLE ARE BACK ON THEIR
FEET. SO THAT THE- THE BOARD
COULD DETERMINE IF THEY WANTED
TO EXTEND IT BECAUSE IT IS A
TWO THIRDS VOTE SO YOU. IF YOU
SAY NO FOREVER THAT IS NO
FOREVER RIGHT OR YOU KNOW THE
TWO THIRDS VOTE OKAY. PROCEED
I'VE AND THEN WHAT THE RAMPAL
PLAN A PROPOSAL- WE BELIEVE
THAT THE LEGISLATURE TO
CONSIDER THE MERITS OF THIS
PROPOSAL INDEPENDENTLY FROM THE
OTHER THREE COMPONENTS- THE
ADMINISTRATION HAS INDICATED
THAT THE ACCEPTANCE OF THE
BROWNFIELDS PROPOSAL IS
CONTINGENT ON THE OTHER THREE
WE DON'T BELIEVE THE
LEGISLATURE SHOULD THINK IN
THESE TERMS- IF IT'S PART OF
ITS GENERAL FUND PRIORITIES TO
APPROPRIATE FUNDS FOR
BROWNFIELDS CLEANUPS IT SHOULD
AND NOT THINK ABOUT THE OTHER
THREE COMPONENTS- HOWEVER
OVERALL WE FIND THAT THE
BROWNFIELDS PROPOSAL- DOES HAVE
A LOT OF MERIT. I'M GETTING
MONEY FOR BROWNFIELDS CAN-
REDUCE ENVIRONMENTAL RISK AND
HEALTH RISKS ASSOCIATED WITH
CONTAMINATION- IT CAN ALSO SPUR
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT
COMMUNITIES THAT ARE UNDER
INVESTED- BUT WE HAVE TO KEEP
POLICY QUESTIONS AND
IMPLEMENTATION QUESTIONS THE
FIRST TWO FORWARDS ARE LARGER
POLICY QUESTIONS THE FIRST
BEING IS WHAT IS- THE INTENDED
GOAL WHAT GOAL IS THE HIGHEST
INTENDED- PRIORITY FOR FUNDING
AND WE FIND THAT THE PROPOSAL
HAS TWO MAIN PRIORITIES IT'S
THE SPUR HOUSING DEVELOPMENT
AND ALSO TO ADDRESS
CONTAMINATION THE LEGISLATURE
MAY WANT TO IDENTIFY. A PRIMARY
GOAL SO FUNDS ARE TARGETED AND
THAT THE LEGISLATURE CONTRACT
HOW WE'RE MEETING THESE GOALS-
FOR THE GRANT PRO- COMPONENT OF
THIS PROPOSAL WOULD ONE INSURE
THAT THE LEGISLATURE
UNDERSTANDS THAT HOW THIS
FUNDING COMPLEMENTS OTHER
HOUSING PROPOSALS WITHIN THE
BUDGET ACT AND IT SUPPORTS THEM
AS WELL- THERE'S NUMEROUS
HOUSING PROPOSALS BUT THEN THE
BUDGETS WOULD WANT INSURE THAT
THIS GRANT COMPONENT I'M
COMPLIMENTS THEM AND ENSURES
THAT THERE'S NO DUPLICATION AS
WELL. AND THAT THIS HOUSING
COMPOUND OUTLINES WHAT THE
LEGISLATURE'S PRIORITIES AND
THEN FOR IMPLEMENTATION
QUESTIONS GO TO THE BOTTOM TWO-
HOW THE ENVIRONMENT AND ENSURE
THE HOUSING ATTRACTIVE THEY'RE
MAD WE JUST WANT TO INSURE THAT
THE DEPARTMENT HAS AN EFFECTIVE
PLAN TO ENSURE THAT
COORDINATING WITH THE
APPROPRIATE AGENCIES AND
ENSURING THAT HOUSING IS A
MAJOR COMPONENT OF THIS AND
THEN FOR THE WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT COMPONENT WE WANT.
TO ENSURE THAT AND SETTING UP
THIS PROGRAM THE THOSE WHO
ENTER THE PRO. HAVE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR LONG TERM.
AND SHOWING THAT THE STATE ACT
DOES NEED TO RAMP UP TRAINING
FOR THOSE WHO. WORK IN THESE
AREAS AND THAT WOULD BE TRAINED
IN THEM. WHAT WOULDN'T THAT
WOULDN'T WOULDN'T THAT YOU KNOW
THE SECRETARY. HAS IDENTIFIED
WHAT WAS A HUNDRED AND FIFTY
THOUSAND SITES. IF WE IF THIS
IF THIS THING GOES FORWARD THEY
MADE TO THE ASSESSMENT ON. WHAT
IT THIRTY OR SIXTY MAYBE A
HUNDRED SITES SO IT'S A LONG
WAY OFF BEFORE WE FINISH THAT
HUNDRED FIFTY. THOUSAND AND
WE'RE ONLY DOING IT FOR
IDENTIFYING THE MOST TOXIC-
WOULDN'T IT IF THE FEES ARE
GOING TO BE ADJUSTED. WOULDN'T
THAT. INTUITIVELY SAY THAT THIS
WORKFORCE IS GOING TO. NEED TO
CONTINUE WANT BECAUSE- YOU'LL
MOVE FROM ONE TOXIC SITE TO THE
NEXT TAX TOXIC SIDE. WERE GREEN
WHAT TYPE OF DEMONSTRATION ARE
YOU LOOKING FOR IN THE
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT BECAUSE
IT SEEMS TO ME IF IT WAS JUST
ONE AND DONE I GET IT WE JUST
GAVE MONEY AND IT WAS OVER. AND
THERE'S A QUESTION THERE BUT IF
IT'S IF WE'RE SETTING THE FEES
AND IT'S GOING TO ROUTE
REVOLVING ACCOUNT. THAT SHOULD.
I WOULD LIKE TO SEE YOU KNOW
SIXTY SITES. ASSESSED EVERY
YEAR OR SOMETHING LIKE THAT
MAYBE MORE. DO YOU SEE IT THAT
WAY OR NOT YES THAT THAT'S TRUE
MISTER CHAIR I THINK WE LARGELY
AGREE WITH THAT BUT WE JUST
WANT TO INSURE THAT THE STATE
DOES NEED IT- MORE TRAINING IN
THIS AREA ENSURING THAT YOU
KNOW MAYBE THAT THERE IS AN
UNDERLYING UNDER UTILIZE WORK
FORCE AND IS THIS RAMPS UP
THEY'LL START TO GET EMPLOYED.
WE WOULD- NOT AGREE WITH THE
STATE'S STARTING A PROGRAM AND
HAVING PEOPLE WHO ARE TRAINED
AND WHEN THEY GET OUT INTO THE
WORKFORCE AFTER THE TRAINING
THAT THERE IS NO LONG TERM
EMPLOYMENT. AND SINCE WE ARE
INCREASING THE FEES AND THERE
WOULD BE INCREASED SOME
INCREASE WORKLOAD WITH THAT AND
THEN THE BROWNFIELDS MONEY
WOULD ALSO COME INTO EFFECT AS
WELL WITH BUT THE BROWN PUTS
MONEY IS LARGELY. ONE TIME THAT
WILL BE SPENT OR MULTIPLE
YEARS. YES ENSURING THE FOR
THAT TRANSITION PERIOD THAT ONE
HE'S- INDIVIDUALS COME OUT OF
THE PROGRAM. THAT THEY DO HAVE
LONG TERM EMPLOYMENT- SO JUST
ENSURING THAT THE STATE.
DOESN'T HAVE THE STRAIN
WORKFORCE AND ENSURING THAT
WERE RAMPING UP TO MEET IT NOT
NECESSARY TRAINING PEOPLE JUST
FOR TRAINING PEOPLE. OKAY I'LL
GET TO A LESS FINANCING. FOLLOW
UP THERE LET'S GET TO THE-
AGAIN WE'VE GOT SO MUCH STUFF
THAT WE AGREE ON AND THAT THAT
THE CAN THE- THE BOARD JUST
COULD BE CREATED. BUT THE
LEGISLATIVE OVERSIGHT I MEAN.
WE'RE SITTING HERE AND WE
CONTROL THE BUDGET OF DGSE N.
R. E. P. A. M. ONE OF THE
CONCERNS YOU HAVE IS THIS BOARD
REPORTING THEIR INDEPENDENT-
CONCLUSIONS AT THE AFTER THEY
HAVE THE SIX MEETINGS
THROUGHOUT THE YEAR. WOULDN'T
WOULDN'T IT BE OBVIOUS OF WHAT
WHAT. WHEN THE WHEN THE
DIRECTOR COMES BEFORE US WE
HEARD HER FOR HER BUDGET AND
DGSE AND SAYS THESE ARE THE
SITES THAT WE'VE CLEANED UP
THESE ARE THE SITES THAT WE ARE
WORKING ON- WHY WOULD I NEED TO
HAVE CONTROL OR IS IT
LEGISLATOR OF THE OF HER
OVERSIGHT BOARD THAT IF SHE'S
NOT CLEANING IT UP THEN I WANT
TO BRING THE OVERSIGHT BOARD
BEFORE THE OF THE LEGISLATURE
BUT WHY WOULD I. WHY WOULD I
WHY WOULD I WANT TO HAVE
ANOTHER REPORT THAT THAT I
DON'T LOVE READING REPORTS FROM
DTS HERE FROM THE SECRETARY OF
EPA BUT WHY WOULD I WANT TO
HAVE ANOTHER REPORT UNLESS
THERE WAS SOMETHING WRONG RIGHT
ON THE ON THE NATURAL. I GUESS
THAT'S MY- BECAUSE YOU SORT OF
SET IT UP. THAT WAY THAT WE
WOULD GET REPORT AND THE
SECOND. IS I KNOW THAT WE LOVE
YOU SORT OF A- SINCE I GOT HERE
EVERYBODY LIKES TO HAVE ONE
PERSON FROM THE ASSEMBLY ONE
PERSON FROM THE SENATE THAT
SPEAKER THEY GET ON THESE
BOARDS. AND YOU KNOW THIS IS
THIS IS A VERY TECHNICAL BOARD
THAT'S DOING OVERSIGHT OF THE-
TOXICS PROGRAM THIS IS NOT.
THIS IS NOT THAT RECREATION. OR
PARKS AND RECREATION SOMETHING
YOU KNOW WHAT WE- THE PEOPLE
WANT TO SERVE ON THE BOARD
IT'S- IT'S A LIMITED GROUP OF
PEOPLE. OTHER THAN WE THINK
IT'S NICE WHAT WOULD BE THE
NEED FOR ME OR MY COLLEAGUES IN
THE SENATE PICKING SOMEBODY TO
SIT ON THIS BOARD. OTHER THAN.
YOU KNOW A POWER TRIP. I'M I
THINK IN RESPONSE TO THE THAT'S
THE FIRST QUESTION ABOUT THE
REPORTING- WE FIND THAT IN THE
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE THAT
THERE'S A REQUIREMENT FOR THE
NEW BOARD TO REPORT TO THE
SECRETARY OF COUNTY PA- WE
THINK THAT REPORTING A CRIME IS
GOOD AND NEEDED BUT- AT THE
SAME TIME TO INCREASE
LEGISLATIVE ORDER OVERSIGHT
THAT THIS- REPORT SHOULD ALSO
BE SENT TO THE LEGISLATURE. SO
CAN BE REVIEWED BY THEM- AND AT
THE SAME TIME THAT IT SENT TO
BOTH EQUALLY- IN RESPONSE TO
THE SECOND COMMENT YOU MADE
ABOUT- APPOINTMENTS- WE THINK
THAT THE LEGISLATURE HAVING THE
ABILITY TO. APPOINT ITS OWN
MEMBERS AND ALSO HAVE THE
APPOINTED BY MEMBERS GOT THEIR
SENATE CONFIRMATION PROCESS.
IT'S JUST ANOTHER AVENUE FOR
THE LEGISLATURE DEPRIVE PROVIDE
OVERSIGHT. AND NO
ACCOUNTABILITY AND TRANSPARENCY
HAVE BEEN AN IMPORTANT ISSUE
FOR THE LEGISLATURE IN TERMS
OF. ESTABLISHING THIS BOARD AND
FOR THE JUST THE GREATER REFORM
OF PTSD. SO HAVING THOSE
APPOINTED BOARD MEMBERS WOULD
HAVE THE LEGISLATURE ANOTHER
OPPORTUNITY TO INCREASE ITS
OVERSIGHT AND ACCOUNTABILITY OF
THE DEPARTMENT BY ENSURING
THAT. THE BOARD MEMBERS THAT
ARE IMPORTANT NOT ONLY REFLECT
THE GOVERNOR'S- USE AS WELL BUT
ALL LET. ISSUES ON ON HOW THE
BOARD SHOULD BE AROUND AND WE
FEEL THAT. A SECOND WHERE
MEMBERS A BIG PROCESS OF THAT
RIGHT. I GUESS THE CONCERN THAT
I HAVE IS THAT. I WANT I WANT
DIRECTOR WILLIAMS TO REPORT TO
ME- WHAT DTS HE IS DOING AND
THEY WERE AND THE BENEFITS AND
THE PROGRESS THAT THEY'VE MADE
AND THE CITED THEY CLEANED UP.
AND I IF THERE'S A PROBLEM THAT
THEY'VE COME IN AND SAY WE
HAVEN'T CLEANED UP ANY SIDE TO
IT AND THERE'S- AND WE'VE HAD
SIX PUBLIC HEARINGS AND
EVERYBODY'S CRAP AND THAT'S
WHAT'S GOING ON. I SORT OF GET
THE IDEA THAT I DON'T NEEDED IN
A REPORT AYE SO. I'VE I'VE
HEARD IT THROUGH SO. IT'S A
IT'S- WE'LL WE'LL GET TO THAT
LET'S HAVE FINANCE- FINANCE. IF
YOU COULD ADDRESS. THE
REMEDIATE. FOR THE BENEFIT OF
HOUSING AND THAT REMEDIATION.
FOR THE PURPOSES JUST
REMEDIATION I MEAN THERE'S A
LOT OF SITES OUT THERE AND
WE'RE GOING TO. THIS FIRST
BATCH THERE'S THERE SEEMS TO BE
A- AN EMPHASIS ON. ON HOUSING
AND- THERE'S NO COMMUNICATION
OR MAYBE THERE IS YOU GONNA
TELL ME BETWEEN H. C. D. N. D.
T. S. C. NOT THE- NOT THE
GENERAL. THE OBVIOUS CONNECTION
BETWEEN THEM BUT THAT'S WHAT
THE- STAFF IN- THE L. A. O. HAS
RAISED. GOOD MORNING MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS ENTER MARCH OF
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE-
SPECIFICALLY TO THAT QUESTION
JERRY CASKEY I WOULD POINT OUT
THAT THE TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE
HAS A REQUIREMENT FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF TOXIC SUBSTANCES
CONTROL TO CONSULT WITH EACH CD
IN THE FORMULATION OF THE
GUIDELINES FOR THEIR GRANT
PROGRAM- AND THE DEPARTMENT IS
CURRENTLY WORKING WITH A CD AND
ORDERED TO- PRIOR. KRILLIN AREA
IDENTIFY SITES THAT WOULD MEET
HUD'S CRITERIA- LIKEWISE EACH
CITY ALSO HAS REQUIREMENTS AND
THEIR- PROPOSAL FOR A FIVE
HUNDRED. MILLION DOLLARS FOR
THEIR INFILL INFRASTRUCTURE
GRANT PROGRAM TO CONSULT WITH
THE GST TO MAKE SURE THAT THOSE
PROGRAMS ARE ALIGNED WITH-
AREAS WHERE THERE'S HIGH
HOUSING NEED. AND ALSO THEY'RE
CONTAMINATED SITES BUT DOESN'T
MEAN MAYBE DIRECTOR WILLIAMS
WHEN YOU GOT TO CLEAN THE SITE
SOMETIMES IT BECOMES
ECONOMICALLY PROHIBITIVE TO GET
IT TO. YOU KNOW- DID WE CAN
HAVE BABIES PLAYING IN THERE
AND THERE IN THE LAWN IN FRONT
THEIR HOUSE PURSES IT BECOMES
AN INDUSTRIAL SITE CLEAN VERSES
IT BECOMES A COMMERCIAL SITE I
MEAN. IS THAT IF YOU'RE
THINKING THAT. IF HCD SAYS THIS
IS A UNIQUELY POSITIVE SITE FOR
HOUSING IT'S. GREAT AND THE
CLEAN UP IS AN- RIFIC THAT THAT
YOU WOULD SAY. WE IDENTIFY THEM
ON JUST SORT OF AFTER WE DO THE
INITIAL ASSESSMENT OF WHAT WE
THINK. IS NEEDED TO BE DONE
BECAUSE NOT ALL SITES ARE NOT
ALL CREATED EQUAL IS THAT YOUR
THINKING. I'LL START ON MY
ANSWER AND I'M GOING TO TURN
OVER SHOULD YOU FRIENDS CHIEF
DEPUTY DIRECTOR MEMORY BECAUSE
SHE'S BEEN MORE INVOLVED IN THE
CONVERSATIONS WITH EACH CITY
ALIGNMENT BUT I WILL SAY THAT-
WE'VE BEEN LISTENING TO
STAKEHOLDERS ABOUT WHAT THEY
WANT TO SEE IN THIS AND THERE
BEEN A RANGE OF THINGS PEOPLE
WANT PARKS PEOPLE WANT TO YOU
KNOW A LOT OF DIFFERENT
FUNCTIONS SO FIGURING OUT THE
APPROPRIATE CLEAN UP- STANDARD
TO PROVIDE ADEQUATE SAFETY IS
GOING TO BE CRITICAL CROSS THE
BORDER NO MATTER NO MATTER
WHAT. THE CASE AND OF COURSE.
WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO DO HERE IS
TO A ADVANTAGE OF ECONOMIES OF
SCALE THERE COULD BE CASES
WHERE THERE ARE MULTIPLE
CONTAMINATED SITES THAT. IN IN
A GENERAL AREA AND WE MAY WANT
TO FOCUS ON THOSE AND THAT
COULD MAYBE DRIVE UP THE COST
FOR ONE PARTICULAR SITE. OR
MAYBE THERE'S ONE THAT HAS MORE
CONTAMINATION AND MAKES THINGS
MORE COMPLEX BUT THE OVERALL
BENEFIT- OF DOING THAT KIND OF
COORDINATION COULD LEAD TO MUCH
BETTER OUTCOMES. FRANCESCA'S
SURE I AM I THINK THINK YOU THE
QUESTION BY JUST TO ADD THAT WE
HAVE PART REGARD. WITH AND
HOUSING AND COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT SURE THAT WERE-
WILL BE WORKING WE ARE HAVE
BEEN AND WILL BE BANNED PARTY
WITH THEM CLOSELY TO IDENTIFY
THOSE AREAS WITH HIGH HOUSING
NEEDS- AND- AND THOSE
VULNERABLE COMMUNITY SAID. THAT
THAT WE'VE IDENTIFIED IS IN THE
TOP 25% OF THEM VIRUS SCREEN
SO. AND THERE IS A FOCUSED- YOU
KNOW THERE'S IT ACCORDED EFFORT
TO FOCUS ON ON THESE AREAS FOR
THE BROWNFIELD SITES- EXISTING
ON AND THEN TO EXACTLY WHAT.
THE DOCTOR SAID WHICH IS TO USE
A CONDOM USE OF SCALE AND USE
WHAT WE KNOW ABOUT SOME OF
THESE SITES AND WE HAVE SOME
ORPHAN SITES WHERE WE ALREADY
HAVE BEEN IN PROGRESS YOU WILL
FORCE WHEN YOU GET THOSE ACROSS
THE FINISH LINE WITH SOME OF
THE SPENDING- SO. I THINK IT'S-
IT'S A COMPLICATED- PROJECT TO
BE SURE- AND COORDINATION WILL
BE ABSOLUTELY NECESSARY AND
WE'VE ALREADY STARTED THAT
PROCESS. YEAH BECAUSE I THINK
YOU KNOW THERE'S I MEAN WHEN
YOU HAVE THE SIX PUBLIC
HEARINGS OR WHEN THE BOARD AS
YOU SIX PUBLIC HEARINGS YOU
GUYS HAVE YOUR OWN I MEAN.
EVERYBODY HAS A DIFFERENT LEVEL
OF CLEANLINESS AND IN ONE OF
THE THINGS IS THAT IT SEEMS TO
US IS THE LEGISLATURE WE WANT
TO GET IT SO THAT IT'S SAFE
WHETHER IT'S SAFE ENOUGH TO
BUILD HOUSING ON IT. OR SAFE
ENOUGH FOR A DEPARTMENT STORE
IF WE EVER BILL THE DEPARTMENT
STORE NOW BECAUSE EVERYBODY'S
ONLINE BUT WHATEVER WHATEVER
YOU USE IS GOING TO BE THOSE
ARE THOSE ARE. VERY DIFFERENT
OF THEM- FIRST THE SIGN OFF ON
THEM. I WITH THE SEC. RIGHT IT.
IN AND IN ADDITION TO. THE
COLLABORATION THAT WE- ARE
ENGAGING AND WITH OUR OUR OUR
LOCAL AND STATE PARTNERS WILL
ALSO BE CONTINUING TO CONDUCT
LISTENING SESSIONS WITH THE
COMMUNITIES THAT ARE- IN THESE
AREAS AS WELL TO GET THEIR FEET
BACK ON. YOU KNOW- WHAT THE-
YOU KNOW WHAT THE ULTIMATE
DECISIONS WILL BE FOR THE USE
OF THAT PROPERTY AND- AND THAT
IN THE FUTURE. YOU KNOW HOUSING
NEEDS THAT ARE EXISTING THOSE
COMMUNITIES YEAH I MEAN THEY
ALEJO ONCE THE LEGISLATIVE
PRIORITIES TO RECEIVE THE
HIGHEST THE HIGHEST ATTENTION
RIGHT AND- HELP TARGET THESE
THINGS AND THIS IS. THREE
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS ONLY GO
SO FAR IT SOUNDS LIKE A LOT OF
MONEY FOR THE PUBLIC OUT THERE
BUT BUT WHEN YOU'RE TALKING
ABOUT ALL THESE CONTAMINATED
SITES YOU COULD BURN THROUGH
THIS THOUGH RATHER QUICKLY- AND
HOPEFULLY WE GET THE- THE FUN
STABILIZER THAT WE CAN. I DON'T
KNOW IF IT'S GOING TO GENERATE
IT'S NOT GENERATING THAT TYPE
BUT GO TO DO THE BROWN FEELS
BUT AT LEAST HE GETS ITS- GETS
OUR ATTENTION THERE. ALL RIGHT.
FINANCE YOU HAVE ANYTHING ELSE
YOU WANT TO. I'M SORRY SHARE I
WOULD JUST. ADD THAT- YOU KNOW
ALTHOUGH THAT THE GENERAL FUND
IS IN A HEALTHY CONDITION THIS
YEAR- I'M GOING HEALTH OF THE
GENERAL FUND IS STILL A CONCERN
FOR THE ADMINISTRATION AND-
INCLUDING THE AMOUNTS THAT ARE
PROPOSED THIS YEAR- THE GENERAL
FUND WELL PROVIDED AROUND
NINETY MILLION DOLLARS TO BACK
FILL DGSE SPECIAL FUNDS I WHICH
SEVENTY MILLION DOLLARS IS
BASICALLY- FUNDING THAT SHOULD
HAVE BEEN PROVIDED BY-
HAZARDOUS WASTE GENERATORS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE. AND THEN
TO THE ALEJO'S POINT ABOUT
SEPARATING THE THREE HUNDRED
MILLION FROM THE OVERALL FEAR
PROPOSAL WE JUST POINT OUT THAT
IF THE THREE HUNDRED MILLION A
SEPARATED FROM THE FEE
PROPOSAL. THAT THE THREE
HUNDRED MILLION WOULD HAVE TO
BE IS FOR ADDITIONAL STAFF
COSTS THAT ARE CURRENTLY BUILT
INTO THE PROPOSAL IS BEING
FUNDED FROM THE TOXIC
SUBSTANCES CONTROL ACCOUNT. AND
BUDGET YOUR PLUS ONE ONGOING.
YEAH THERE'S SOME MAGIC TECH
KEEPING THINGS TOGETHER-
DIRECTOR WILLIAMS. DID YOU HAVE
ANYTHING TO ADD. WE JUST WANTED
TO EMPHASIZE THE IMPORTANCE OF
MAKING SURE THE CLEANUP
STANDARDS ARE FIT FOR PURPOSE.
WE HAVE BEEN VERY FOCUSED ON
CLEAN UP AND THAT MEANS
RESIDENTIAL STANDARDS ARE. THE
MOST LIKELY CLEANUP STANDARDS
THAT WE'RE GONNA BE POINT TO.
THAT AS WE IMPLEMENT THIS WORK
AND I JUST WANT TO HIGHLIGHT
THAT BECAUSE I KNOW THIS IS.
ALWAYS A CONCERN HE'S REALLY
STATE THESE ARE THESE ARE
COMMUNITIES THAT HAVE OTHER
POLLUTION BURDEN FOR LAST THING
YOU WANT TO START. YOU KNOW PUT
A NICE SHINY BALL ON SOMETHING
THAT'S REALLY HARMFUL AND SO. I
JUST WANTED TO UNDERSCORE THAT
PARTICULAR. IT'S NICE KNOW THAT
WE'RE HAVING THIS OR GETTING
DOWN TO THE MINUTIA ON WHETHER
THE REPORT SHE GO TO THE
SECRETARY OF EPA OR TO COME TO
US I MEAN THAT'S- IF THAT'S OUR
BIGGEST DIFFERENCE THAN THAT
YOU KNOW- I'M I'M- I'M FEELING-OKAY. ABOUT THAT ARE ARE ONE OF
THE DIFFERENCES- LET'S SEE.
KALRA WHO- MR SECRETARY I SEE
YOUR HAND UP I GOT TO PAY
ATTENTION AND HANDS ALL RIGHT.
PLEASE I THANK YOU CHAIR- JUST
THREE THINGS THAT THAT IT HAD
AS WE ARE TALKING- I'VE HAD
DISCUSSIONS WITH LA UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT THAT BASIC
POINT IS THE ONLY REMAINING
PLACES FOR THEM TO BUILD NEW
SCHOOLS ARE BROWN KILLS THE
CURRENTLY NOT CLEANED UP SO
JUST TO SHOW YOU THAT. THE
SCALE WITHIN THAT- VERY VERY
LARGE METROPOLIS LIKE LA THE
OPPORTUNITIES STILL IF YOU WANT
IF YOU WANT TO BUILD A NEW
SCHOOL IS GOING TO HAVE TO BE
ON A BROWNFIELD. WE'LL HAVE
PARTLY IN THE SHADOW OF WHAT'S
BEEN HAPPENING ON EXIDE- AND
THAT COSTS ARE ASTRONOMICAL- IF
WE DON'THAVE THE
ACCOUNTABILITY MEASURES AND AT
A FUNCTIONING DGSE THAT CAN
HOLD. POLLUTERS ACCOUNTABLE I'M
SO MAKING SURE ALL THAT THAT WE
HAVE THAT STRUCTURE IN PLACE.
IS GOING TO ULTIMATELY SAVES
HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
TO THE STATE AND THAT TO
ANGIE'S POINT. AT DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE AND- AT THE MOMENT WAS
SUBSIDIZING INDUSTRY. I'M IN
THIS INTERVENING PERIOD SO THAT
THEY REALLY IS ADAM C. TO
GETTING THIS DONE AND THEN. THE
FINAL THING THAT I'LL SAY SOME
OF THESE. YEAH WE HAVE AS A
STATE UNFORTUNATELY DECIDED TO
NOT LOOK BECAUSE WE DIDN'T HAVE
THE MONEY TO PAY FOR THE
CLEANUP SAYS. YEAH THE NUMBER
OF A HUNDRED AND FIFTY THOUSAND
IS IT'S ASTRONOMICAL I'M- BUT
JUST TO GIVE YOU AN EXAMPLE
FROM THE SACRAMENTO AREA- I'M
OUT AND MINE. THE CLEANUP COSTS
TO DATE HAS BEEN SIX HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS IT WAS DUMPING
A TON OF ACID MINE DRAINAGE
INTO THE SACRAMENTO RIVER EVERY
SINGLE DAY SO WE HAVE A WET CAT
OUT FOR US AND I JUST WANTED TO
ADD CHAD TO WHAT YOU WAS SAYING
WHICH IS. WE ARE
EXTRAORDINARILY CLOSE TOGETHER-
THE DIFFERENCES BETWEEN US ARE
RESOLVABLE. IN IN MINUTES WEEKS
AND REALLY A TEST TO THE SIDES
COMING. OUR FRIENDS IN ASSEMBLY
TO YOU'LL- AB CHAD AND TO THE
DTS SEEING ARE TEAM AND- EVEN
JUST LOOKING THE L. A. O. WANT
TO GIVE COME. TO THE L. A. O.
YOU KNOW MOSTLY WHAT WE COME IN
WE SEE THE A. RIVER. THERE'S
ALSO A LOT OF HAS BEEN. IN
PRACTICE DALY BETWEEN US I WAS
NINETY MY HEAD YEAH. THIS IS.
MAINLY MAKING SENSE MAINLY IN
CONCURRENT SO. WITH THIS MUCH
AGREEMENT- I THINK WE NEED TO
GET THIS OVER THE FINISH LINE
AND ANYTHING THAT I CAN
PERSONALLY DO ALL WE- IN THE
ADMINISTRATION CAN DO TO
SUPPORT THAT EFFORT IN THE
LEGISLATURE. WE HAD WE HAD TO
DO. YEAH APPROVE THE- APPROVED
THE STRUCTURAL CHANGES TO THAT
THE FEES APPROVED THE OVERSIGHT
NAY ABILITIES THE BOARD TO
GRAPH THE ADJUSTMENTS. APPROVE
THE MONEY RIGHT NOW IT'S A IT'S
A VERY GOOD I HAVE NO OTHER
MEMBERS IN THE ROOM- CENTER
STERN I DON'T SEE YOUR. HE'S
VERY AND I SEE THAT YOU THE
HERE WELCOME GOOD MORNING- I
HAVE NOTHING ELSE IF ANYBODY-
HAS NOTHING TO ADD I WILL DO MY
BEST TO- GET THIS ACROSS THE
FINISH LINE FOR OFFICE HE SAID
THIS IS A GOOD PLACE TO BE. IS
A GOOD PLACE TO BE- I'M ALMOST
PREPARE TO DO IT TODAY BUT I
WON'T- WE WILL. WE WILL- WE'LL
WAIT. AND CENTER STERN YOUR
RECOGNIZE. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN I WAS JUST GOING TO
ADD. AND LIGHT OF THE TESTIMONY
RECEIVED TODAY AND ALL THE
WONDERFUL STAFF WORK AT THE
ADMINISTRATIVE LEVEL AND WE
JUST WITH OUR LEGISLATIVE STAFF
HERE THAT. I'LL I'LL TAKE SOME
OF THAT BURDEN WITH YOU- WE
HAVE TO GET THIS DONE THIS
YEAR. AND- IF WE CAN'T AFFORD
TO WAIT. THIS IS THE YEAR TO
FINALLY TACKLE THESE ISSUES AND
SO- STANDING WITH YOU SEE NOT
TO TAKE THIS ALL ON YOUR OWN.
READY TO GO SO THANK YOU. THANK
YOU THANK YOU FOR THE TESTIMONY
WE WILL. OPEN IT LEAVE IT OPEN
LEAVE THE MATTER OPEN WILL HAVE
COMMENTS AT THE END FOR PEOPLE
ON ON THE PUBLIC COMMENTS SO I
APPRECIATE YOUR TIME WILL MOVE
ON TO ISSUE NUMBER TWO. WHICH
WILL BE. THE SENATE BUDGET PLAN
ON DROUGHT SAFE DRINKING WATER
WATER SUPPLY RELIABILITY. AND
REPAIR ASSISTANCE. AND WE HAVE
MISTER BROWN FROM THE L. A. O.
TO- WITH RESOURCES I'M SORRY-
MANAGER JONES. ARE YOU HERE.
YES GOOD MORNING MISTER RIDE
SHARE AND MEMBERS JEANINE
JOHNSON DROUGHT MANAGER FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF WATER RESOURCES
WE HAVE A BACKGROUND POWER
POINT FOR YOU TODAY I WOULD
LIKE YOU TO WALK YOU THROUGH ON
THE- AND NATURAL RESOURCES
AGENCIES REPORT TO THE
LEGISLATURE ON OUR LAST DROUGHT
AND THE LESSONS THAT WE LEARNED
FROM THAT. SO IF WE ARE READY
TO GO I WILL- DIVE INTO THAT
OKAY. PLEASE. OKAY SELL- WE
WERE PREVIOUSLY DIRECTED TO
PROVIDE THIS REPORT TO THE
LEGISLATURE ON THE LESSONS THAT
WE LEARNED FROM OUR LAST
DROUGHT AND AS BACKGROUND
DROUGHTS ARE NOT A NEW THING IN
CALIFORNIA IT'S A RECURRING
FEATURE OF OUR CLIMATE SYSTEM
AND WE'VE HAD QUITE A BIT OF
EXPERIENCE WITH THEM OUR LAST
STATEWIDE DROUGHT A
SIGNIFICANCE WAS RELATIVELY
RECENT. TWENTY TWELVE TO TWENTY
SIXTEEN AND IN THIS DROUGHT WE
HAD A COUPLE OF WATER YEARS IN
PARTICULAR THAT WERE REALLY-
QUITE HYDROLOGICALLY SEVERE AND
POINTED OUT THAT WE ARE LOOKING
AT DOM. I. CHANGING CONDITION
WITH RESPECT TO SEEING THE
INFLUENCE OF WARMING
TEMPERATURES SUCH AS RECORD LOW
SNOWPACK IN A WILDFIRE SEASON
THAT IS NOW ARE BECOMING ALMOST
YEAR ROUND THAT DROUGHT WAS
ALSO CHARACTERIZED BY FIRST
TIME EVER ZERO ALLOCATIONS TO
THE BUREAU OF RECLAMATION
CENTRAL VALLEY PROJECT
AGRICULTURAL CUSTOMERS IN THE
SACRAMENTO AND SAN JOAQUIN
VALLEYS WHICH CREATED A LOT OF
ADDITIONAL GROUNDWATER PUMPING-
CAUSING SIGNIFICANT LANDSLIDES
AFFECTING SOME OF OUR WATER
SUPPLY INFRASTRUCTURE AND ALSO-
CAUSING A LOT OF WATER RIGHTS
ADMINISTRATION CHALLENGES FOR
OUR COLLEAGUES AT THE STATE
WATER RESOURCES CONTROL BOARD
BECAUSE NATURAL FLOWS. WERE SO
LOW AT THE TIME. SO WE LOOK AT
AS DIRECTED IN THE LEGISLATION
THE NUMBER OF- AREAS THAT WERE
AFFECTED BY THE DROUGHT AND
SOME OF THE THINGS. WE DID
DURING THIS DROUGHT REFLECTING
THE MAJOR FUNDING PROVIDED BY
THE LEGISLATURE TO RESPOND TO
DROUGHT CONDITIONS THIS WAS THE
SECOND TIME THAT WE HAD A
STATEWIDE PROCLAMATION OF
DROUGHT EMERGENCY. AND ALSO THE
VERY FIRST TIME THAT THE STATE
REQUIRED MANDATORY URBAN WATER
USE REDUCTIONS ALSO THE FIRST
TIME THAT WE HAD WIDESPREAD
STATE ASSISTANCE FOR SOCIAL
SERVICES IMPACTS RELATED TO
DROUGHT ESPECIALLY THOSE
RELATING FROM THE LOSS OF
AGRICULTURAL JOBS. IN THE US
CENTRAL VALLEY AND THE IMPACT
OF THAT ON COMMUNITIES THAT
WERE VERY DEPENDENT ON
AGRICULTURAL EMPLOYMENT. SO I
AS IS NORMAL WHEN WE HAVE MULTI
YEAR DROUGHTS WE SEE RESPONSE
ACTIONS ONE THE VERY
SIGNIFICANT ONES IN THE LAST
ROUTE WAS THE ENACTMENT OF THE
SUSTAINABLE GROUNDWATER
MANAGEMENT ACT OR SIGMA WHICH
REQUIRES. THAT LOCAL AGENCIES
BRING GROUNDWATER BASINS INTO
LONG TERM SUSTAINABLE
CONDITIONS AS WELL AS NEW
REQUIREMENTS FOR WATER
CONSERVATION AND IMPORTANTLY
BEGINNING TO ADDRESS SOME OF
THE CHALLENGES FACED BY THE
SMALL WATER SYSTEMS. AND DATA
COMMUNITIES THAT RELY ON
PRIVATE WELLS WHO ARE AFFECTED
EARLIEST AND NORMALLY TO THE
GREATEST EXTENT BY DROUGHT OUR
LARGE URBAN WATER PURVEYORS-
TEND TO HAVE THE RESOURCES AND
THE CAPACITY TO DO- WELL AND
PREPARE FOR MULTI YEAR
DROUGHTS. THAT IS NOT THE SAME
THING FOR THE SMALL SYSTEM
WORLD AND OUR COLLEAGUES AT THE
STATE WATER RESOURCES CONTROL
BOARD HAVE BEEN IMPLEMENTING
SOME OF THE- YOU PROVISIONS
PROVIDED BY THE LEGISLATURE TO
DEAL WITH THAT INCLUDING THE
FUNDING PROVIDED THROUGH THE
SAFER. ACT AND THE USE OF
MANDATORY CONSOLIDATION
AUTHORITY TO CONNECT US
STRUGGLING SMALL SYSTEMS OR
GROUPS OF DISADVANTAGED JOB
PRIVATE WELL OWNERS FOR EXAMPLE
TO PUBLIC WATER SYSTEMS. ARE
SOME OF THE LESSONS THAT WE
LEARNED IN THE LAST DROUGHT.
BIG LESSON WAS TO BEGIN TO SOON
IN IS SLOW A CONDITION AS
COMPARED TO THINGS LIKE
EARTHQUAKES OR WILDFIRES AND IT
PROVIDES A LONG LEAD TIME FOR
STATE THE AGENCY RESPONSE
ACTIONS THESE ACTIONS TEND TO
TAKE TIME BECAUSE THEY INVOLVE
THINGS LIKE- CONTRACTING FOR
RESOURCES PROVIDING FINANCIAL
ASSISTANCE COULD TO
COMMUNITIES. ON DOING THE LONG
TERM PLANNING TO ADMINISTER
WATER RIGHTS THOSE KINDS OF
THINGS AND WE'VE IDENTIFIED A
NUMBER OF THINGS THAT WE ARE
ALREADY PUTTING INTO PRACTICE
AS WE LOOK AT THE DRY
CONDITIONS THAT WE ARE SEEING
NOW. SO CERTAINLY THE WATER
RESILIENCE PORTFOLIO SPEAKS TO
THE ART LONG TERM IMPROVEMENT
ACTIVITIES FOR- WATER SUPPLY
AND DROUGHT RESILIENCE
CONDITIONS ALSO TALKING ABOUT
THE PROGRESS IN OTHER AREAS
SUCH AS- UP REPAIRED MISSED FOR
WILDFIRE AND LOOKING AT THINGS
THAT THE DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND
WILDLIFE HE CAN DO TO BETTER BE
PREPARED TO HELP WITH THE
ECOLOGICAL CONDITIONS. SO-
AMONG OUR MAJOR RECOMMENDATIONS
FROM INVESTING IN IMPROVING OUR
DATA INPUT AND FORECASTING
INFRASTRUCTURE. ONE OF THE-
LESSONS THAT WE'VE SEEN IN
PRIOR DROUGHTS IS THIS ISSUE OF
FUN. THE IMPORTANCE OF HAVING
LONGER LEAD TIME TO RESPOND AND
YOU GET THAT LONGER LEAD TIME
BY IMPROVING FORECASTING. ALSO
MAKING ADVANCE- MAKING
IMPROVEMENTS IN OUR OUTREACH
COMMUNICATIONS ACTIVITIES AND
IMPORTANTLY SOME OF THE WORK
THAT CAL FIRE HAS DONE IN
PARTNERING WITH THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT TO ADDRESS FOREST
MANAGEMENT CONDITIONS. ON NOW
THE FEDERAL LANDS WHICH MAKE UP
SO MUCH OF OUR WATERSHEDS IN
CALIFORNIA. SO WHERE ARE WE
TODAY WELL I HATE TO SAY IT'S
LOOKING LIKE DEJA VU ALL OVER
AGAIN BUT WE ARE HAVING VERY
DRY CONDITIONS RIGHT NOW. THE
IS PURSE.
OF AVERAGE. SO WE ARE
YOU KNOW EXPECTING TO SEE SOME
SIMILAR CONDITIONS AS WE
EXPERIENCED THEM. AND IN TERMS
OF OUR CURRENT RESPONSE TO
DROUGHT CONDITIONS WE ARE-
RAMPING UP SOME ACTIVITIES THAT
WE HAD IDENTIFIED AS THE THINGS
THAT WE SHOULD BE DOING AND
THEN HE BOB PRIOR DROUGHT AND
AT THIS POINT I WOULD. LIKE TO
TURN THIS OVER TO MY TWO
COLLEAGUES FROM THE WATER BOARD
WHO ARE ALSO ON THIS ZOOM
MEETING AND ASK IF THEY WOULD
LIKE TO SPEAK ABOUT THEIR-
LESSONS LEARNED WITH RESPECT TO
WATER RIGHTS ADMINISTRATION
AND- DRINKING WATER ESPECIALLY
FOR ROCK. OF SMALL COMMUNITIES.
SURE I CAN JUMP IN FIRST THANK
YOU I'M I WISH THE NEWS WERE
BETTER BUT THANK YOU FOR THE
FOR COMPLETE REPORT. YES
CHAMPION. YES ON THEIR PLANES
ON W. DIRECTOR FOR THE DIVISION
OF DRINKING WATER I JUST WANTED
TO HIGHLIGHT SOME OF THE EARLY
ACTIONS WERE TAKING- TO TRY TO
GET A HANDLE ON WORKING WATER
SYSTEMS ARE AT. AS A MISS JONES
MENTIONED IT REALLY IS-
IMPORTANT TO UNDERSTAND THAT
THIS IS LARGELY ENDS UP BEING A
SMALL SYSTEM IMPACT- THERE THE
LEAST ABLE TO TAKE THIS- IMPACT
ON ON TOP OF A- COVERED
FINANCIAL IMPLICATIONS- WE ARE
CONCERNED ABOUT WHERE THEY
PROCEED. WE ARE WORKING TO TRY
TO ADDRESS AND UNDERSTAND WHERE
WATER SYSTEMS ARE AT ONE OF THE
LESSONS LEARNED FROM THE LAST
DROUGHT WAS A LOT OF SMALL
WATER SYSTEMS DON'T ACTIVELY.
MONITOR THEIR WELL DEPTHS OR
THEIR INTAKE THE LEVEL OF THEIR
INTAKE AND RESERVOIRS WERE-
WORKING TO TRY TO MAKE SURE WE
SECURE THAT INFORMATION AND CAN
MONTEREY ALONG WITH THEM THAT
WE'RE PROCEEDING IN A WAY TO
UNDERSTAND. THAT THERE'S A
CRISIS COMING BEFORE WE GET THE
CALL AT FOUR THIRTY FRIDAY
AFTERNOON THAT THE OTHER OUT OF
WATER AND THEY YOU KNOW NEED
EMERGENCY ASSISTANCE FROM US OR
OTHERS TO TRY TO GET THEM BACK
IN. SERVICE AND WHAT START FROM
YOUR FROM YOUR PERSPECTIVE WHAT
IS THAT STARTED IN THE RAINY
SEASON'S OVER RIGHT SO WOULD
THAT BE. WITH THAT THEY WAIT
TILL JUNE TODAY START
MONITORING IMMEDIATELY I MEAN
WE'VE GOT. 50% LESS THAN 50%
WATER. PRECIPITATION NOT TO AND
YOU KNOW A LOT OF THE LAW
LEVELS TO RECOVER. THE DROUGHT
SO THERE ALREADY A STRESS
CONDITIONS THE MANTRA NEEDS TO
BEGIN NOW- AND THAT'S WHAT
WE'RE WORKING TOWARDS TRYING TO
MAKE SURE WE GATHER THAT
INFORMATION FROM THEM- AND MAKE
SURE THAT THEY ARE PERFORMED
THAT MONITORING SO THAT THEY'RE
ALSO AWARE. OF THEIR CURRENT
CONDITION. THE OTHER THING I'D
LIKE TO MENTION AS WELL IS
THAT. A LOT OF OUR WATER
SYSTEMS HAVE BACKUP SUPPLIES-
IN IN RECENT TIMES AS MANY OF
THOSE SUPPLIES WERE WELL THAT
WERE ACTIVE BUT THEY TOOK. OFF
OF ACTIVE STATUS DUE TO. WATER
QUALITY CONTAMINATION FROM. ONE
TWO THREE T. C. P. OR FROM P.
BASS COMPOUNDS THAT WE'RE NOW
FINDING. IN MANY OF OUR
SOURCES. AND SO WHAT WE WANT TO
WORK WITH WATER SYSTEMS AS
WELL- WILL PRIORITIZE FROM OUR
ACTION. TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
ADDRESS IT IS MAKING SURE THAT
WE ARE ABLE TO- PERMIT US
SOURCES AND GET WATER QUALITY
TREATMENT ON THOSE SYSTEMS
BEFORE THEY ARE. NECESSARY TO
BRING BACK ON LINE. AND THAT
OBVIOUSLY INVOLVES INVESTMENT
ON THEIR PART AND OUR PART FROM
OUR FUNDING PROGRAMS. INTO A
PERMITTING ACTIVITY SO WE'RE
REACHING OUT TO THOSE SYSTEMS
WE NOW HAVE THAT. SCENARIO AND
MAKING SURE THAT THEY
PROGRESSED NOW IT'S YOU KNOW
CONSTRUCTION'S ALWAYS DIFFICULT
AND THE BEST OF TIMES IT'S
HORRIBLE. WHEN YOU'RE TRYING TO
RUSSIA AND WE KNOW MATERIALS
AND OTHER THINGS ARE DIFFICULT
TO FIND IN THE CURRENT
CONSTRUCTION ENVIRONMENT SO WE
NEED TO. MAKE SURE THE PEOPLE
WHO WATER SYSTEMS UNDERSTANDS.
IMPERATIVE TO BEGIN THAT ACTION
NOW. IN FINDING ALL MEANT IS A
WE'RE ALL TAKING EARLIEST TO
MAKE SURE WE WORK. WITH OUR
DIVISION OF WATER RIGHTS AS
THEY- RECEIVE INTO CARTEL MEN'S
LAST TIME THERE IN THE LAST
DROUGHT WE HAD TWENTY TWO WATER
SYSTEMS. WHERE WE ISSUED A
FOLLOW ON BUILDING MORATORIUM.
AFTER CURTAILMENT WAS ISSUE TO
MAKE SURE THAT THEY DIDN'T
CONTINUE TO ADD WATER DEMANDS
TO THEIR SYSTEM AS THEIR WATER
SYSTEM WAS CURTAILED. HOPEFULLY
ALL THE SYSTEMS OF NOW AND PART
OF ARE RELEASING HIM FROM THAT.
MORATORIUM WASN'T THEY DID
SECURE ADDITIONAL SUPPLIES AND
MOST OF THE WATER SYSTEMS WERE
ABLE TO. TO DO THAT WELL NOW
UNFORTUNATELY HAVE A CHANCE TO
TEST OUT HOW. HOW VIABLE AND
NOW WERE THEY ABLE TO GET THOSE
ALL IN PLACE- AS WE MOVE
FORWARD AND THAT'S A GOOD. HAND
UP POINT FOR- YEAH DIRECTOR
ACTOR. FOLLOWING ME FROM OUR
WATER RIGHTS DIVISION. THANKS
ALL AND HOPEFULLY EVERYONE CAN
HEAR ME THANK YOU FOR. HAVING
US HERE TODAY AND- THANK YOU
THE CHAIR AND OTHER MEMBERS MY
NAME IS ARGHA ACT ON THE W.
DIRECTOR FOR THE DIVISION OF
WATER RIGHTS AT THE STATE WATER
BOARD. AND THEY JUST WANT TO
FOLLOW UP TO BOTH WHAT JEAN
HIGHLIGHTED AS WELL AS
DIFFERENT- KIND OF ONGOING
LESSONS LEARNED AND CHALLENGES
FROM THE LAST DROUGHT JEAN
HIGHLIGHTED IN THE- POWER POINT
A NUMBER OF AREAS WHERE.
LOOKING AT KIND OF WHAT
HAPPENED DURING THE DROUGHT
THE- EXPERIENCE OF DOING
CURTAILMENTS IN THE FOURTEEN
FIFTEEN TIME PERIOD WE ISSUED
ABOUT NINE THOUSAND NOTICES OF
WATER UNAVAILABILITY TO. WATER
RIGHT HOLDERS THROUGHOUT THE
STATE. BY ANDY. THE EXPERIENCE
OF TRYING TO CALCULATE AND
DETERMINE WHEN THOSE CURTAILING
NOTICES WERE NEEDED. AND THEN
TRACKING AND KIND OF RESPONDING
TO THEM IN LOOKING AT. HOW WE
LOOK AT WATER AVAILABILITY KIND
OF IN GENERAL THROUGHOUT. LOTS
OF DIFFERENT WATER BASINS AND
WATERSHEDS IN THE STATE. WAS
EXTREMELY COMPLICATED AND
RELIED ON SOME OLDER AND OUT OF
DATE DATA. THE PRIOR TO SB
EIGHTY EIGHT WHICH WAS PASSED
IN IN TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN.
WATER DIVERTERS ONLY REPORTED
ABOUT ONCE EVERY THREE YEARS.
AND THEN THERE WERE SOME
CHANGES MADE DURING THE LAST
DROUGHT TO UPDATE THAT
FREQUENCIES NOW IT'S NEARLY.
BUT WE'RE STILL RELYING ON DATA
THAT SUBMITTED SOMETIMES
EIGHTEEN OR MORE MONTHS AFTER
THE FACT AND IT. THERE ARE SOME.
CHALLENGES IN THE STATE'S WATER
RATES DATA MANAGEMENT SYSTEM
HOW THAT INFORMATION IS
REPORTED HOW IT'S YOU A OR OR
QUALITY CHECKED ESSENTIALLY.
MAKES IT VERY DIFFICULT TO
RESPOND QUICKLY OR EVEN TRACK
WHERE WATER IS BEING USED ON A
THEY WERE CLOSE TO REAL TIME
BASIS AND WEBER FINDING DURING.
THIS YEAR AS WELL AS OTHER DRY
CONDITIONS IS THAT IT'S
IMPORTANT ACTUALLY TO TRACK
WHERE THINGS ARE GOING AND
WATER USE AND WATER
AVAILABILITY A MUCH MORE KIND
OF GRANULAR AN UP TO DATE TIME
FRAME. SOME OF THE LESSONS
LEARNED ARE THAT WE DO NEED
KIND OF INVESTMENTS IN. OUR
WATER RATES SYSTEM RIGHT NOW
THE- THE STATE'S WATER RATE
RECORDS ARE ALL HELD IN PAPER
FILES IN- A STORAGE ROOM IN THE
KELLY PA BUILDING IN
SACRAMENTO. AND SO VIEW THAT ON
ITS OWN RAISES CHALLENGES ABOUT
EVEN HOW STAFF CAN ACCESS THE
DATA PARTICULARLY DURING COPING
TIMES AND- OTHER PUBLIC ACCESS
IS THAT DATA AS WELL MAKES IT
JUST DIFFICULT TO REALLY
UNDERSTAND. WHO OWNS A WATER
RATE WHAT- WHAT RATE IS
AVAILABLE TO WHOM WHERE IT'S
BEING USED WHEN IT'S BEING
USED. AND HOW DO YOU INTEGRATE
THAT KIND OF A WATERSHED SCALE.
TO LOOK AT THINGS LIKE
VOLUNTARY APPROACHES TO BETTER
WATER MANAGEMENT OR GREATER
WATER EFFICIENCY. SO I THINK
WITH THAT ALL. OUR STUFF AND
HEADED BACK TO JUNIOR ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS. ONE WHEN WE HOLD
QUESTIONS FOR A SECOND AND
BEFORE I RECOGNIZE FINANCE I
WANT TO TAKE A- COUPLE MINUTE
BREAK- IF YOU GUYS CAN PAUSE
AND I'LL BE RIGHT BACK SO DON'T
GO ANYWHERE.
DO YOU THANK YOU
THANK YOU FOR YOUR INDULGENCE-
AND THANK YOU WATER RESOURCE
BOARD FINANCED YOU HAVE
ANYTHING ELSE YOU'D LIKE TO
HAVE BEFORE WE TURNED IT OVER
TO PRESENTATION TO THE L. L. DR
OUR DEPARTMENT FINANCE. I JUST
COUPLE POINTS I KNOW THE AGENDA
HAS A CHORE OF EXPENDITURES
MADE- APPROPRIATIONS MADE IN
THE LAST DROUGHT- JUST COUPLE
THINGS KNOW THAT. YOU KNOW SAID
SEN THE LAST RATHER HAVE BEEN
SIGNIFICANT- WATER
INFRASTRUCTURE INVESTMENT THAT
HE PRIMARILY THROUGH
PROPOSITION ONE AND PROPOSITION
SIXTY EIGHT WHICH YOU KNOW.
RIDER POSSIBLY SEVEN BILLION
DOLLARS IN DIFFERENT- WATER
PROJECT INVESTMENT- SENT THE-
MADE A LOT OF THINGS EVIDENCE
IN THEY BREAKING WATER AND I
THINK WITH A PASSAGE OF SB TWO
HUNDRED AND TWENTY NINETEEN
WAS. RIDING A HUNDRED THIRTY
MILLION DOLLARS- ONGOING
ANNUALLY. TO SUPPORT THAT
EFFORT. AND EVEN IN THE CURRENT
GOVERNMENT BUDGET THERE ARE
SOME ADDITIONAL INVESTMENT THAT
WE DO THINK THAT COULD SUPPORT
DURING- YOU KNOW DROUGHT TIMES
OTHER THING I'LL GIVE NO
QUICKLY IS YOU KNOW THE
GOVERNOR DID RECENTLY RELEASED-
I THINK I COULD HAVE ORDER ON
RALPH. AND PART OF THE DIRECTOR.
REYES TO WORK WITH THE
DEPARTMENT- TRY TO ACCELERATE-
FUNDING- WORK. REPURPOSE THE
SOME FIVE BOND FUNDING- WE KNOW
WHEN POSSIBLE AND AVAILABLE AND
ALSO LOOK AT POTENTIAL OTHER.
ADDITIONAL INVESTMENT IN THE IN
THE MAYOR VISION WHICH WE ARE
CURRENTLY WORKING THROUGH.
THANK YOU ABOUT THREE POINT
FOUR BILLION IN ONE YEAR BUT
THAT'S IT WAS HE WHO THERE IS-
NECESSARY INVESTMENTS WELL.
MISS EHLERS GOOD GOOD AFTERNOON
I GUESS IT IS WELCOME- IN.
PLEASE PROCEED WITH THE
PRESENTATION ON THE- THE SENATE
BUDGET PLAN ON DROUGHT AND SAFE
DRINKING WATER THANK YOU
SENATOR AND- AND MEMBERS NICE
TO SEE YOU GOOD AFTERNOON FOR
OUR RETAILERS WITH THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE-
IF I COULD I'LL JUST MAKE A
COUPLE QUICK COMMENTS AHEAD
BEFORE WE TALK ABOUT THE
PACKAGE MORE GENERALLY ON
DROUGHT AND WE KNOW THAT. THERE
IS A PACKAGE THAT YOU ARE
DISCUSSING TODAY BUT WE ALSO
KNOW THAT THE- NEGOTIATIONS
WILL CONTINUE IN DISCUSSIONS
WILL CONTINUE SAID JUST A FEW
POINTS WE THINK YOU MIGHT WANT
TO KEEP IN MIND AS THOSE
DISCUSSIONS CONTINUE- FIRST AS
THE ADMINISTRATION PRESENTED
THINGS ARE LOOKING PRETTY BAD-
THUS FAR. I DILIGENTLY- SO ONE
OF THE BIG LESSONS WE LEARNED
DURING THE LAST DROUGHT IS
THINKING ABOUT BEING PROACTIVE
RATHER THAN REACTIVE WE ARE
LUCKY THAT WE HAVE THESE
LESSONS LEARNED THAT SILVER
LINING I GUESS OF WHAT WE WENT
THROUGH A FEW YEARS AGO SO IT'S
GREAT THEY'RE HAVING THIS
DISCUSSION TODAY AND REALLY
THINKING STRATEGICALLY ABOUT
WHAT WE CAN DO TO GET AHEAD OF.
OF CONDITIONS ARE WORSENING. IF
YOU LOOK AT THAT CHART ON PAGE
TWENTY SIX OF YOUR AGENDA
YOU'LL SEE WE DID. SPEND THREE
POINT FOUR BILLION DOLLARS OVER
THAT FOUR YEAR PERIOD DURING
THAT THE LAST DROUGHT IN
DROUGHT RESPONSE. BUT YOU'LL
SEE THAT THE OF THE BOOK OF IT
WAS IN THAT FIRST CATEGORY
WATER SUPPLY THAT WAS MOSTLY
SUPPORTED BY BONDS. AND THOSE
ARE MOSTLY LONGER TERM-
PROJECTS SO THEY REALLY DIDN'T
RESPOND TO THAT. THE LAST
DROUGHT BECAUSE FUNDS TAKE
AWHILE TO GET OUT THE DOOR THE
PROJECTS TAKE A WHILE TO
FINANCE AND PERMIT AND SO
HOPEFULLY THOSE WILL HELP US IN
THIS NEW DROUGHT THAT WE'RE
FACING. BUT AS YOU THINK ABOUT
YOUR PACKAGE THINKING ABOUT
BALANCING KIND OF IMMEDIATE
NEAR TERM RESPONSE TO PRESSING
SITUATIONS AS COMPARED TO
LONGER TERM RESILIENCE BOTH ARE
IMPORTANT- BUT THOSE BIGGER
LONGER TERM PROJECTS WON'T
NECESSARILY ADDRESS IMMEDIATE
NEEDS. AND THEN ALSO GLAD LEASE
TO HAVE CONSIDERATIONS ABOUT
FUND SOURCE AND- AS I MENTIONED
YOU KNOW WE USE MOSTLY BOND.
AND MANY SUFFERED FOR THOSE BIG
PROJECTS LAST TIME AND THOSE
TAKE AWHILE WE REALLY DID RELY
ON GENERAL FUND AND IN SOME
CASES SPECIAL FUNDS FOR SOME OF
THOSE IMMEDIATE. EMERGENCY
RESPONSE WATER CONSERVATION
ENVIRONMENTAL PROTECTION.
ACTIVITIES YOU SEE IN THAT
CHART. AND ANOTHER THING THAT
ABOUT A BALANCE THE HUMOR NEED
OF DROUGHT IMPACTS AS WELL AS
THE ENVIRONMENTAL NEEDS THE
STATE IS RESPONSIBLE FOR
MANAGING PUBLIC TRUST RESOURCES
INCLUDING FISH AND WILDLIFE
AND- AND WATERWAYS. AND THOSE
THAT HAD SOME PRETTY
SIGNIFICANT IMPACTS DURING THE
LAST DROUGHT SO MAKING SURE AS
YOU'RE THINKING ABOUT
CONSTRUCTING ANY FUNDING
PACKAGE YOU'RE THINKING ABOUT
BOTH OF THOSE. CATEGORIES WE
NEED. AND THEN EVEN WITHIN THE
HUMAN NEEDS. I'M THINKING ABOUT
IN PARTICULAR VULNERABLE
COMMUNITIES THE LAST DURING THE
LAST DROUGHT AS WAS MENTIONED
RURAL FARM WORKER COMMUNITIES
REALLY- EXPERIENCE SOME VERY
SIGNIFICANT IMPACTS NOT ONLY
FROM FROM LOSS OF DRINKING
WATER BUT ALSO ECONOMIC IMPACTS
FROM LOSS OF JOBS FROM.
AGRICULTURAL AT PRODUCTION
SLOWDOWN SO THINKING ABOUT HOW
THE STATE CAN HELP THOSE. WHO
TO TARGET AID TO THOSE WHO
MIGHT NEED IT MOST. AND THEN
FINALLY AND WE THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT TO NOTE WE PUT OUT A
RECORD ABOUT TWO WEEKS AGO ON
THE STATE APPROPRIATIONS LIMIT.
WHICH IS THAT KIND OF A NEW
COMPLICATING FACTOR IS A FAR
STATE BUDGET PROCESS WASN'T
COMPLICATED ENOUGH NOW WE'VE
GOT A NEW FACTOR- THAT PROBABLY
IS GOING TO COME INTO PLAY AND-
PLAY SOME CONSTRAINTS ON ON
STATE SPENDING AND STATE
GENERAL FUND SPENDING PROCEEDS
OF TAXES. I'M NOT ONLY IN THE
COMING BUDGET BUT IN THE COMING
YEAR SO IT'S PRETTY TECHNICAL
AND WE COULD HAVE A LONG
CONVERSATION ABOUT I'M HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS OF MEMBERS
HAVE IT BUT WE JUST WANT TO
HAVE THAT ON YOUR RADAR AS
YOU'RE THINKING ABOUT. THE
PACKAGE THAT THERE IS THE KIND
OF THIS NEW LEVEL OF
COMPLICATION- AND THEN THERE
ARE SOME THINGS THAT COUNT
TOWARDS THE LIMIT AND SOMETIMES
OF EXPENDITURES THAT DON'T
COUNT SOWE'RE HAPPY TO WORK
WITH YOU AS YOU. WORK THROUGH
YOUR YEAR BUT OVERALL BUDGET
PACKAGE BUT THAT'S JUST
ANOTHER. ISSUE TO HAVE ON YOUR
RADAR I HAVE THATCOPY OF IT ON
MY DESK AND I HAVE CRACKED THE
SEAL ON IT BUT IT WAS A- IT'S
SPECIAL READING. SO BEFORE WE
GET INTO THE YOU KNOW BASICALLY
IF YOU LOOK IF YOU TAKE OUT THE
BOND MONEY FROM TWENTY THIRTEEN
TO TWENTY. SEVENTEEN FOR THOSE
FOUR YEARS WE PLAYED. SPENCER
NORTH OF BILLION. OVER EVERY.
OVER THE FOR YEARS WHICH IS A-
A QUARTER FOR THE- BILLION
DOLLARS. THIS IS TO BE TAKE OUT
TO. THE MONEY TO THE WATER JUST
SIX FOR THE- THE FEDERAL
FUNDING BUT WE'RE PUTTING
TOGETHER FEDERAL FUNDS. GENERAL
FUNDS AND- ANY SCRAPES OF MONEY
THAT'S LEFT FROM THE BONDS YOU
KNOW SIXTY EIGHT AND ONE. SO
THIS IS RICK THIS IS REAL MONEY
THIS IS NOT. MIDDLE PROBLEM AND
WE'RE GOING TO FINANCE IT SO
THAT'S- YOU GIVE ME SOME IDEA
OF THE OF THE IMPACT OF PAINT
SPENDING TWO HUNDRED FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS A YEAR AND TWO
HUNDRED AND- TWO POINT FIVE
BILLION. NOW OR IN A LOT ABOUT
THIS TEN TIMES AS MUCH FOR ALL
THESE THINGS THAT THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION HAS POINTED OUT
THAT WERE SORT OF LESSONS
LEARNED COMMUNITY. SEEMS LIKE A
GOOD IDEA. YEAH THERE ARE
CERTAINLY NEEDS CERTAINLY NEEDS
AND AGAIN ACTING EARLY AHEAD OF
WHEN- CONDITIONS WORSEN I
THINK- AGAIN EMPHASIZING HOW
MANY OF THE ACTIVITIES YOU WANT
TO FUND OUR KIND OF IMMEDIATE
AND WILL WILL MAKE A BIG
DIFFERENCE IN THE NEXT YEAR TO
VERSUS HOW MANY WILL MAKE A
DIFFERENCE IN THAT SUBSEQUENT
DRUG BOTH ARE IMPORTANT IT'S
JUST THINKING ABOUT WHAT ARE
THE AREAS OF FOCUS AND EVEN IF
YOU PUT ANOTHER IMPORTANT
CONSIDERATION IS EVEN IF YOU
PUT A LOT OF FUNDING OUT IN ONE
YEAR THAT DOESN'T NECESSARILY
MEAN IT WILL BE SPENT IN THAT
YOU'RE PARTICULARLY FOR SOME OF
THE LONGER TERM- PROJECTS SO
IT'S BALANCING KIND OF THAT
IMMEDIATE NEED. A LONGER TERM
NEED AND ALSO HOW WHAT TYPES OF
ACTIVITIES CAN BE IMPLEMENTED
ON A ON A QUICK BASIS VERSUS
THAT WILL TAKE LONGER. OKAY HI
CLIFFORD IT THOSE ARE. THREE
GENERAL. IDEAS TO KEEP IN MIND
ON ON DROUGHT. HELLO WHAT ARE
YOU PROCEED WITH THE MAIN
ATTRACTION- SO YES STAFF HAVE
ASKED US TO PRESENT THE
PROPOSAL BEFORE YOU JUST ONE OF
THEM REITERATE THIS IS NOT AN
ALLEY- PROPOSAL ARE IN LA-
PACKAGE WE ARE JUST BE I'M
SERVING AS YOUR STAFF TO
PRESENT SO IF THERE ARE
SPECIFIC QUESTIONS MEMBER HAVE
MEMBERS HAVE ABOUT THAT
PACKAGE- PROBABLY BEST TO
DIRECT THEM TOWARDS COMMITTEE
MEMBERS OR STAFF BUT I'M HAPPY
TO PRESENT. SO THE PACKAGE
BEFORE YOU IS THREE POINT FOUR-
ONE BILLION DOLLARS IN ONE TIME
STATE AND FEDERAL FUNDS AND
I'LL GO THROUGH THAT AT A HIGH
LEVEL THAT CATEGORIES ARE
THERE'S FIVE HUNDRED MILLION
FOR IMMEDIATE COMMUNITY
ASSISTANCE FOR WATER IN DROUGHT
RELIEF. FIVE HUNDRED MILLION
FOR EMERGENCY DROUGHT WATER USE
EFFICIENCY PROJECTS. THREE
HUNDRED AND FIFTY MILLION FOR
SUSTAINABLE GROUNDWATER
MANAGEMENT THAT WOULD BE GRANTS
TO IMPLEMENT THE SUSTAINABLE
PRODUCT GROUNDWATER MANAGEMENT
ACT SICK MATH AS WELL AS- FOR
SOME OTHER GROUND WATER RELATED
ACTIVITIES. TWO HUNDRED MILLION
FOR RESILIENT WATER
INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECTS. TWO
HUNDRED MILLION FOR RECYCLED
WATER PROJECTS. TWO HUNDRED
MILLION FOR STORM WATER
MANAGEMENT. TWO HUNDRED AND
EIGHTY FIVE MILLION FOR VARIOUS
ACTIVITIES THAT WOULD HELP
PROTECT FISH AND WILDLIFE FROM
DROUGHT IMPACTS. ONE HUNDRED
MILLION FOR WATER QUALITY
ACTIVITIES. SEVENTY FIVE
MILLION FOR VARIOUS- ACTIVITIES
TO IMPROVE WATER DATA AND
FORECASTING. AND THEN ONE
BILLION DOLLARS IN FEDERAL
FUNDS TO HELP REPAIRS COMMUNITY
WATER SYSTEMS WASTEWATER
TREATMENT WORKS AND PUBLIC
UTILITIES RECOVER FROM THE
IMPACTS OF THE FAT COATED-
PANDEMIC COULD NINETEEN
PANDEMIC. I AND THEN FINALLY
THE PACKAGE ALSO INCLUDES
LANGUAGE TO ACCELERATE
APPROPRIATION OF EXISTING WATER
BOND PRIORITIES FROM
PROPOSITION ONE AND PROPOSITION
SIXTY EIGHT WHERE FUNDS ARE
AVAILABLE AND DEMAND IS HIGH.
AND ALSO TO URGE THE WATER
COMMISSION TO CONVENE AND
REALLOCATE ONE HUNDRED FORTY
FIVE MILLION IN EXISTING
PROPOSITION ONE FUNDS THAT WERE
ORIGINALLY SET ASIDE FOR THE
TEMPERANCE FLAT DAM TO USE FOR
OTHER SUSTAINABLE WATER STORAGE
INVESTMENTS IN THE CENTRAL
VALLEY. AND WE SHOULD BE CLEAR
THAT THAT THAT IS HIS IS A
SUGGESTION FOR THE MEMBERS OF
THE WATER BOARD WHEN THEY
RECONVENE IT'S NOT AT THAT IS
NOT TO BE INTERPRETED THE
BUDGET ITEM PER SE- AND JUST.
WE KNOW THAT THERE'S MONEY
SITTING THERE. WHAT DO WE GET
TO ASK QUESTIONS IN OR LATER
WOULD. LET HER GET THROUGH OKAY.
AND THAT CONCLUDES THE
PRESENTATION OF THE PACKAGE.
CENTER DOLLY. THANK YOU GOOD TO
BE ABLE TO PARTICIPATE TODAY.
OKAY SO I HAVE A SO I AS
SOMEBODY WHO- PARTICIPATED IN
PROP ONE AND NEGOTIATED HEAVILY
TO GET THE BILL ACTUALLY OUT OF
OFF THE FLOOR TO GET IT TOO-
THE OPPORTUNITY TO HAVE A VOTE
ON. WE LOOKED. AT TEMPERANCE
FLAT WE LOOKED AT- SITES
RESERVOIR AND HERE WE ARE NOW
SIX YEARS LATER AND- YOU KNOW
WE'RE STILL NOT DOING THOSE
PROJECTS AS WERE SOLD TO THE
VOTERS- AS- BASICALLY EARMARKS
IN THOSE PIECES OF LEGISLATION
THAT WOULD THEY THEY WERE
PRIORITY THAT WE HAD WE HAD TO
SELL. THAT THOSE RESOURCES
FIRST FOR STORAGE SO THE ONE
FORTY FIVE- I HAVE SOME
CONCERNS ABOUT THAT I THINK
THAT SHOULD STAY IN THE PROP.
IN IN THE BOND MONEY TO GO TO
THOSE PROJECTS AND COULD YOU
IDENTIFY WHAT OTHER PROJECTS IN
THE CENTRAL VALLEY- THAT YOU
WOULD BE LOOKING OUT WITH THAT
MONEY AND- THERE SEEMS TO BE. A
QUITE A BIT OF- RESOURCES
AVAILABLE RIGHT NOW IN THIS
PACKAGE. AND TO SIPHON SOME OFF
OF PROP ONE WHICH THE VOTERS.
DEFINITELY- PUSH FOR STORAGE-
CAN YOU ANSWER THAT FOR ME
PLEASE. I CAN. WELL THAT THAT
WAS NELSON'S QUESTION L. LONGER
GOING TO REFLECT IN THAT SO
RIGHT SO AGAIN I'D FROM FROM
THE SENATE POINT OF VIEW THIS
IS A SUGGESTION WHAT WE'RE WHAT
WE'RE LOOKING FOR SIR SOME
MONIES IN THE PROP SIXTY EIGHT
THEY JUST THEY THEY PROJECTS
HAVE BEEN COMPLETED AND MONEY
HAS BEEN GONE BACK THERE WITH
YOU MAKE THESE ESTIMATES ON ON
THOSE THOSE THINGS SO IF ANY OF
THOSE POTS OF MONEY. THAT ARE
THERE OR HER. OTHER MADISON
PEOPLE AREN'T THEY HAVE TO ACT
HAVE TO COMPLETE THE PROJECT TO
THE THEIR THEIR DECIDED NOT TO
COMPLETE THE PROJECTS A LOT OF
WATER RESTORATION SO THE GOAL
IS TO LOOK TO THE ALL THOSE
PROPS TO SCRAPE UP EVERYTHING-
RIGHT I DON'T I'M NOT DISPUTING
PROP SIXTY EIGHT BUT IN PROP
PROPOSITION ONE WE NEGOTIATED
AND THAT CONTRACT THAT IT WAS
GOING- IN THAT BILL THAT IT WAS
GOING TO BE FOR STORAGE THAT'S
HOW WE GOT ALL OF MOST OF THE
REPUBLICAN VOTE CAME FROM THE
FACT THAT. WE ACTUALLY.
DESIGNATED IT FOR STORAGE AND-
AND WE'RE NOT THERE WE SPENT A
WHILE. BUT I DON'T WANT TO SEE
THOSE FUNDS DIVERT OFF I STILL
WOULD LIKE TO SEE SITES
RESERVOIR TEMPERANCE FLAT. FOR
IT TO COME TO FRUITION SO THAT
WE IT DURING THESE TIMES WE
HAVE SEVERE DROUGHT WE ACTUALLY
HAVE SOME WATER AVAILABLE WELL
I THINK I THINK THE GOAL WOULD
BE NOT THAT YOU WOULD DIVERT IT
FROM. INVESTMENTS IN
AGRICULTURE AND GROUNDWATER
STORAGE BECAUSE WE HAVE
INTERVENING SIGMOD THAT IS
HELPING OUT WATER DISTRICTS AND
IF THE WATER BOARD DECIDES THAT
THE NEED IS THERE I GET IS THAT
C. IS JUST A SUGGESTION IT'S
NOT. A LOT OF BUDGET ITEM RIGHT
BECAUSE THERE'S- THERE'S
DROUGHT THEY MAY HAVE
PRIORITIES THAT THEY SAY OKAY
WE NED TO. WE NEED TO HELP OUT
THIS AGRICULTURAL OF- ROGIC. I
DON'T KNOW CENTER WAREHOUSE WAS
OLDER. SUGGESTIONS TURN INTO.
HAPPENINGS HERE AND THIS IS THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SAY HEY. D. D.
WOULD DO WE ARE YOU CAN MIX YOU
CAN TALK ABOUT SEGMENT YOU CAN
TALK ABOUT ALL THESE THINGS AND
THEY'RE ALL PRIORITIES THERE'S
A TON OF CARS OUT THERE. BUT
WITHOUT CREATING MORE WATER
WHICH IS WHAT PROP ONE WAS. WAS
SOLD TO THE VOTERS AS- AND SOLD
TO THE LEGISLATURE WHO PASSED
THE LEGISLATION OUT HERE TO
CREATE THE PROPOSITION. IN OUR
DIVERTING THOSE FUNDS AWAY I
WANT TO GO ON RECORD THAT I
THINK THAT'S THE WRONG YOU SOME
MONEY ALL RIGHT I THINK WE
SHOULD LEAVE THAT MONEY THERE
AND ACTUALLY DO WHAT WE ARE.
THAT THE BOAT WHAT THE VOTERS.
EXPECTED US TO DO WHICH WAS TO
CREATE SOME STORAGE. SO I KNOW
WHAT HOW IT WORKS HERE IT GOES
TO THIS COMMITTEE. AND THEN IT
GOES TO THE BIG THREE. PRETTY
SOON. BECAUSE IT NOBODY STOOD
UP AND SAID SOMETHING ABOUT IT
IT BECOMES. MAKING RECOVERY
ALREADY IN IT AND IT HAPPENS.
PROP SIXTY IT WAS A DIFFERENT
SCENARIO PROP SIXTY EIGHT WAS
ALL THE VOTERS IN A DIFFERENT
WAY. SO I'M TALKING ABOUT PROP
ONE MONEY'S GOING TO. OTHER
PLACES THAN STORAGE NO BUT THIS
IS JUST THE RIVER THAT. THE
WORDING THAT YOU'RE KEEN OFFICE
IT'S- IF IT'S DIVERTED TO USE
YOUR FOR. YOUR FIRM TO OTHER
SUSTAINABLE WATER STORAGE
INVESTMENT FOR AGRICULTURAL IN
THE CENTRAL VALLEY SO. IT MAY
NOT GO TO. TEMPERS FLAT DAM BUT
WILL GO TO OTHER WATER STORAGE
FACILITIES IN THE CENTRAL
VALLEY SO. IT'S NOT THIS IS
NOT- HIJACKING IS JUST SAYING.
IF WE CAN IF WE CAN DO MORE
GOOD IN OTHER PLACES I SEE
MISS. BELARUS IS AT HAND THIS
UP THAT'S ALL WE'RE LOOKING IS
JUST. CREATIVELY FIFTY FOUR IF
YOU GET MORE. WE WANT THAT PART
TO STATE WERE THE VOTERS WANTED
IT IN. WATER STORED IN THE
CENTRAL VALLEY THAT'S- NOT
DISPUTED WE'RE NOT DISPUTING
THAT WOULD JUST SINK. IF
THERE'S OTHER THINGS THAT COME
UP. BUT THAT'S IT THERE WAS TO
IDENTIFY PROJECTS AND- IN PROP
ONE AND TRUST ME I'M I'M VERY
MUCH CONCERNED ABOUT SITES IT'S
OF. AWESOME PROJECT AND WE NEED
TO BUILD AND DIVERSIFY IT IS IN
THAT. IS IN THAT AS WELL. NOT
TO DIVERT THAT MONEY AWAY FROM
THOSE IS THE WRONG THING TO DO
I'M JUST I. I THINK I'VE HEARD
IT LET'S GO TO MISS. ELLERS AND
IT WILL GO TO MISTER SINISTER
AND. IN CENTER MCGUIRE- THANK
YOU MISS CHAIR JUST AS UP OF
CLEAR. SO PROP. WE INCLUDED A
BIT OF FUNDING AND I WAS JUST
LOOKING FOR THE MAGIC IT WAS
ROUGHLY FOUR BILLION FOR WATER
STORAGE. AND DEFERRED TO THE
WATER COMMISSION TO DECIDE HOW
TO ALLOCATE THAT- ACROSS
DIFFERENT PROJECTS THEY PICKED.
SEVEN DIFFERENT PROJECTS FOR
THAT- FOR INITIAL ALLOCATIONS-
OF WHICH- THIS PROJECT WAS ONE.
DIFFERENT ACCESS TEMPERANCE
FLAT WAS ONE HOWEVER TEMPERANCE
FLAT HAS SINCE DIED BY BELIEVE
LAST OCTOBER WITHDRAWN FROM THE
PROGRAMBECAUSE THEY DIDN'T
HAVE- SUFFICIENT FUNDING I
THINK. THAT'S WHERE TIM TO
MATCH THE STATE FUNDING SO-
THIS FUNDING COULDN'T BE
DIVERTED FOR PURPOSES OTHER
THAN WATER STORAGE WITHOUT
GOING BACK TO THE VOTERS
BECAUSE PROPOSITION ONE
REQUIRES THAT IT BE IS FOR. FOR
WATER STORAGE BUT IT'S REALLY
UP TO THE WATER COMMISSION TO
DECIDE HOW TO ALLOCATE
CONSISTENT WITH BOND LANGUAGE
ACROSS PROJECTS. AND I BELIEVE
THAT TEMPERANCE FLAT IS NOW NOT
WHEN IT HAD HAS WAS ORIGINALLY
I HAVE. DECIDED BY THE WATER
COMMISSION TO GET SOME AT
FUNDING. BUT THEN HAS SINCE
WITHDRAWN SO MY UNDERSTANDING
IS THAT THESE FUNDS ARE STAR
WAITING FOR A NEW ALLOCATION AT
THIS POINT. WELL THEN LET ME
SUGGEST. THAT YOU USE THOSE
FUNDS. TO DESIGNATE THE
PROJECTS THAT WE DESIGNATED.
AND PROP ONE WHICH WAS- I THINK
LIVES MAY BE LOST FOR CAROL'S I
CAN'T REMEMBER WALL BUT I KNOW
THAT SITE IS ONE OF THOSE AND I
DON'T WANT TO THE POT IS
ALREADY. DWINDLED DOWN TO WHERE
WE CAN WE'RE TRYING TO GET THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT TO HELP US.
WITH WITH THESE PROJECTS AND WE
REALLY NEED TO BUILD A SOME
POINT ONCE YOU. WAIT THE LONGER
YOU WAIT NUMBER ONE BECAUSE
INFLATION. HAPPENS AND YOU'VE
YOU'VE- BOB PROBS WITH BILLIONS
DOLLARS IT DOES MEET MANY
BECAUSE IT YOU AFFORD TO BE.
MIGHT IS I DON'T WANT THESE
FUNDS SIPHONED OFF. TO PROJECTS
THAT WERE IDENTIFIED IN PROP
ONE. AS PRIORITY PROJECTS. WE
LINK. IN OUR- TO THE WATER
COMMISSION. ON TO CONVENE AN TO
REVIEW IT IF TEMPERED SLATS HAS
WITHDRAWN THAT'S BEYOND OUR-
OUR CONTROL. I'M FINE GO BUILD
SITE. SENATOR STERN YOUR
RECOGNIZE. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR- I PUT MY HAND DOWN HERE.
COME THROUGH OKAY YES YES GO
AHEAD RIGHT THANK YOU YEAH I
WANT TO START OF BY THANK YOU A
STAFF IN OUR LEAD. FOR YEAH
AGAIN IN THE- THIS GESTURE- ON
THE OF MOST- URGENT. TO OUR
STATE- I'M NOT TRYING TO DO IS
KEEP THE CAN DOWN THE ROAD OR
EVEN- WAIT FOR EVERYTHING TO
SHAKE OUT IN WASHINGTON BUT
STARTING ON EARLY I PACK ON WHY
IN NOW HE- ON THIS PACK WERE IN
THE TODAY- WE'RE CHAU CA
LEADERS. AT THE SCALE THAT I
THIS CRY TO ME. AND YOU KNOW TO
A IN SOME. WE RELY ON RECYCLED
WATER LA IS IN FACT COMMITTED
2100% RECYCLED WATER BY TWENTY
THIRTY FIVE- THE TWENTY MILLION
PEOPLE WHO LIVE IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA YOU KNOW 60% OF THE
STATE'S POPULATION HAS TO GET
CREATIVE ABOUT OUR RESOURCES SO
I'M REALLY EXCITED ABOUT. A LOT
OF ELEMENTS OF THIS PACKAGE I
THINK OUR GROWERS ARE IN A
REALLY TOUGH SPOT RIGHT NOW AND
WE NEED TO MAKE SIGNAL WORK I
THINK THE OPENING SALVOS WHEN
IT COMES TO WATER RECYCLING
AND- STORM WATER AND WATER
QUALITY HERE A GOOD START- AND
I WAS JUST HOPING WHILE WE HAD
OUR EXPERTS HERE TODAY JUST TO
DO IT A LITTLE BIT JUST TO GET
A LITTLE BIT OF FEEDBACK AB
STARTING WITH THE WATER BOARD.
ABOUT THE SCOPE OF NEED SO THAT
YOU KNOW THREE POINT FOUR
BILLION MAY SOUND LIKE A LOT-
BUT I KNOW THERE'S BEEN A FAIR
AMOUNT OF ANALYSIS BEING DONE
ON. NEEDS IN A FEW THESE AREAS
IF YOU'D INDULGE ANSWER CHECK
AND I ASKED THEM- OUR WATER
BOARD IN TERMS OF. PROJECTS
THAT- THEY'VE ALREADY ANALYZED.
THAT SEEM TO ALIGN WITH OUR
CRITERIA ABOUT YOU KNOW WHAT
SHOVEL READY WHERE IS THERE
CONSENSUS WHERE'S THE
PERMITTING WORK BEEN DONE- BUT
REALLY JUST GIVE US A LITTLE
MORE DETAIL. TO INFORM MARC ARE
AND PROCESS GOING FORWARD
PLEASE PROCEED I'M I'M SURE THE
WATER POURED WOULD LOVE TO GIVE
US A DETAILED LIST OF ALL TO
SHOVEL READY PROJECTS PLEASE-
IF. YOU'RE GOOD THANK YOU AND I
DON'T YOU KNOW I YOU ALSO NEED
TO BE EXHAUSTED BUT I WAS
REVIEWING IT WE CAN JUST START
WITH THAT AND- RECYCLED WATER I
KNOW YOU YOU ALL HAVE DONE A
SOME KIND OF ANALYSIS FOR. THE
SCOPE OF FUNDED WILL PROJECTS-
THIS YOU KNOW IN THIS NEXT YEAR
TO. GIVE IT CAN YOU GIVE US OF
WHAT WHAT THAT OVERALL NEEDED.
OR OVERALL SORT OF A FEW KNOW
WHAT'S FEASIBLE- AND FUND WILL
PROJECT NEEDS. YEAH I I'VE GOT
A QUICK LIST HERE I CAN RUN
THROUGH. I WON'T LIST THE
PROJECTS BUT JUST YOU KNOW
ROLLING IT UP FOR YOU- WE HAVE-
IN WATER RECYCLING PROJECTS
WHICH WE LUMP TOGETHER IS WASTE
WATER BECAUSE THEY ARE OFTEN
LINKED TOGETHER. I TWO HUNDRED
AND TWO PROJECTS ACCOUNTING FOR
SIX POINT FIVE FIVE BILLION
THAT ARE. IN SOME FORM OF
APPLICATION AND READY TO
PROCEED AND IN DIFFERENT
FASHIONS ARE BEGIN
IMPLEMENTATION- I CAN JUMP INTO
JUST A COUPLE OTHERS WHILE
IMAGINING I'M DRINKING WATER IS
THAT IT IS THAT THE STATE. HERE
OF THE OF THE RECYCLE PROJECTS
ARE JUST THE TOTAL COST OF THE
PROJECT TOTAL COST YEAH I'M
JUST LISTING THE TOTAL COST
YEAR OF THE PROJECTS AS WE HAVE
A MAN OF COURSE THEY'RE THEY'RE
ESTIMATES THEY'RE NOT. SOLID
NUMBERS FROM OF WHAT'S BEEN BAD
OR ANYTHING LIKE THAT BUT THESE
ARE. THESE ARE WHAT THE
PROPONENTS OF THE PROJECTS OF
INFORMED US- WHEN WE LOOK AT
THOSE LEVEL OF PROJECTS. IN
ANY. IN MIND TOUCHING ON. I
KNOW IT SO THAT'S RECESSED-
THAT'S SORT OF WHAT YOU CALL
WASTE WATER- I KNOW THE M. S.
FOR PERMITTING PROCESS AND
STORM WATER HAS BEEN A MAJOR.
LIABILITY FOR LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS- AND IS IT A BIG
DEAL INTO ITSELF YOU HAVE
ANYTHING IN THAT IN THE STORM
WATER AND AS FOR READING. YES I
DON'T KNOW THE THESE ARE ALL OF
SPECIFICALLY MS FOR BUT I DO
KNOW THAT WE'VE IDENTIFIED
FORTY THREE STORMWATER PROJECTS
IN THE MOST LIKELY. LARGELY MS
FOR A RELATED- THE TOTAL OF
THAT WOULD BE FIVE HUNDRED AND
FIFTY EIGHT MILLION OF THOSE OF
PROJECT PROPOSALS WE RECEIVED.
OKAY AND THEN THE LAST AREA WAS
I WAS. THIS WAS NOT THE LAST
YEAR I AM INTERESTED IN A LOT
OF THIS BUT- BUT ON WATER
QUALITY- ON THE SAFE DRINKING
WATER SIDE I KNOW WE'VE GOT A
ROBUST. PACKAGE YEAR ESPECIALLY
ON THE- SOME OF THE COMMUNITY
WATER NEEDS AND THAT ELEMENT
BUT YOU HAVE A- IF YOU WERE TO
SORT OF WRAP IN SAY- NOT JUST-
THOSE WATER QUALITY ISSUES BUT
LIKE THE BROADER GROUNDWATER
CLEANUP ISSUES OUT THERE- I'M
THINKING OF. YOU KNOW
EVERYTHING FROM- THE YOU KNOW
THE PROJECTS GOING ON IN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA TRY TO
GREET CLEAN UP OUR AQUIFER'S
THAT ARE UNDER WAY- BUT EVEN-
THE DRINKING WATER FOUNTAINS IN
SCHOOLS- THE LEAD. YOU KNOW
LEAD AND OTHER HAZARDOUS-
CONTAINMENT ISSUES GIVE A SENSE
ON THAT SIDE OF THINGS ON THE
BROADER WATER WATER QUALITY.
YEAH LET ME START WITH
GROUNDWATER GROUNDWATER-
THERE'S DEFINITELY A LOT MORE
NEEDS I'M GONNA REPRESENT HERE
THESE ARE PROJECTS THAT WE-
AGAIN HAVE PROPOSALS AND
HOUSING OR WORKING WITH. REP
FOR PROJECTS CURRENTLY LISTED
FOR SIXTY FOUR MILLION I KNOW
PERSONALLY THAT DIED COULD BE
EXTENDED DRAMATICALLY
ESPECIALLY IN THE LA AREA IN
THE INLAND EMPIRE AREA- KNOWING
THAT THERE ARE THERE'S A LOT OF
PROJECTS ARE GETTING LOCALLY
FUNDED THERE AS WELL. ON THE
DRINKING WATER SIDE IF WE JUST
KIND OF LUMP TOGETHER ALL
DRINKING WATER THAT WE KNOW OF
THAT ARE PROJECTS AND IN YOU
KNOW SOME AGAIN FORM OF
COMMUNICATION WITH US. THAT'S
TWO HUNDRED AND FORTY EIGHT
PROJECTS IN ABOUT TWO POINT
SEVEN BILLION DOLLARS WORTH OF
PROJECTED COSTS- FOR DRINKING
WATER. GOT IT. I THANK YOU FOR
THAT RUN THROUGH AND- ALL RIGHT
I HOPE THAT THAT HELPS INFORM
AT LEAST AT A HIGH LEVEL OUR
DISCUSSIONS GOING FORWARD I
WOULD UST SAY MISTER CHAIR.
THE POINT I WOULD I WOULD MAKE
IS WE HOPEFULLY MOVE THIS. BIG
BOLD PACKAGE FORWARD TODAY- IS
THAT. WE RECOGNIZING IN THESE
AREAS ALONE NOT TO MENTION SAY
SEGMENT LIMITATION. WHERE I
KNOW THERE'S ALSO A LOT OF
CAPACITY NEED- AND MAYBE. IN
THE FUTURE IN THE AS WE GO
FORTY WE CAN TOUCH ON- SORT OF
WHAT THE GSA AND SOME OF THOSE
OUTSTANDING ISSUES THAT THE
GROWERS ARE GOING TO BE FACING
IN THOSE REGIONS. BUT EVEN IN
THOSE AREAS ALONE- I'M HEARING.
I MEAN WE'RE WELL OVER. TEN
BILLION DOLLARS- SO. I WANT TO
BE- STRAIGHT FORWARD WITH OUR-
CALIFORNIA TO AND SAY YOU KNOW
WE'RE GOING TO WE WANT TO PUT A
BIG BIG INVESTMENT AND
SUPERCHARGES WEEDING THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT IS GOING TO
BE BEHIND US ALL THE WAY WE
HEARD FROM THE PRESIDENT
HIMSELF LAST NIGHT. WE KNOW THE
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS HAVE A BIG
PART TO PLAY IN THIS TO- BUT
THEY'RE REALLY SCOPE THE NEED
AND UNDERSTAND- HOW BIG WE'VE
GOT TO GO SO I HOPE THAT THAT
DOESN'T INTIMIDATE US BUT MAYBE
BOYS OUR SPIRIT ST DIG TO KEEP
GOING BIGGER SO THANKS FOR THE
INDULGENCE IN AND MISTER CHAIR
IF IT'S WORTH IT I WOULD- I
WOULD LIKE TO TOUCH ON THE SAME
ISSUE TO GO I IMAGINE IT'LL
COME UP IN TEST. MODE YEAH I
MEAN I THINK YOU YOU MAKE A
GOOD POINT IF. IF WE HAVE TEN
BILLION DOLLARS WORTH OF
PROJECTS HANGING OUT THERE AND-
WE'RE TWO AND A HALF SO IT'S A
DOWN PAYMENT- CENTER MCGUIRE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH MISTER CHAIR
I WAS JUST GONNA GO BACK TO
THAT THE ISSUE OF WHAT THE VICE
CHAIR OF. THE SENATE BUDGET
COMMITTEE CENTER NIELSEN HAD
REQUESTED THROUGH CENTER
DOLLING IN GREATLY APPRECIATE
THE CONCERN I THINK. THE
CHALLENGE IS NUMBER ONE THIS
COMMITTEE CAN'T CHANGE THE BOND
MEASURE RIGHT IT'S CONTINUOUS
APPROPRIATION NUMBER ONE.
NUMBER TWO THE OTHER ISSUE. IS
CENTER NIELSEN WILL ALSO HAVE
THAT SECOND BITE AT THE APPLE
WHEN I GO TO FULL BUDGET. SO
UNDERSTAND THE CONCERNS WHERE-VICE CHAIR DOLLY- BUT JUST HAVE
TO THE CONCERNED IN AND
RESPECTED GREATLY. I THINK THIS
IS GONNA BE THE FIRST OF
ANOTHER. LONGER CONVERSATION
AND I DON'T WANT TO PUT WORDS
INTO A CHAIR MAKOWSKI IS MATH.
THAT WE WOULD SEE ALSO AT THE
LARGER BUDGET COMMITTEE WHEN A
RECOMMENDATION WOULD COME
FORWARD TO THIS. I'D FROM
BUDGET SAID TO THE LARGER
BUDGET COMMITTEE WHERE SENATOR
NELSON BEARDED CHIME IN
DIRECTLY ON AS WELL I JUST WANT
TO SAY THAT. AGAIN GRATEFUL FOR
ADVISED HER DOLLAR FOR DANCING
COMES- THERE'S NO DOUBT THAT
MANY FOR. WILL BE REVIEWING THE
ITEMS ARE INCLUDED IN THIS AND
SCRUBBING IT LET'S GO BACK TO
CENTER DOLLY. I WANT TO JUST
MAKE A COMMENT FIRST OFF I
WANTED TO. FOR THE FOR THE I.
T. WORK THAT NEEDS TO BE DONE
IN THE- IN THE DEPARTMENT OF
WATER RESOURCES WHAT WERE WE
HAVE WATER RIGHTSBASICALLY ON
PAPER STILL I AM ALL IN. I'M
NOT I DON'T KNOW A LOT OF FAITH
AS YOU AS MANY OF YOU KNOW I'VE
I'VE BEEN CRITICAL OF. THE WORK
WE'RE ABLE TO DO IN THE I. T.
AREA FOR SOME REASON WHEN YOU
LOOK AT EDT IN THE DMV WE HAVE
WE PUT A LOT OF MONEY AND BUT
WE DON'T GET. A GOOD PRODUCT
OUT SO I'M HOPEFUL. ONCE AGAIN
WE'RE WE TALKED ABOUT IT AND
DGSE IN THE SAME COMMITTEE-
EARLIER THIS YEAR. SO I WANT TO
SEE IS GET INTO THE TWENTY
FIRST CENTURY HERE WITH OUR
TECHNOLOGY SO THAT PEOPLE
ESPECIALLY NOW WHERE PEOPLE
CAN'T GET INTO ACCESS THINGS WE
NEED TO BE ABLE TO. STREAMLINED
THE PROCESS SO I WANT TO. JUST
SHARE THAT. I'M IN SUPPORT OF
THAT. YEAH THE THING I WANTED
TO BRING UP IS THAT- I AS A AS
SOMEBODY WHO IS A FARMER AND-
I'M NOT SEEN A DRYER YOU'RE IN
MY LIFETIME. THIS EARLY ON. AND
I THINK THAT- I KNOW THAT THIS
PROCESS HAS IT TAKES TIME WE
HAVE TO YOU KNOW GO THROUGH THE
PROCESS BUT- WE HAVE SOME EARLY
ACTION ITEMS THAT WE REALLY
NEED TO FOCUS ON HERE AND WHEN
I SAY THAT- THAT FOR EVERY. DAY
OR WEEK THAT WE WAIT IN GETTING
MONEY ON THE GROUND IT'S DAY
IT'S DAYS AND WEEKS THAT
THERE'S EVAPORATION HAPPENING
ON OUR SOILS- IN SOME THESE
WATER DISTRICT IS QUITE FRANKLY
NEED SOME RESOURCES TO GET.
THINGS DONE AND SO- I WANT TO
JUST TALK A LITTLE BIT ABOUT
THE TO THE LAKE BASIN- WHICH A
FAX SENATOR MCGUIRE AND MY
DISTRICT AS WELL- I HOPE IS
JUST APPROPRIATE TIME TO HAVE
THIS CONVERSATION. I WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT- AND I DON'T
KNOW OF ANY YOU KNOW BUT
ACTUALLY THE DAILY FAMILY CAME
TO CALIFORNIA- BECAUSE MY
GRANDFATHER WAS A WORLD WAR ONE
VETERAN AND ACTUALLY DO DREW A
LAND GRANT INTO THE LAKE SO I
HAVE THE DEED. TO THE PROPERTY
WAS SIGNED BY FRANKLIN
ROOSEVELT IN MY OFFICE-
UNFORTUNATE WE SOLD THAT PIECE
OF PROPERTY ABOUT TWELVE YEARS
TWELVE OR THIRTEEN YEARS AGO
BUT IN TWO THOUSAND AND ONE WE
STILL OWN THAT PROPERTY. AND
THE DISTRICT UP THERE WAS
ZEROED OUT OF WATER SO IT IS A-
AREA WHERE WATER FROM THE FROM
THE KLAMATH LAKE. IT GOES DOWN
THE KLAMATH RIVER WHICH AFFECTS
BOTH SENATOR MCGUIRE IN MY
DISTRICT AND THERE'S ALSO WATER
PROJECT IS ALSO. CONNECTED TO
THAT IS THE UNITED STATES FISH
AND WILDLIFE REFUGE. THATIS-
HAS WITH THE PLACE FOR THE
PACIFIC FLYWAY THERE'S FOUR
HUNDRED AND THIRTY THREE
SPECIES. THAT LIVE IN THAT.
BASIN ARE THAT WE THAT WE NEED
WATER- THE ALEC. TO THE TO THE
CORRUGATION DISTRICT HAS BEEN
ZEROED OUT THIS YEAR THAT MEANS
THERE'S NO WATER. AT ALL- IN
TWO THOUSAND ONE UNDER THE
GUIDANCE OF THE LEGISLATURE IN
GRAY DAVIS THEY ACTUALLY THE
STATE ACTUALLY HELP THE
DISTRICT ALSO MILES. AND THEY
ARE THEY'RE GONNA WANT TO TURN
THOSE WELLS ON AND BE ABLE TO
HELP TAKE CARE OF THE HABITAT
THIS IS ALSO SOME OF THE MOST
FERTILE LAND IN THE WORLD. AND
IT HAS A TENDENCY TO BELOW. AND
AS YOU ALL KNOW IT SEEMS LIKE
WE GET NGUYEN MORE NET NOWADAYS
THAN WE DID IN THE PAST AND SO-
I'M GONNA BE ASKING FOR. A
FIFTEEN MILLION DOLLAR-
AMENDMENT TO THIS BUDGET- AND-
I GUESS THAT'S THE RIGHT WORD-
TO GO TO THAT MASON SO THAT
THEY CAN- JUST STABILIZE THE
SOIL AND HELP THE MIGRANT
WORKERS THAT ARE THAT ARE THERE
AND THE- COMMUNITY- AND GET
THAT WATER TURNED ON. AND GET
THE AND SO TWENTY YEARS AGO THE
INFRASTRUCTURE HAS HAS CHANGED
SOMEWHAT BUT WE NEED TO UPGRADE
SOME OF THOSE- THIS THE STUFF
IS THERE SO I WANTED TO JUST
SHARE THE IT'S A- THIS IS AN
AREA WHERE. THE PACIFIC FLYWAY-
IF YOU DON'T PLANT THOSE FILLED
IN HOLD THAT SOIL THERE'S
NOHING THERE FOR THE BIRDS TO
FORAGE ON AS A RESTING TO COME.
TO THE REST OF CALIFORNIA WHICH
IS THE BAY DELTA AND EVEN
FURTHER SOUTH. SO FOR THOSE
REASONS MEMBERS I'D LIKE TO
MAKE AN AMENDMENT TO THIS TO
ADD FIFTEEN MILLION DOLLARS TO
AND THE MECHANICS OF IT- IN THE
PAST THEY DID IT THROUGH- YES
WHICH I AS A CHALLENGE I THINK
FOR US NOW BUT I WOULD REALLY
LIKE TO BE ABLE TO HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO WORK WITH THE
COMMITTEE. ON WHERE THAT WERE
NOT PART OF. RESOURCES GOES AND
HOW IT GETS IMPLEMENTED. THAT'S
THAT'S FINE AND FOR FOLKS THAT
ARE LISTENING IN YOU KNOW THERE
IS THERE'S- AS WE WERE
INDICATORS FIVE HUNDRED MILLION
IMMEDIATELY FOR COMMUNITY
ASSISTANCE FOR WATER IN
DROUGHT. THIS AND THAT AND
THAT'S YOU KNOW FIVE MILLION
FOR COMMUNITIES SOME OF THE
SMALLER DISTRICTS THAT WERE
FOCUSING ON AND WE TAKE. FIVE
HUNDRED MILLION FOR THE THIRD
WATER IF I USE EFFICIENCY FOR
THE DROUGHT AND WE'RE GIVING
YOU ONE FIFTY MILLION TAKE AG
IN TWO HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION TO
THE- TO. HELP RESIDENTIAL
HOUSEHOLDS IN COMMERCIALS BUT
YOUR POINT IS WELL. MADE FUNDED.
THE NEED FOR. THESE MONEY TO
GET OUT THE DOOR AND THAT'S
WHAT WE'RE DOING THIS IN APRIL
RIGHT RIGHT AND I WANT TO JUST.
COME IN THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE
THE L. A. THE- THE AGENCIES.
AND THE MEMBERS FOR THE I MEAN
THE SOONER THE BETTER EVERY DAY
WE WAIT. IS A DAY THAT WE'RE
LOSING THE OPPORTUNITY TO GET
SOME SEEDS IN THE GROUND AND
STABILIZE THAT SO WELL. AS WELL
AS TAKE CARE OF THE
ENVIRONMENT. OKAY LET'S SEE I
DON'T SEE ANY OTHER HANDS UP-
MY PAST OUR PANEL IS THERE
ANYBODY THAT WANTS TO ADD
ANYTHING. OKAY OKAY SO. SENATOR
STERN I'M SO SORRY I MEAN
INTERRUPT I DON'T HAVE A
DIGITAL HANDS NOT A HIKE THAT'S-
IT'S GOING. SORRY ABOUT THAT
CAN I JUST CAN I GET A SENSE ON
THAT I ON THE SIGMA FRONT JUST
TO. I KNOW WE'VE GOT- SOME
FUNDING HERE BUT IT- HOW IS
THAT PROCESS LOOKING RIGHT NOW
I KNOW THE L. A. YO AND THAT.
FROM THE FINANCE COMMENTED ON
THAT. RECORD FOR YOU TO COME IN
TO MEET THE WATER BOARD BUT-
WHAT. WHAT WHAT THE IMMEDIATE
NEEDS ARE IN SICK MAN
PLANTATION AND WHAT WHAT SHOVEL
READY LOOKS LIKE IN THAT WORLD
HOW WE MAY SEE SOME OF THIS.
FUNDING ABLE TO ACTUALLY
ALLEVIATE SOME OF THE PRESSURES
IN THE PROCESS IS THE GSA'S GET
THEIR PLANS TOGETHER CAN YOU. I
DON'T KNOW BETWEEN THEM WE HAVE
A MERE THREE HUNDRED MILLION IN
THE POT FOR- THE DEPARTMENT OF
WATER RESOURCES FOR SEVERAL FOR
SIGMA FOR TO SUPPORT DANTE D.
W. ARE OKAY YEAH FOR DEEP. BUT
ONE OF YOU GO AHEAD YEAH JUST
TO GIVE US A SENSE OF HOW HOW
THAT'S GOING TO LOOK IN WHAT
WHAT KIND OF- PRESSURE THAT MAY
ALLEVIATE AND WHAT WHAT AND
WHAT NEED LOOKS LIKE THEY'RE-
THIS IS. RACHEL IN THERE SO
THAT WAY I CAN TAKE A FIRST
SHOT AND THEN- YOU KNOW MISS
JONES I KNOW WORKS WITH YOU TO
BE ART BUT NOT DIRECTLY IN
SICKNESS I'M NOT SURE WHETHER
SHE'S GOT ANY. INPUT BUT I KNOW
THAT- AND AS YOU ALL KNOW THAT
CRITICALLY OVER DRAFTED BASS
AND SUBMITTED THEIR PLANS LAST
YEAR DEPARTMENT IS IN THE
PROCESS OF REVIEWING THEM BUT-
AND DUE TO BE OUR- LAB RELEASED
IT FOR THE FIRST FEW ROUNDS OF
GRANTS. ARE USING PROPOSITON
SIXTY EIGHT FUNDS FOR BEGINNING
TO IMPLEMENT THOSE PLANS THOSE-
GRANDMOTHER STATED BILLY PLANS
FOR THE CRITICALLY OVER DRAFTED
BASINS. AND I KNOW THEY GOT
MORE FUNDING REQUESTS AND THEY
HAD FUNDING AVAILABLE FOR THE
FIRST ROUNDS. AND THAT'S JUST
FOR THOSE CRITICALLY OVER
DRAFTED BASINS NEXT JANUARY
TWENTY TWENTY TWO IS WHEN THE
REST OF THE BASINS BY HIGH AND
MEDIUM PRIORITY WILL SUBMIT
THEIR- GROUNDWATER
SUSTAINABILITY PLANS. AND THEN
BEGIN IMPLEMENTING THOUGH SO
THERE'LL BE INCREASED DEMANDS
AND SO THE PROJECTS ARE THINGS
LIKE- YOU KNOW POTENTIALLY THAT
BUILDING CONNECTIONS BETWEEN
DIFFERENT- WATER SYSTEM SO THAT
THEY CAN TRANSFER WATER MORE
EASILY- BUILDING FACILITIES TO
BE ABLE TO CAPTURE- MORE FLOOD
WATERS AND PERMEATED INTO THE
GROUND TO HELP TRAIN REPLENISH
GROUNDWATER BASINS. SO SOME
LARGE CAPITAL PROJECTS LIKE
THAT I WOULD ASSUME ALSO SOME
KIND OF SMALLER PROJECTS OF
INCREASED PLANNING INCREASED
DATA COLLECTION SO THAT THEY
CAN IMPROVE THEIR PLANS AS THEY
MOVE FORWARD. SO THOSE WOULD BE
THE TYPES OF PROJECTS I WOULD
EXPECT. AGAIN STARTING PROBABLY
WITH THOSE CRITICALLY OVER
DRAFTED BASINS THAT ARE FURTHER
AHEAD. AND WITH THE REST OF THE
B. SINCE COMING UP SOON BEHIND.
YEAH WE SHOULD REMEMBER THAT
THERE ARE. LEGISLATIVE EFFORTS
RIGHT NOW FOR OF BOND MEASURE
THAT THERE ARE WORKING THEIR
WAY THROUGH TO HEAR THIS IS
THIS IS REALLY THE HERE AND NOW
THIS IS WHAT WE HAVE NOW. THAT
WERE PUSHING MONEY OUT IN THE
AN EMERGENCY- BUT YEAH I THINK
WE CAN. WALK AND CHEW GUM
DOABLE. IN ON THIS. DEAL WITH
THE HERE AND NOW AND IN THE
BOND. MISTER OF THE PULL FROM
MR YOU HAVE SOME TO ADD ON. S.
PORTLAND THAT GOOD AT THE SMACK
PART IT'S NOT PART OF MY
PORTFOLIO I DON'T KNOW WHO'S
JONES SHE'S WITH THE DEPARTMENT
LOTTERY SO SHE MIGHT HAVE
SOMETHING TO SAY. I KNOW I WILL
PASS ON THIS ONE BECAUSE WE ARE
STILL IN THE PROCESS OF.
WAITING FOR THAT SECOND BATCH
OF PLANS THAT WAS REFERRED TO
COME IN AND SEE WHAT THEIR
NEEDS ARE. AS AS WAS MENTIONED
WE HAVE DONE SOME INITIAL
ROUNDS FORTY CAPACITY BUILDING.
FOR THE AGENCIES TO START OFF
ON DEVLOPING THEIR PLANS
WHICH- SOME OF THEM ARE NOW
IMPLEMENTING. I MAY HAVE MISSED
THIS IN YOUR TESTIMONY WAS
JONES BUT IT. WHAT WHAT IS THE
NEED IN THAT. CAPACITY BUILDING
ASSESSMENT YOU'VE DONE SO FAR.
ON I AM I HAVE TO APOLOGIZE
BECAUSE I AM NOT THE SIGMA
PERSONS LIKE OKAY. NUMBERS IN
FRONT OF ME OKAY THAT'S OKAY
MAYBE WE CAN FOLLOW UP ON THAT
ONE ONE OF WE STIPULATE THAT
THE NEED IS GREAT- THAT THAT
THAT WE CAN'T WE UNDERSTAND
THAT THE NEED IS GREAT. AND
THAT- YOU KNOW THIS IS. THIS IS
WE LOOK WE WAIT WITH OPEN ARMS
FOR THE ADMINISTRATION'S
RESPONSE AND THE STEPS THAT
THEY WANT TO TAKE THIS IS THE
SENATE PROPOSAL TO COME UP WITH
TO DO SOMETHING. WITH THE HERE
AND NOW SO. THAT'S GREAT- OKAY
WE HAVE LET'S OPEN WE HAVE A
MOTION BY WHAT ARE THE WE'RE
GONNA WAIT ON THAT WE'RE GONNA
OPEN UP THE PUBLIC HEARING IF
WE HAVE NO OTHER QUESTIONS. WE
DO HAVE THE PUBLIC OUT THERE.
ALL RIGHT LET'S DO THAT-
EIGHTEEN T. THANK YOU IF YOU
WISH TO MAKE A COMMENT PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. AND I SHOULD HAVE SAID I
SEE NOBODY IN THE COMMUNITY THE
HEARING ROOM- TO TESTIFY SO
WE'LL GO. TO THE PUBLIC THROUGH
THE PHONES. THANK YOU AND I
HAVE ABOUT THIRTY COMMENTS IN
Q. WE'LL START WITH WHY IN
SIXTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
WINDS SIX ONE YOU ARE OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. AND WE'RE
TRYING SIXTY SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YES GOOD MORNING WELL
CHORE- MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
ONE OF THEM WE DON'T KNOW WHAT
OTHER ONE CALIFORNIA THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK
WITH OUR ON THE KIND OF TODAY
WE WANT TO THANK THE SENATE FOR
PUTTING THIS PROPOSAL FORM-
FORWARDS BUT GENERALLY HAPPY
WITH YOUR MARKETING AND
PROGRAMS FUNDED IN THIS
RESPONSE. WELL FOR THIS-
DROUGHT CONDITIONS- OUR
RESPONSE YEAH WE DON'T
MENTIONED THE STATE HAS THE
PUBLIC TRUST LOCAL PROFESSIONAL
WILDLIFE AND THE
RECOMMENDATION. FROM THE REPORT
POINTS OUT THAT WE NEED TO
IMPROVE ACCOUNT OF THEIR
ACCOUNTING FOR MY LIFE BEFORE
AND DURING STROKES AND- A LOT
WE WOULD LIKE TO SEE THE
FUNDING FOR DFW PROGRAMS TO
REDUCE HUMAN WILDLIFE CONFLICTS
ON AGRICULTURAL LANDS DUE TO
DROUGHT AUGUST HELP ADDRESS
DIRECT. TOM BETWEEN WILDLIFE
AGRICULTURE PART TWELVE. STATE
OF. DANGER MANTRA PARKS.
DEPARTMENT BC ABOUT CLOCK. AND
DEVELOP CLINICAL PRO. WE WILL
NOW MY TO KEEP ON. FOR SCIENCE.
OF DROUGHT THE FACT. AND WATER
MANAGEMENT AWHILE HABITS. WHICH
RECENTLY FOR THE- OR MONITOR
I'M DRAW OUR BIRDS. THERE ARE.
READING BECAUSE AND- THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME. THIS SO THAT
EVERYBODY IN THERE'S HIS FACE
MILLION FOR THE DEPARTMENT
OFFICIAL FOR COASTAL MONITOR.
ON THE EFFECTS OF SALMON POP
SITS IN THE- BUT THERE'S MORE
TO COME MODERATOR NECK. THANK
YOU RAIMES TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MISTER CHAIRMAN MY MILLER
VALLEY WATER AND AWAY AND I
WANT TO COMPLETE THE OF ON THE
SENATE- WELL I. APPRECIATED
PLAN. RECYCLED WATER WELL IT'S
NOT A. TO HAVE ON A SOME OF THE
WITH REGARD I'M NOT A HATER
WATER. TO GET OCT THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR YOUR TIME ALL OF OUR
THE APPETITE. MINTED POSITION
ON THE GPS THE FISCAL TRAILER
BILL AND LET ME START BY WE
SHARE THE- OVER ARCHING. GO AND
IMPROVE EACH YEAR GOVERNOR. AND
PROVIDE A IT WITH THE NEW REACH.
ESPECIALLY TO ADDRESS OR IN
LIKE THE- SITES SO WE STRONGLY
TO GO PROCEDURAL IN MOST OF THE
SCHOOLS. COMPOSED BY T. S. B.
AT THE SAME WE REMOVE OF THE-
OPTIONS FOR. WASTE TAKE A THE
HOUSE HAZARDOUS WASTE. SO FOR
USED OIL AND FOR UP WAY.
ELIMINATION OF THESE EXEMPTION
WILL CO SEVERAL DOLLARS AND IT
DOES COSTS IN FOR THE VITAL LOW
PRO. PLEASE PROGRAMS THAT ARE
TO. THE L. BOOZE. OF HAS WASTE
AND DUMPING ASTERS WASTES. WE
FEAR THE ADDITIONAL CALL COULD
NOT CAN BE A DISPOSAL OPPORTUNE
AND MANY WORLD. UNTIL LOW CLEAN
UP ACTION. BUT FINALLY WE HAVE.
THE EXTENT AFTER TO WORK WITH
US AND OTHERS TO. RESOLVE THESE
AND ARE CONCERNS ABOUT THE
PROPOSALS THANK YOU. LIST OF
RECYCLED WATER PROJECT THE
STATE BOARD THAT CAN HELP MAKE
LOCAL COMMUNITIES MORE DROUGHT
RESILIENT AND CREATED
SIGNIFICANT NUMBER OF JOBS AT
THE SAME TIME. WATER BE USED
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST THE SENATE
INCREASE THE FUNDING FOR
RECYCLED WATER IN DROUGHT
PACKAGE AND WE THANK YOU FOR
THIS OPPORTUNITY. MAX. THANK
YOU BRIAN SEVENTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS CINDY TECH WITH THE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA WATER
AGENCIES AWKWARD STRONGLY
SUPPORTS THE SENATE DROUGHT
RELIEF PACKAGE WE APPRECIATE
THE SENATE LEADERSHIP ON THIS
AND I'LL JUST MAKE A COUPLE OF
QUICK POINTS ON TODAY. SO FIRST
OBVIOUSLY THIS PACKAGE INCLUDES
MUCH NEEDED FUNDING FOR MANY
WATER MANAGEMENT CATEGORIES
THAT WILL HELP CALIFORNIA TO
DROUGHT BARKLEY IS GLAD TO
SERVE AS A RESOURCE- TO THE
LEGISLATURE IN THE MINISTRATION
IN THIS AREA- I DO WANT TO-
NOTE AS SENATOR. OR CHAIR
ACCOUNT HE SAID THAT WE SUPPORT
BE YOU WHEN YOU CAN WALK IN AND
SHOOT THEM AT THE SAME TIME IN
OTHER WORDS THIS IMMEDIATE
FUNDING IS CRITICAL IN THE
CLIMATE RESILIENCE. BOND
FUNDING WITH MONEY FOR
INFRASTRUCTURE IS REALLY
IMPORTANT TO. TOBACCONIST
PACKAGE THIS PACKAGE WOULD ALSO
APPROPRIATE FEDERAL CODED
FUNDING TO HELP COVER COVERED
NINETEEN RELATED WATER DEBT FOR
CUSTOMERS THAT DRINKING WATER
AND WASTEWATER AGENCY USE.
THAT'S THE RIGHT APPROACH IT'LL
HELP BOTH THE CUSTOMERS AND THE
PUBLIC WATER AGENCIES THAT
REALLY HAVE BEEN HIT
FINANCIALLY BY CODE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR YOUR TIME TODAY.
NEXT THANK YOU BYE NINETY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS DONNED KHAKI
RECHNET UCAP UNISEX YOUTH ON
BEHALF THE CALIFORNIA COUNCIL
FOR ENVIRONMENTAL AND ECONOMIC
BALANCE TESTIFYING WITH REGARD
TO THE PROPOSED ISSUE NUMBER
ONE RELATED TO THE GST REFORM
THE LAST YEAR AND A HALF YEARS
THE ASSEMBLY IS TO WORK CLOSELY
WITH THE GST TALLY PA AND THE
LEGISLATURE ON ISSUES RELATED
TO THE GST REFORM. AS A MATTER
OF FACT SHEET WITH PLEASE JUDGE
THE CORNET ASSEMBLY BILL NINE
NINE FIVE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
CRISTINA GARCIA IN TWENTY
TWENTY AND IS AGAIN SUPPORTING
HER WE INTRODUCTION AS AB ONE
THIS YEAR THAT INCLUDES
IMPORTANT FOR MARKERS TO ENSURE
TRANSPARENCY EFFICIENCY AND
ACCOUNTABILITY THAT APARTMENT.
PERMITTING PROGRAMMATIC AND
REGULATORY PROGRAMS THAT ARE
PARTICULARLY IMPORTANT YOU TO
REGULATE COMMUNITY AFTER THE
BUDGET PACKAGE WE CONTINUE TO
BE ENGAGED WITH EACH AT THE END
THE ADMINISTRATION ON THEIR
RECORDS REFORM PACKAGE WORKING
THROUGH THE DIFFERENT THAN WHAT
WE AGREED YOU IN ASSEMBLY BILL
ONE AND CONCERNS ASSOCIATED
WITH THE TALK OF THE CHANGES
AND BE SETTING UP THE
AUTHORITY. THE FISCAL REFORM
AFFECT THE PROPOSAL IN
PARTICULAR ARE COMPLEX AND
SIGNIFICANTLY INCREASE TO BE A
MANY GENERATORS OF COMMITTEES
THAT RAISE CONCERNS ABOUT
CREATING FURTHER CHALLENGES FOR
CALIFORNIA. AND MANAGING THAT
DON'T HAVE TO JUST WAIT. IT CAN
THE CHANGE OVER IN FOR DECLINE
OF PERMITTED TO SELL. DURING
THE DAY. TO RECITE USED. AND
MADE HIM CAPACITY OF. FOR
CALIFORNIA TO MAN NINE HUNDRED
SQUARE FORCED GREATER. ON AXWAY
HAS WHICH OTHERS. THAT SAID
THEN ENOUGH TO BE. AND FLEW
DURING. EVEN A COALITION
PARTNERS HAVE COME TO THE TABLE
WITH PROPOSED ALTERNATIVE
APPROACHES FOR DRAFTING
POLITICAL CHALLENGES. AS WELL
AS RECOMMENDED REFINEMENT THE
PROPOSAL WE LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING TOGETHER ON A REFORM
PROPOSAL THAT ENSURES THE
PROTECTION OF COMMUNITIES AND
ENVIRONMENT. WHILE ALSO
ENSURING TRANSPARENCY
ACCOUNTABILITY RESPONSIVENESS
AND EFFICIENCY IS PROJECTED
GOING FORWARD HE REMAINED
COMMITTED TO AN EFFICIENT
WORKABLE AND APPROPRIATELY
FUNDED DEPARTMENT. AS WE
CONTINUE TO BE DISCUSSIONS WE
APPRECIATE THE LEGISLATURE
HOLDING I OPEN IT ITEMS OPEN
FOR THE TIME BEING THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ZACKS. THANK YOU
FIFTY FOUR CALL. THANK YOU DAVE
PETERSON GENERAL MANAGER OF BOX
VIRGIN IT'S BEAUTIFUL WATER
DISTRICT I WANTED TO EXPRESS
OUR SUPPORT FOR THE SENATE SIDE
DROUGHT RELIEF PACKAGE AND PER
SENATOR STERN'S COMMENTS
RELATED TO OPPORTUNITIES TO
INCREASE FUNDING RELATED TO
WATER RECYCLING AND ALSO
STORMWATER. USING SHOVEL READY
PROJECTS THAT HAVE ALREADY BEEN
SUBMITTED TO THE STATE WATER
RESOURCES CONTROL BOARD AND WE
ALSO SUPPORT WALKING AND
CHEWING GUM THANK YOU. THE EX.
THANK YOU I'M EIGHTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YOUR LOCK ON
BEHALF OF THE CITY OF BURBANK
IN SUPPORT OF ITEM NUMBER TWO
AND THE FUNDING FOR YOU CLAUDIA
WEYRICH'S THE CITY AND BURBANK
WATER AND POWER HAS BEEN
CONSISTENTLY WORKING WITH
CUSTOMERS THAT ARE STRUGGLING
TO MEET BASIC OBLIGATIONS
INCLUDING PAYING THEIR UTILITY
BILLS AND THIS FUNDING WILL BE
SIGNIFICANTLY HELPFUL. FOR
STRUGGLING CUSTOMERS MY
COMMUNITY GONZALEZ THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT. THANK YOU RIGHT
EIGHTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HEARING HEALTH IMPLEMENTORS
JANA IF YOU NAY ON BEHALF OF B.
O. THAI WATER DISTRICT- OR THE
PERFECTLY ON. TO ONE BILLION
DOLLARS IN FEDERAL FUNDING FOR
UTILITY AND WATER DELIVERING
RECORDS OR SO SEATED WITH THE
KOBE NINETEEN ECONOMIC IMPACTS
NOT COMMUNITIES. REALLY I THINK
THE PLANET EARTH LEADERSHIP. ON
THIS CRITICAL ISSUE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU WE HOPE THAT THE ALL
THE YOU THE WATER DISTRICTS
WITHIN WHEN PAYMENTS ARE MADE
THAT. THEIR BOND RATINGS GO UP
NECKS. THANK YOU RAIMES SEVENTY
SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN OR STEVE BAKER
WAS APPARENTLY DISSOCIATES FOR
THE A PERCENT GABRIEL VALLEY
MUNICIPAL WATER AGENCY IN
SUPPORT OF THE SENATE PACKAGE
AND LOOKING FORWARD TO OUR BOND
RATINGS GOING UP THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR. YOU'RE WELCOME
NEXT. THANK YOU RIGHT NINETY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. MISTER
CHAIR AT MANNING ON BEHALF OF
THE- LOS ANGELES DEPARTMENT OF
WATER AND POWER AND MOJAVE
WATER AGENCY IN SUPPORT OF THE
RELIEF PACKAGE FOR DROUGHT AND
IN PARTICULAR VERY CREATION OF
YOUR LEADERSHIP IN THE SENATE
LEADERSHIP. TO HELP BUT OUR
RATE PAYERS OUT AND MAKE THEM
ALL- AND HELP THE AGENCIES GET
BACK ON A SOUND FOOTING THANKS.
WELCOME OUR NEXT. THANK YOU
RIGHT NINETY TWO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MISTER CHAIRMAN SENATORS
ANTHONY MOLINA ON BEHALF OF
MESA WATER DISTRICT IN THE
SANTA CLARITA VALLEY WATER
AGENCY HERE IN SUPPORT OF THE
SENATE'S DROUGHT RELIEF PACKAGE
THANK YOU FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP
ON THE ISSUE WE SPECIFICALLY
LIKE TO THANK YOU FOR THE
FUNDING INCLUSION TO HELP
UTILITY CUSTOMERS IN UTILITIES
ADDRESSING THE BACK BOX BILLS.
AND RIDGES- ASSOCIATED WITH
CALVET NINETEEN ECONOMIC
IMPACTS THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
NEXT THANK YOU RIGHT THIRTY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS NATALIE
WITH LEADERSHIP COUNCIL WE
COMMEND THE SENATE FOR THE
PROPOSED DROP PACKAGE AND TO
ENSURE THE FUNDING MAKES ITS
WAY TO COMMUNITIES THAT WILL
FACE THE WORST IMPACT DRINKING
WATER IMPACT WE MAKE THE
FOLLOWING SUGGESTION WE SUPPORT
THE PROPOSAL A FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION FOR IMMEDIATE COMMUNITY
ASSISTANCE FOR WATER AND
BROUGHT RELIEF. TO PROPERLY
ALLOCATE THE FUNDS WE MUST
LEVERAGE THE WORK THE STATE
WATER BURKE DID AN EXTREMELY
WATER NEEDS ASSESSMENT AND THAT
YOU ARE EITHER WE ARE GETTING
IT HE D. AG REPORT. BOTH OF
WHICH LOOK AT WATER FROM THEM
WHILE THEY ARE AT RISK OF DRUG
ARRESTS OF DROUGHT IMPACT
ADDITIONALLY WE MUST ENSURE
THAT WE ARE LEVERAGING THE
STATE WATER BOARD STATE THE
PROGRAM AND WALDRON THAT EVEN
AS WE RESPOND TO DROUGHT WE
MUST CONTINUE TO MAKE PROGRESS
ON DRINKNG WATER QUALITY.
GRANT GIVEN TO THE POOR
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE MEASURE
PRIORITIZE PROJECTS THAT
BENEFIT AND PROTECT GROUNDWATER
SOURCES OF LOWER INCOME
COMMUNITIES AND EVENTUALLY THEY
WILL PROJECT BUT DO NOT PROVIDE
MULTI BENEFITS TO DRINKING
WATER THE ENVIRONMENT SHOULD
NOT BE FUNDED. THE RESILIENT
WATER INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECTS
FUNDING SHOULD PRIORITIZE
PROJECTS THAT THAT WATER
INFRASTRUCTURE PROMOTE PROJECTS
FOR WATER INFRASTRUCTURE FOR
LOWER INCOME LOW INCOME AND
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES WE
SUPPORT FUNDING FOR WATER
EFFICIENCY MEASURES AND ADVICE
AND IMPLEMENTATION INCLUDE
DIRECT INSTALL PROGRAM TO
ENSURE THAT LOW INCOME
HOUSEHOLDS ACCESS AND BENEFIT
FROM. COULDN'T CONSERVATION
BUSSMANN. WE ALONG WITH.
REMINDING THE FOR THE FOR TO
PROVIDE BILLION FOR WATER IN
THE TOILET THAT REAL. IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT I WE RECOVER THE
PANDA WE PER SUPPORT TO THOSE
HIT HARD BY THE TELEGENIC AND-
CRISIS. ENSURE THAT DO NOT SEE
AWAY OF WATER AND POWER SHOP
AND SUPPORT FAMILIES. EIGHT
RISK OF. WHAT AND UTILITY THAT
CAL. TWO BILLION AND WE MUST
ENSURE THAT NUMBER OF FUNDS.
MEET THE NEED THAT PROTECT.
SHOP THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PROVIDE COMMENTS
ON THE POTENTIAL FUNDING ALSO.
THANK YOU NEXT. THANK YOU RIGHT.
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. I'M GOOD
AFTERNOON THIS IS YOU ARE NOT
THINKING TARA- ON BEING OF RE
ENTITIES ALL RUN THROUGH
QUICKLY- IRVINE RANCH WATER
DISTRICT AT THE PORT OF
PROPOSED SPENDING FOR ISSUE TWO
I THANK YOU TO THAT LEADERSHIP
WILL BRING THAT FORWARD-
PARTICULAR EMPHASIS ON ME A
BILLION DOLLARS FOR A REAR AGES
AS WELL AS OTHER ELEMENTS OF
THE PACKAGE. ALSO FOR EAST
VALLEY WATER DISTRICT- WHO
WANTS TO PARTICULARLY THANK-
LEADERSHIP AND OTHERS FOR THE
INCLUSION OF THE SEPTIC- DOES
YOUR CONVERSION ISSUE I WHICH
WILL ENHANCE WATER QUALITY AND
HAPPILY GROUNDWATER DEPENDENT
AREA- AND ALSO FOR YOU BUT
WATER AGENCY- WITH A PARTICULAR
EMPHASIS- AND GRATITUDE FOR THE
ATMOSPHERIC RIVER RELATED FROM
FUNDING BY ROW FUNDING. AND
SIGMA FUNDING THANK YOU. THE
THANK YOU RIGHT EIGHTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS IS
ANDREA EVAN TURNER WITH CLEAN
WATER ACTION AND I'D LIKE TO
COMMENT ON ITEM NUMBER ONE
REGARDING THE TSC- I WILL BE
VERY BLUNT HERE AND SAY THAT
WAS A LITTLE DISAPPOINTED TO
HEAR THE FEELING- THAT DID WE
WERE IN A GREAT PLACE AND THIS
NEEDED TO MOVE FORWARD WELL WE
ABSOLUTELY DO SUPPORT. FUNDING
FOR DGSE WE UNDERSTAND THAT THE
AGENCY BY NO MEANS CAN CONTINUE
FUNCTIONING WITHOUT PROPER AND
FIFTEEN A BILL FUNDING- WE ARE
CURRENTLY STRUGGLING WITH THIS
ISSUE THIS YEAR BECAUSE WHILE
WE'RE LISTENING TO THE
ADMINISTRATION NEEDS WE'RE ALSO
LISTENING TO COMMUNITIES WHO
REALLY ARE SAYING NO WE NEED TO
SEE THE STRUCTURAL CHANGES
FIRST WE REALLY NEED TO SEE
THAT. BOB DISCUSSION IS
HAPPENING AND THE BAND IS GOING
TO BE VERY CLEAR BEFORE WE HAND
OVER THE CHEQUE SO TO SPEAK AND
WE'RE TRYING TO FIND THE
BALANCE BETWEEN GETTING THEM
THE MONEY TO EXCEED AND MAKING
SURE THAT WE HAVE THAT
ASSURANCE THAT THEY WILL BE
REAL CHANGES MALE PERFORMANCE-
INITIATIVES PUT FORWARD SO WE
ARE CONCERNED CAN CAN YOU ONLY
A CONTINUING TO BE IN THE
DISCUSSIONS WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION WITH THE
LEGISLATURE- AROUND AB ONE. AND
ALL OF THE VARIOUS INITIATIVES
AROUND AGAINST THE REFORM TO
MAKE SURE IT BAD HAPPENS BEFORE
THE BUDGET IS FINALIZED SO
WE'RE NOT QUITE THERE YET AND
WE WANTED TO PUT THAT ON THE
RECORD THE LAST THING I WOULD
MENTION IS- I WANT YOU TO
RESPOND BECAUSE I RESPECTED THE
QUESTION- TO SENATOR WHAT
COUNTIES QUESTION ABOUT. WHY
SHOULD THE SENATE BE PLAIN A-
IN CHOOSING BOARD. AND J. KIND
OF- YOU KNOW PUTTING IN ALL IN
ON THAT AND I DON'T THE THAT WE
MADE BUT WE WOULD LIKE TO SEE
THAT NOT ONLY BECAUSE IT
PROVIDES ADDITIONAL OVERSIGHT
FROM THE LEGISLATURE NOT JUST
THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICES POINT OF
VIEW OF WHO SHOULD SERVE ON
THAT BOARD. BUT ALSO PROVIDES A
PUBLIC FORUM BY WHICH THE
PUBLIC CAN WEIGH IN ON MEMBERS
OF THE DGSE BOARD THAT THE
BEING PROPOSED- WE WOULD ALSO
LIKE TO SEE A REAL EXPERTISE ON
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE INCLUDED
ON THE BOARD NOT JUST AS AN
AFTERTHOUGHT. AND WITH THAT ALL
INTO MY COMMENTS AND I THANK
YOU FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY. NEXT
NEXT. THANK YOU I'M SEVENTY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON TURN MEMBERS
CONCERNING DOLLARS WILL
INCREASE ACTION AND I'M USED TO
I'LL BE SPEAKING ABOUT HER
BUDGET PLAN ON TROUT STATE
DRINKING WATER AND REPAIR
SYSTEMS- COLLECTION CLEAN WATER
ACTION SUPPORT SYSTEM THE
PROPOSAL TO PROVIDE FUNDING TO
RESOLVE CUSTOMER UTILITY DEBT
AND WOULD LIKE TO ASK- AND-
WOULD LIKE TO. RE ENTER EITHER
NEARLY 12% OF CALIFORNIA
HOUSEHOLDS WILL DEMOCRATS WATER
DEBT DURING THE PANDEMIC OF THE
STATE WATER BOARD ESTIMATES THE
LEVEL OF INTERNATIONAL WATER
DEBT A ONE BILLION IN JANUARY
OF THIS YEAR WITH A TOTAL
RISING BY HUNDRED MILLION PER
MONTH- THAT LEVELS. AND WE
CAN'T WE CAN'T HAVE A JOB TO
COVER YOU STOLE SO MANY OF OUR
MOST VULNERABLE RESIDENTS
BURIED BY WATER DANCE- SO THE
SENATE PACKAGE- OH SORRY WE
ALSO WE URGE OF THESE FUNDS BE
APPLIED AS OFFICIALLY POSSIBLE
TO DIRECTLY REDUCE CUSTOMER
DEBRA ALSO DOING RESIDENTIAL
CUSTOMERS. TO ENSURE THEY STAY
CONNECTED IN CENTRAL WATER AND
ENERGY UTILITY SERVICES
ADDITIONALLY WE ALSO STRONGLY
SUPPORT THE SENATE PROPOSAL TO
PROVIDE FIVE HUNDRED MILLION
FOR JOHN MERGING SHE FUNDING
FOR LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES
ALONG WITH ADDITIONAL. FUNDING
FOR OTHER GOT NEEDS. BECAUSE
COME CAN YOU ACROSS KNOWN
NUMBER AND YOU CAN. WELCOME TO
GO TO. IN SOME OF THE STATE IT.
AND SO I MENTIONED IN- BY A
COMMITTEE MEMBERS- THAT. YOU
KNOW NEED TO BE MORE ACROSS. IN
AND BE PREPARED. COMPARE TO
LAST YEAR OUT- AND FOR THE
MONEY TO. YOU KNOW ELECTION NOW
THAT WE KNOW WE'RE GOING TO
BORN THE STRAW AND TO IT
PROTECT RESIDENTS ARE ASSIST
ACCESS TO DRINKING WATER- AND
WE ALL FURTHER WE ALSO WELCOME
THE CONGRESS FOR FUND CARD WITH
THE STATE WATER BOARD PROGRAM.
YOU KNOW GALLON ACCESS CAN GO
SUSTAINABILITY ARE YOU KNOW
VERY MUCH CONNECTED AND SO WE
ALSO SUPPORT THE PROPOSAL TO
PROVIDE THREE HUNDRED FIFTY
MILLION FOR SIGNAL
AMPLIFICATION. OUR ORGANIZATION
HAS PROVIDED RECOMMENDATIONS
ALREADY TO THE BUDGET COMMITTEE
ARE- TO GUIDE SIEGMUND DUSTIN
AND- MAINLY IN A MULTI BENEFIT
PROJECTS THAT PROTECT TO
RESTORE WATER QUALITY IN
GROUNDWATER LEVELS IN
COMMUNITIES DEPENDENT ON
KHALKHAL OWNS AND YOU KNOW ALSO
TRYING TO ACT- I'M- GOING TO
TECHNICAL SYSTEMS- TO. THE
VARIOUS COMMUNITIES TO
PARTICIPATE IN DECISION MAKING
THAT AFFECTS OUR WATER SUPPLIES
AND COMMUNITIES BECAUSE NO
EQUITABLE COMMUNITY REALLY
CRITICAL- AND. DIGITAL AND-
WITH THAT I'D LIKE TO READ IT
MAY COME AND DIG FOR YOUR TIME
LEADERS ON ISSUE. THANK YOU
NEXT. THANK YOU I FIFTY FIVE
PLEASE AHEAD. COULD NOT
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS THIS IS
MARLENE MAINE WITH THE EAST BAY
MUNICIPAL UTILITY DISTRICT YEAH
HERE TO EXPRESS SUPPORT FOR
ITEM NUMBER TWO AND- PARTICULAR
APPRECIATION FOR THE ONE
BILLION DOLLARS PROPOSED FOR
THE RATE ASSISTANCE. WE'VE SEEN
OUR OUR UTILITY RARE JUST FOR
WATER AND WASTEWATER DEBT
INCREASED DRAMATICALLY DURING
THE PANDEMIC AND THIS WILL BE A
WELCOME LIFELINE FOR MANY OF
OUR CUSTOMERS. THANK YOU.
WELCOME NEXT. THANK YOU RIGHT
EIGHTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES
GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS GREG
MORRISON ON THE GOVERNMENT
RELATIONS OFFICER FOR ELSEWHERE
VALLEY MUNICIPAL WATER DISTRICT
IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA. I
REALLY APPRECIATE THE SENATE
LEADERSHIP ON THIS ISSUE AND WE
FULLY SUPPORT THE DROUGHT
RELIEF PACKAGE THAT YOU HAVE-
BEFORE YOU TODAY AND WE WOULD
LIKE TO PUT EVEN A FINER POINT
ON THE ONE BILLION DOLLARS FOR
THE- CUSTOMERS UTILITY BACKLOG
OF BILLS AND RESURGENT AND THAT
CONCLUDES MY COMMENT THANK YOU.
NECKS THANK YOU RYAN SIXTEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. I'M NOT WRONG
THEY WERE NOT GOING. WE ARE
NINE SIXTEEN THREE. OKAY GOOD
MORNING THIS IS SPEECH ONE OF
OUR WITH THE CITY OF LODI WE
HAVE BUT WE'RE I'M SPEAKING IN
SUPPORT OF THE- THE EFFORT US
THIS UTILITIES AND RATEPAYERS
WITH OPEN RELATED THAT WE HAVE
SEEN AN INCREASE IN OUR NET
NINETY DAYS PAST DUE FROM A
QUARTER MILLION ON AVERAGE IT
TWO AND A QUARTER MILLION. MANY
OF OUR RATE PAYERS HAVE
BALANCES THAT HAVE BUILT UP TO
WELL OVER TWO THOUSAND DOLLARS
AND MANY OF THEM WILL STRUGGLE
MIGHTILY TO RECOVER FROM THAT
WITHOUT THIS ASSISTANCE AND SO
WE WANT TO EXPRESS OUR SUPPORT
AND APPRECIATION. FOR YOUR
ACTION NOT REGARD THANK YOU.
NECKS THANK YOU I'M FIFTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. I GET
AFTERNOON SHARING MEMBERS
PASANEN ON BEHALF OF THE CITY
OF SANTA CRUZ WATER DEPARTMENT
AND BUILDING AT BALLY BIG BEN
GROUNDWATER THEY HAVE THAT
WOULD BE A STATE OUT WE ARE
VERY SUPPORTIVE OF THAT THAT
PROPOSAL FOR DROUGHT RELIEF
PACKAGE AS OUTLINED IN TO TAKE
THE CHANCE THAT. HOWEVER WE
WOULD LIKE TO ECHO THE COMMENTS
HAS BEEN AGGRESSIVE TURN AND
THEN- WHAT FUNDING IS LIKELY
NEEDED ACROSS ALL OF THE
PROGRAM AREAS INCLUDING THANK
YOU BYE AND ALSO FUNDING. FOR
INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECTS- THANK
YOU FOR YOUR LEADERS ON THE
PART ISSUE. YOU'RE WELCOME NOW.
THANK YOU RYAN FORTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS MARKET THAT
WHILE OVER THE CALIFORNIA
SPECIAL DISTRICTS ASSOCIATION
CALLING IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
AGENDA ITEM NUMBER TWO THE
SENATE DROP BUDGET PLAN WHICH
THE FDA BELIEVES WOULD PROVIDE
NEEDED INVESTMENT STRENGTHENED
COMMUNITY WATER RESILIENCY AND
WOULD BRING NECESSARY RELIEF TO
RATEPAYERS THEREBY STABILIZING
OPERATIONAL BUDGET OF LOCAL
AGENCIES WHO HAVE BEEN IMPACTED
BY NON PAYMENT OF THAT. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME. YOU'RE
WELCOME NEXT. THANK YOU RYAN
SEVENTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI MY NAME IS BORN AGAIN I'M
I'M CALLING ON BEHALF OF THE
LOS ANGELES ALLIANCE BRING YOUR
CALLING ME ON ITEMS YOU WEAR
AND STRONG SUPPORT OF THE
SENATE PROPOSAL COULD PROVIDE
ONE MILLION DOLLARS IN FUNDING
FOR WATER AND PUBLIC UTILITY
EVERY ORIGIN AND GIVEN OUR WORK
WITH THE DWP CUSTOMERS AND
UNDERSTANDING THE CONCERNS THAT
THEY ARE FACING WE HOPE THAT
THIS DISCUSSION CAN CLARIFY
THAT THE THREE ASSISTANCE IS
ALSO. AVAILABLE BOTH YOUR
CUSTOMERS STRUGGLING WITH WATER
WHICH HAVE WE KNOW IT'S A HUGE
CONCERN STATEWIDE AS WELL AS
THE ENERGY UTILITY THAT AND TO
CONSIDER ADDITIONAL FUNDING TO
MEET THAT ENERGY THAT NEEDS-
THE THUNDER ESPECIALLY CRUCIAL
PART PUBLICLY OWNED ENERGY
UTILITIES WHERE THE DATA IS
ESTIMATED AT OVER THREE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS ACROSS THE
STATE GIVEN THE WAY THAT PROP
TWENTY SIXTEEN TO EIGHTEEN
PLACE RESTRICTIONS ON OTHER
FORMS OF REPAIR ASSISTANCE FOR
THOSE UTILITIES. AND WE WENT
ACT- THAT EARLIER SUPPORT
RESPOND TO BE ABLE TO BE
APPLIED TO THE FISH ONLY IF
POSSIBLE TO DIRECTLY REDUCE
THAT THAT THAT ARE STRUGGLING
MEMBERS ARE FACING- AND
ENSURING THAT THEY STAY
CONNECTED TO THEIR WATER AND
ENERGY UTILITIES AND ECHO
THANKS AS WELL FOR THE ALL THE
CONSIDERATIONS AROUND DROUGHT
RESILIENCE AND- WATER RECYCLING
AS WELL FROM LOS ANGELES AND
WHAT SENATOR STERN LIFTED UP IN
TERMS OF OUR GOALS THERE. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR THE
CONSIDERATION. WELL NET. THANK
YOU RIGHT NOW FOUR PLEASE AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS
BRIAN I GOT- ON BEHALF OF THE
RURAL COMMUNITY ASSISTANCE
CORPORATION ITSELF ALL IN OUR
PRICES ON OUR- EXPRESS OUR
STRONG SUPPORT FOR THE DROUGHT
PACKAGE IN COMMAND. CHAIR IN
LEADERSHIP FOR THEIR WORK ON
THAT ONE A NOTE A COUPLE OF IN
PARTICULAR OBVIOUSLY THE MEDIA
THANK YOU WATER RELIEF
INCLUDING SUPPORT FOR
INTERMITTENTLY FOR THOSE OF
LOST ACCESS. TO WELLS AT THIS.
DROUGHT CONTINUE AND EXPANDS WE
KNOW AND THEIR FAMILIES ARE
GOING TO CONTINUE TO LOSE
ACCESS TO WELCOME EACH AND
ARMED SOLUTIONS ONE ALSO BUT
MANY HAVE. RESTAURANTS SUPPORT
FOR THE RATE PAYER AND
COMMUNITY SYSTEM RELIEF TO
ROUND THE CORNER WORKING ON THE
DETAILS ON THAT AND ALSO THE
SUPPORT. FOR SEPTIC IN OTHER
WAYS WATER NEED GLAD CONTINUES
TO BE A CRITICAL NEED AND
WORKPLACE SHE GOT PART OF THIS
PACKAGE. THANK YOU MISTER.
YOU'RE WELCOME NEXT. THANK YOU
RIGHT EIGHTY SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU HELLO MISTER
TURN MEMBERS THIS IS BOB EURO
ON BEHALF OF THREE ENTITIES THE
WESTLANDS WATER DISTRICT THE
WATER REPLENISHMENT DISTRICT OF
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA IN THE SAN
DIEGO COUNTY WATER AUTHORITY
ALL EXPRESSED STRONG SUPPORT
FOR THE PRO TEMS AND THE SENATE
LEADERSHIP'S DROUGHT PACKAGE
WE'D LIKE TO THANK THE
LEADERSHIP AND THE LEADERSHIP
STAFF AND YOUR STAFF MISTER
CHAIR- FOR WESTLANDS WE
PARTICULARLY LIKE TO FOCUS ON
SOME SEGMENT FUNDING SERVICE
WATER INFRASTRUCTURE. AND WE
ALSO SUPPORT INCREASED
MONITORING AND POLICING OF
ILLEGAL DO WATER DIVERSIONS.
FOR THE WATER REPLENISHMENT
DISTRICT WE LIKE THE FUNDING
FOR P. FIVE THOUSAND PEOPLE
OBVIOUSLY WE HOPE IT'S A GOOD
START BECAUSE WE'LL NEED A LOT
MORE FOR THE CLEAN UP DOWN
THERE IN PERSON YOU GO WE'D
LIKE TO EXPRESS OUR
APPRECIATION FOR THE ENTIRE
DROUGHT PACKAGE FOR WATER
RECYCLING AND FOR. THE ZERO
ESCAPING IN THE SHOVEL READY
PROJECTS WE WOULD ALSO LIKE TO
THANK THE COMMITTEE FOR A YEAR
MOVEMENT ON RATE RELIEF. THANK
YOU. WELCOME CONNECTS. THANK
YOU RIGHT EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
AFTERNOON MISTER SHARON
SENATORS LUCAS BURKE FROM HALF
THE NATURE CONSERVANCY THE
NATURE CONSERVANCY STRONGLY
SUPPORTS THE SENATE BUDGET PLAN
DROUGHT- THE PLAN WILL HELP
ENSURE THAT A PORTABLE DRINKING
WATER IS AVAILABLE TO ALL
CALIFORNIANS ALSO PROVIDING
IMMEDIATE INVESTMENTS IN
SCIENCE THE MEASURE DROUGHT
IMPACT FUNDING TO SUPPORT
SUSTAINABLE GROUNDWATER
MANAGEMENT. ACTIONS TO SECURE
WATER FOR PEOPLE FISH AND
WILDLIFE WE APPRECIATE THE
SENATE LEADERSHIP ON THIS
PRESSING ISSUE IN RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR AYE VOTE. NECKS
THANK YOU RIGHT EIGHTY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI GERRY LINK
WITH THE NORTHERN CALIFORNIA
WATER ASSOCIATION KNOCK WAS
SUPPORTS MANY OF THE MULTI
BENEFICIAL ONE TIME FUNDING
PROPOSALS AND LOOKS FORWARD TO
CONTINUE WORKING WITH THE
SENATE ASSEMBLY AND THE GUMS
OFFICE ON THIS PROACTIVE
DROUGHT PREPARATION. ISSUE TOO
THANK YOU GUYS VERY MUCH. NEXT.
THANK YOU I NINETY ONE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN NUMBER THANK YOU TO
CRAPPIE BUT THE NATURAL
RESOURCES DEFENSE COUNCIL AND
IF YOU FEEL LIKE TO ALIGN MY
COMMENTS WITH THOSE OF THE
UNDERCOUNTER OF THE CLEAN WATER
ACTION AND HE SUPPORTS THE
SENATE PROPOSED DROUGHT PACKAGE
WHICH PRIORITISES IMMEDIATE
FUNDING TO PROVIDE THE PERSONAL
WATER FOR LOW INCOME AND
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES AT
RISK. WE SUPPORT INVESTMENT TO
MAKE CALIFORNIA MORE RESILIENT
TO DROUGHT IMPROVE WATER USE
EFFICIENCY ON FARMS AND CITIES
THEIR PROGRAMS LIKE FEET EXPAND
WATER RECYCLING ALL OF WHICH
ARE THE FASTEST AND CHEAPEST
WAY IS TO STRETCH LIMITED WATER
SUPPLY IN THE PACKAGE ALSO
INCLUDES IMPORTANT FUNDING TO
SUPPORT MONITORING FOR HARMFUL
ALGAL BLOOMS OF THE DELTA WHICH
MAY CAUSE HUMAN HEALTH RISK
BECAUSE OF VIOLATIONS OF WATER
QUALITY STANDARDS THE SUMMER.
OF ALL FUNDING TO ADDRESS
IMPACT THE FAMINE OF WILDLIFE
REFUGES AND OTHER NEED A
QUESTION BY LIKE THE THING
GROWN A CONDITION HERE AND
FINALLY AND IMPORTANTLY ENERGY
STRONGLY SUPPORTS THE ONE
BILLION DOLLARS OF PROPOSED
FUNDING FOR PUBLIC UTILITY BILL
RELEASED FOR CALIFORNIANS FOR
FACING YOU FACTORING AMOUNT OF
UTILITY THAT. OF ALL THE
LOOMING THREAT OF WATER AND
POWER SHUT OFF OF THE WEATHER
AND RECOVER FROM THE PENTOMIC
LIKE TO THINK SENATE BUDGET
LEADERSHIP AND YOUR STAFF FOR
THIS IMPORTANT AND TIMELY
PROPOSAL AND THANK YOU. FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TAP I THANK.
YOU'RE WELCOME NEXT. THANK YOU
I AM SICK ONE PLEASE AHEAD. HI
MY NAME IN THE DRAFTTO SEND ON
RACE POVERTY THE ENVIRONMENT
SPEAKING ON HIS ONE THAT EACH
YEAR THE PACKAGE STE I'M THE
ONE THAT WE DO RECOGNIZE AND
WE'VE BEEN PUSHING FOR MANY
YEARS AS A MECHANISM AND
STRUCTURES FOR ACCOUNTABILITY
TRANSPARENCY EJECTING AND FOR
THAT REASON WE DO SUPPORT THE
ESTABLISHMENT OF THE
ENVIRONMENT THANK YOU FOR IT.
STE HOWEVER IN ORDER TO SUCCEED
THE BOARD MUST BE DESIGNED
AFTER PROVIDE ACCOUNTABILITY AN
IMPORTANT FIRST STEP THE BOARD
MUST BE AUTHORIZED AND DIRECTED
TO ESTABLISH ON TRAFFIC WOMAN
STANDARDS- AND BENCHMARKS. AND
WE MUST BE INFORMED THROUGH A
PUBLIC PROCESS AND AFTER
GATHERING FEEDBACK FROM
IMPACTED COMMUNITIES- CERTAINLY
THE- THE BOARD MUST BE
DESIGNED. TO PROVIDE
CONSEQUENCES IF THE AGENCY
FAILED TO MEET BENCHMARKS AND
SO I DO THINK THAT THERE'S
ADDITIONAL COMPLICATIONS NEEDED
IN ORDER TO ENSURE THAT THE
ACCOUNTABILITY STRUCTURE THAT
WE'RE PUTTING IN PLACE ARE
DESIGNED TO PROVIDE THAT
ACCOUNTABILITY AND ENSURE THAT
YOU CAN'T SEE AS MEETING ITS
CONFORMANCE STANDARDS AND OUR
EXPECTATION THAT THE STATE. IS
SECONDLY IN TERMS OF THE THREE
MILLION DOLLARS WE DO HAVE
CONCERNS ABOUT PRIORITIZING
CONTAMINATED SITE WILL BE USED
AS HOUSING FOR AFFORDABLE-
HOUSING FOR LOW INCOME
RESIDENTS. IN IN ONE OF OUR
COMMUNITY. HOUSING AS- SENATE-
I KEPT NOTED GOING TO MOST
SENSITIVE RESULTS. I'M BUT YOU
CAN'T AN REQUIRED BUT- YOU. HOW
TO MOW RARE- RESUME ARE A
REQUIRED THE MO CLEAN UP AND
FRANKLY- WHAT WE HAVE SEEN FROM
THE JEFF TIMES OF TRACTOR FOR
UP LEAVES A LOT TO BE DESIRED
INPUT PEOPLE IN HARM'S I USED
TO BE. TALK SIDE- IS THE
CONCERNED TO US. WE DO SEE THE
NEW- TO DESIGN MORE WITH THE-
APPROACH DEALING WITH THE TWO
HUNDRED. THOUSAND ODD
BROWNFIELD I THOUGHT IN
CALIFORNIA AND WE SHOULD USE
THE OPPORTUNITY NOT FOR ONE
TIME FIX BUDGET BABBLERS. I'M A
LONGSTANDING. APPROACH AND
FUNDING STRUCTURE THAT WILL
PROMOTE WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
AND CLEAN UP COMMUNITIES IN
THE- ARM WE ALSO SEE THIS IS AN
IMPORTANT CONVERSATION TO HAVE
ON THE SYNERGIES. FOR THE
STATE'S NEED TO REMEDIATE NOT
ONLY GROUND FIELD BUT ALSO ARE
THE STATE'S OIL FIELD. AND WE
SHOULD EXPLORE SOLUTION BUT
LABOR AND UNIONS- TO DEVELOP A
CALIFORNIA REMEDIATION WORK
FORCE- THAT. THAT WOULD SERVE
MULTIPLE PURPOSES AND BE A LONG
AND SELECTION. THANK. YOU THANK
YOU NECKS. THANK YOU VERY
NINETY. PLEASE GO AHEAD. SURE
NUMBERS THIS IS JAMIE GIRL ON
BEHALF OF ENVIRONMENTAL DEFENSE
FUND WE'D LIKE TO EXPRESS
SUPPORT FOR THE DROUGHT
PROPOSAL AND MOST MORE
SPECIFICALLY THE FUNDING FOR
SEGMENT IN THE PACKAGE AND THE
ANSWER IS THE SECOND DRY YOUR
IN A ROW INVESTMENT ENSURE
SUCCESSFUL THINK MEDICAL
MEDICATION ARE ESSENTIAL WE
ENCOURAGE THE LEGISLATURE TO
ENSURE THAT THESE RESOURCES.
ADVANCE STRATEGIC LAND
REPURPOSE IN AFRICA AND EQUIP
FARMERS WITH THE TOOLS AND
EQUIPMENT NEEDED TO SUSTAINABLY
MANAGE GROUNDWATER RESOURCES.
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO PROVIDE COMMENT. THANK YOU
NEXT. EIGHT YOU RAIMES SIXTEEN
PLEASE GO OUT. GOOD AFTERNOON
KERRY COMMITTEE MEMBERS- RHINO
JACKING WITH THE REGIONAL WATER
AUTHORITY- HERE IN SUPPORT OF
ITEM NUMBER TO THE DROUGHT
PACKAGE ONE I COMMEND THE CHAIR
AND SENATE LEADERSHIP ON
ADVANCING THAT PACKAGE- IN
PARTICULAR WHILE WE SUPPORT THE
ENTIRE PACKAGE BUT IN
PARTICULAR WANT TO HIGHLIGHT
THE NEED TO KEEP. MOVING
FORWARD WITH THE RESILIENT
WATER INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECT WE
THINK ABOUT AND ALLOW ME BOTH
SHORT TERM LONG TERM LOCAL
STATEWIDE PEOPLE AND
ENVIRONMENTAL NEEDS I WOULD
THINK THAT THAT CONSTITUTES
WALKING AND CHEWING GUM AND I
WANT TO KEEP DOING THAT WITH-
ADVANCING ABOUT THE SAME- KIND
OF INVESTMENT THROUGH A BOND
MEASURE AS WELL. THANKS FOR THE
TIME. I THAT I NECKS. THANK YOU
RIDE ONE HUNDRED PLEASE GO
AHEAD. WELL THIS IS PATRICK
WHAT THE CALIFORNIA MUNICIPAL
UTILITIES ASSOCIATION
REPRESENTING PUBLIC WATER
AGENCIES AND PUBLICLY OWNED
ELECTRIC UTILITIES. WOULD LIKE
TO APPLAUD THE SENATE
SUBCOMMITTEE TODAY FOR THEIR
ACTIONS ADVANCE A MUCH NEEDED
FUNDING PACKAGE THAT WOULD
BOLSTER PROJECTS AND PROGRAMS
ADDRESSING DROUGHT RESILIENCY.
BUT OTHERS SPEAKERS WE ARE
PARTICULARLY GRATEFUL THAT THE
PROPOSED INCLUDE SIGNIFICANT
FUNDING HOW CALIFORNIANS PAID
OR UNPAID WATER AND ELECTRIC
BILLS THE PACKAGE WOULD
MITIGATE THE IMPACT OF THE
DROUGHT HELP STRUGGLING
HOUSEHOLDS INSTEAD OF THE WHOLE
RECOVER FROM THE PANDEMIC
ECONOMIC AND SOCIAL IMPACTS. WE
LOOK FORWARD TO ADVOCATING FOR
INCLUSION IS FUNDING PACKAGE IN
THE FINAL BUDGET AND WORKING
TOGETHER WITH YOU. TED BILL
BACK BOLDLY THANK YOU. MAX
THANK YOU RIDE ONE ON ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS A KINDRED
GO WITH THE LOCAL GROUP WE
APPRECIATE THE EFFORTS OF THE
SENATE AND- THE STAFF ON ITEM
NUMBER TWO- THE MODESTO
IRRIGATION DISTRICT SUPPORTS
THE SENATE DROUGHT PACKAGE IN
PARTICULAR STIGMA- FUNDING AND
FUNDING FOR CUSTOMER ASSISTANCE
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
WINE GRAPE GROWERS SUPPORTS
FUNDING FOR THE CONSTRUCTION
AND REFURBISHMENT OF SMALL
AGGREGATION PONDS WE FEEL IT'S
A SMART WAY TO SAVE WATER
DURING STORM EVENTS FOR USE
DURING DRY MONTHS. THE LONG
BEACH WATER DISTRICT
APPRECIATES THE FUNDING TO HELP
RATE PAYERS RECOVER FROM THE
CODE NINETEEN ECONOMIC IMPACTS
AND ON BEHALF OF THE CITY OF
ROSEVILLE THEY'RE SUPPORTIVE OF
THE ENTIRE SENATE DROUGHT
PACKAGE AND APPRECIATE THE
INCLUSION OF FUNDING TO HELP
THOSE HARDEST HIT DURING THE
PANDEMIC TO ADDRESS PAST YOU
UTILITY BILLS AND IN
PARTICULAR- FUNDING THAT IS-
IDENTIFIED FOR T. W. R. THAT
WOULD BE BENEFICIAL FOR MANY OF
THEIR PROJECTS I THANK YOU SO
MUCH. WELCOME NEXT. THANK YOU
RYAN WHITE OH SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS AND WENDY
ROBUST WITH COUNTY STYLE WE
SUPPORT KIND OF NUMBER YOU THE
BUDGET DROUGHT RELIEF PACKAGE
THANK YOU. NECKS. THANK YOU
RYAN WON ALL FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON REBEKAH
BACKEND ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA
CITRUS MUTUAL ANOTHER ACT
CLIENTS I WOULD FIRST LIKE TO
THANK THE SENATE FOR THEIR
LEADERSHIP ON DEVELOPING THE
TROPICAL LOW I WOULD APPRECIATE
THE MONEY ALLOCATED PROTECT MY
BUT WOULD LIKE TO SEE AN
ADDITIONAL ADDITIONAL MONEY.
OPPOSED CLOSER TO ONE BILLION
DOLLARS FOR THE IMPLEMENTATION
THERE WILL BE SIGNIFICANT
IMPACT AT THE MENTORING THIS
DROUGHT AND ADDS THAT THE DAY
THERE ARE SEVERAL SHOVEL READY
PROJECT THAT COULD BENEFIT FROM
THE PROPOSED GRANT THAT
SUPPORTS THAT MY IMPLEMENTATION
WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
YOU FURTHER ON THAT THANK YOU
FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP ON THIS
ISSUE. THANK YOU YOU'RE WELCOME
NECKS. THANK YOU RIGHT NINETY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
MACKLER WITH THE INTERNET BY
THEIR BEHALF OF THE SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC POWER
AUTHORITY CALLING IMPORTANT
ISSUE NUMBER TWO DIFFERENT
BUDGET PLAN ON DROUGHT RELIEF.
IN PARTICULAR WE ARE VERY
APPRECIATIVE OF THE PROPOSED
ONE BILLION DOLLARS TO HELP
UTILITY CUSTOMERS AND UTILITIES
ADDRESS BACKLOG BUILD AND WE'RE
JUST YOU TO CO THAT ECONOMIC
IMPACT AND WE THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND THE SENATE. FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP ON THIS ISSUE YEAH.
WELCOME NEXT. THANK YOU RIGHT
ONE OH EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
MRS MARC THANK YOU MAKER ON
BEHALF OF SONOMA WATER WATER
AGENCIES SERVING SONOMA COUNTY
ONE STRONG SUPPORT AN ITEM TO
THE PROPOSED DROUGHT PACKAGE.
THANK YOU TO THE COMMITTEE
SENATE LEADERSHIP AND STAFF TO
THE TIME AND WORK THEIR WAY
INTO PUTTING TOGETHER THIS MUCH
IN THE PROPOSAL I THANK YOU
SOME GENERAL ACQUIRE. HELLO
REGION. IF YOU SAW THE IMAGES
FROM THE GOVERNOR'S CONFERENCE
LAST WEEK LAKE MENDOCINO CAN
YOU KNOW HOW EXTREME OUR
SITUATION AND HOW QUICKLY WE
NEED THIS FUNDING PACKAGE NOW.
WE SUPPORT THE WHOLE PACKAGE
BEDS THIS BIKE TO SPECIFICALLY
CALL OUT. OF SUPPORT FOR THE
FUNDING TO DO W. R. FOR
PROJECTS THAT INCLUDE.
PRECIPITATION FORECASTING. FOR
HOUSTON FORECAST INFORMED
RESERVOIR OPERATIONS WORK ZERO.
ZERO ENABLE US TO HOLD BACK AN
EXTRA ELEVEN THOUSAND ACRE FEET
AT LAKE MENDOCINO. ONE OF THE
OTHERWISE WOULD HAVE BEEN
RELEASED UNDER OUTDATED ROCKERS
FROM THE ARMY CORPS. THAT
ELEVEN THOUSAND ACRE FEET IS
BASICALLY ONE THIRD OF A LOT
OF. MY CATHOLIC MENDOCINO AND
SHOWS HOW VITAL THIS EFFORT IS
FOR OUR REGION AND ALSO WHAT
OPPORTUNITIES ARE HAD FOR THE
REST OF CALIFORNIA TO BE BETTER
EQUIPPED. TO DEAL WITH DROUGHT
THANK YOU SO MUCH. YOU'RE
WELCOME NEXT. THANK YOU RIGHT
ONE OH SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
CAITLYN CLUE WHAT I AM BECAUSE
THE MANAGER FOR THE COMPANY
COULD KEEPER LINE- WE ARE
ENCOURAGED AND SUPPORTED YOUNG
THE ITEM NUMBER TWO THE SENATE
BUDGET PROPOSAL ON DROUGHT AND
WATER WATER SUPPLY RELIABILITY
IN GREAT CARE SYSTEM. WE
FURTHER ENCOURAGE THE EXPLICIT
INCLUSION AND RECOMMEND AND
THEN INCREASE FUNDING FOR
SHOVEL READY WATER RECYCLING
PROJECTS TO INCREASE LOCAL COST
EFFECTIVE AND ENVIRONMENTALLY
SOUND WATER SUPPLY. AND JUST
THOUGHT AND YOUR SUPPORT TO OUR
WATER MANAGEMENT PROJECT
PROJECT THE TURN TURN TURN
WATER. FROM A LIABILITY INTO
RESOURCE. THE REQUESTED HIM OF
ONE BILL BE. TO RELIEVE
OUTSTANDING WATER UTILITY THAT
LEVERAGES FOR STRUGGLING
CUSTOMERS THE NEED. AND HELP
THE OVERALL SOLVENCY OF
INDIVIDUAL WATER SYSTEMS THANK
YOU. WELCOME TAX. THANK YOU
RYAN WON ALL FOUR PLEASE GO ASK.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR GOT CARE
LIKE OUT THE MEMBERS OF THE
SUBCOMMITTEE MY NAME IS MICHAEL
HADLEY AND I'M THE GOVERNMENT
RELATIONS OFFICER FOR WEST
MUNICIPAL WATER DISTRICT ON
BEHALF OF OUR NEARLY ONE
MILLION CUSTOMERS RESERVE IN
WESTERN RIVERSIDE COUNTY I LIKE
TO EXPRESS OUR STRONG SUPPORT
FOR AI NUMBER TWO IN THIS
PROPOSAL. ESPECIALLY THE ONE
BILLION DOLLARS IN DIRECT
RELIEF UTILITY PUBLIC UTILITY
PROVIDERS ON BEHALF OF OUR
START FINANCIALLY STRESSED
CUSTOMERS THAT HAVE BEEN EVEN
FURTHER NEGATIVELY AFFECTED BY
COVER. NINETEEN THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME AND YOUR LEADERSHIP
ON THESE ISSUES. THE EX. THANK
YOU RYAN ONE I LIVE IN PLEASE
BUT I HAD. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR
AND MEMBERS FAMILIES TO VERO ON
BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA TROUT AND
TROUT UNLIMITED IMPORT OF THE
SENATE DROUGHT RELIEF PACKAGE
WELL WE URGE EVEN FURTHER
INVESTMENT EMERGENCY ALLOCATION
FOR NATIONAL RESOURCES ARE
APPRECIATIVE OF THE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS BUT WE EVEN
EXTREME WELL I CAN'T THE
PROGRAM. SPECIALLY THE SHORT
TERM ACQUISITION IS EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT AND THE FIFTEEN
MILLION DOLLARS FOR THE COASTAL
MONITORING PROGRAM. THANK YOU
SO MUCH. NEXT THANK YOU I ONE
TWELVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. I THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS
CAN HELP YOU KNOW REPRESENTING
DEFENDERS OF WILDLIFE- DEFENDER
STRONGLY SUPPORTS ITEM NUMBER
TWO THE SENATE DROPPED PACKAGE
AND TAX THE SENATE FOR THEIR
LEADERSHIP CALIFORNIA'S FISH
AND WILDLIFE- TAKING DIRE
CONDITIONS DURING THIS
EXTREMELY DRY YEAR AND THE
INVESTMENTS PROPOSED IN THIS
DROUGHT PACKAGE WILL BE
ESSENTIAL. FOR THE PROTECTION
OF THE DECLINE IN FISH AND
WILDLIFE HOWEVER WHAT IS
CRITICAL WELL IT'S CRITICAL TO
HAVE THIS INVESTMENT OF FUNDING
WHAT IS ALSO CRITICAL IS THE
DECISION MADE BY THE STATE AND
FEDERAL AGENCIES TO OPERATING
YES CENTRAL VALLEY PROJECT AND
STATE WATER PROJECT CALIFORNIA
IS POISED TO LOSE 90% OF OUR
WINTER RUN SALMON THIS YEAR DUE
TO WATER MANAGEMENT DECISION. I
WOULD LIKE TO POINT OUT THAT
THE FINAL SLIDE IN THE
PRESENTATION BY RESOURCES
AGENCY AND YOU GET THERE ARE
STATE THAT EITHER WE ARE AND
THE BUREAU PLAN FOR MINIMAL
DELIVERY FROM STATE WATER
PROJECT AND CENTRAL VALLEY
PROJECT THIS YEAR I ACTUALLY IN
REALITY IF YOU'RE A RECLAMATION
IS RUNNING TO DELIVER AN
ENORMOUS AMOUNT OF WATER TO THE
SACRAMENTO RIVER SETTLEMENT
CONTRACTORS. RATHER THAN
KEEPING ENOUGH WATER BEHIND
SHASTA DAM YOU MAINTAIN STATE
TEMPERATURES FOR ENDANGERED
WINTER RUN CHINOOK SALMON AND
ALL AND SUMMER AND THE STATE
BOARD HAS THE AUTHORITY TO
REQUIRE REDUCE DIVERSION HAS
NOT YET TAKEN ACTION. SO WE
URGE THAT THE SENATE NOT ONLY
PROVIDES CRITICAL FUNDING BUT
ALSO ENSURE THAT THOSE AGENCY
YOUR RECEIVING THE MONEY ARE
ACTUALLY USING THEIR FULL
AUTHORITY TO PROTECT
CALIFORNIA'S. FISH AND WILDLIFE
THANK YOU. NECKS THANK YOU WHAT
THIRTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS WHO
ARE STILL WITH US IT WAS THE
BEST BEST AND KRIEGER I'M
CALLING ON BEHALF OF TWO
CLIENTS WHO COULD NOT BE MORE
DIFFERENT ONE OF THE MUNICIPAL
WATER DISTRICT OF ORANGE COUNTY
WHICH IS THE WHOLESALE WATER
PROVIDER FOR ALL OF ORANGE
COUNTY. THE OTHER IS THE BREAK
A WATER DISTRICT WHICH IS A
VERY SMALL ISOLATED WATER
DISTRICT YOU THE AND THE BREAK
A DESERT WHICH FOR THE WHOLE
COMMUNITY QUALIFIES AS THE
SEVERELY DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITY. THAT BOTH THESE
CLIENTS HAVE ASKED ME TO CALL
IN AND EXPRESS SUPPORT FOR ADAM
TO DEMONSTRATE. WHAT A GOOD JOB
THE SENATE HAS DONE IN TRYING
TO ADDRESS THE INCREDIBLE
DIVERSITY OF SACRAMENTO A
CALIFORNIA'S WATER NEEDS. SHE
THOUGHT EFFORT VERY MUCH ON
BEHALF OF BOTH OF THEM WE URGE
SUPPORT CRIED WITH YOU THANK
YOU. NEXT. THANK YOU RIDE ONE
FOURTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN BURKE
THIS IS ROSS BARKLEY ON BEHALF
THE CITY OF SACRAMENTO WE
SUPPORT THE FENCE DROUGHT
PACKAGE IN PARTICULAR
APPRECIATE THE FUNDING FOR
WATER ELECTRIC BILL RAGES HELP
CUSTOMERS IN THE IN THE BILL.
THANK YOU. ZACKS. THANK YOU
RYAN ONE FIFTEEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON JAMIE
MINOR WITH NEMO PAPPAS AND
ASSOCIATES ON BEHALF OF EASTERN
MUNICIPAL WATER DISTRICT IN A
MARGARITA WATER DISTRICT
INTERLOCUTOR GAUGING DISTRICT
OR CALLING SUPPORT FOR ITEM Q.
AND WE TRULY APPRECIATE THE
SENATE CONTINUED LEADERSHIP ON
THIS ISSUE ESPECIALLY
LEADERSHIP STAFF THE DISTRICT
ARE READY TO WRITE THE
CHALLENGED TO INNOVATE AND
DIVERSIFY THEIR PORTFOLIOS. AND
IT'S FUNDING IS CRITICAL TO
ALLOW THEM TO DO SO AT THE
SPECIFICALLY WE APPRECIATE THE
INCLUSION OF FUNDING. FOR
SEPTIC TO SEWER CONVERSION. NO
THIRD A TECHNO. WATER RECYCLING
WATER EFFICIENCY PROJECTS IN
AGRICULTURAL REGION I WE ALSO
APPRECIATE THAT BILLION DOLLAR
OF THE WEEK FOR RATE PAYERS
STRUGGLING WITH LARGE BUILD
THAT- ESPECIALLY IN SOME OF THE
HARDEST HIT REGIONS IN OUR
STATE. THANK THANK THANK AGAIN.
NECKS. THANK YOU RYAN ONE
SIXTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MISTER KAREN
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
RAVI THOMPSON WITH METROPOLITAN
WATER DISTRICT OF SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA I'M EXPECTING
SUPPORT FOR ITEM TO THE SENATE
DROUGHT PACKAGE WE BELIEVE THE
PROPOSED PACKAGE CRIED
NECESSARY FUNDING TO ADDRESS
CHALLENGES RELATED TO WATER
SUPPLIES SUCH AS ADVANCING
RECYCLED WATER FOR POTABLE
REUSE AS WELL AS P. FIVE. AT
MONITORING AND TREATMENT WE
BELIEVE THIS WILL BENEFIT OUT
OF THE FUNDING WILL BENEFIT ALL
CATEGORIES- WITH A VALUABLE ONE
TIME OPPORTUNITY. FUNDING THANK
YOU FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION.
NEXT THANK YOU RYAN ONE TWENTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU TERM
MEMBERS THE VEHICLE DEVELOPED
COMMUNITY WATER CENTER AND
THANK YOU TO THE SENATE FOR
THEIR LEADERSHIP ON THE
PACKAGE- WE SEE HOW DRIVE
DROUGHT WILDFIRE AND- A GROUND
OVERDRAFT IN COMMUNITIES IN THE
NOSE DIVE SO THAT WHEN THE
PRODUCT IS THAT BECAUSE THEY
MANY OF THESE WATERS AT THE
TRUMP FAILURE AND PROTECT
COMMUNITY WATER SUPPLIES. YOU
TO BE B. AND NEGLIGENCE WRONG
OR THE SENATE PROPOSAL TO
PROVIDE FIVE HUNDRED MILLION OR
THE FUNDING FOR LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES ALONG WITH
ADDITIONAL FUNDING PER JOB
NEEDS- WE ALSO WELCOME FOR THE
CONVERSATION FOR HOW THE
FUNDING CAN BE COORDINATED WITH
STATE WATER BOARD SPEAKER
PROGRAM- EITHER BC ARE
SUPPORTED IN A PROPOSAL TO
PROVIDE TWO HUNDRED FIFTY
MILLION FIRST EGGMAN
IMPLEMENTATION OUR ORGANIZATION
HAVE ALSO PROVIDED
RECOMMENDATIONS THE BUDGET
COMMITTEE- REGARDING THE THING
MY INVESTMENT MAINLY. AT THE
FUNDING GO TO MULTI BENEFIT
PRODUCTS INCLUDING THOSE THAT
PROTECTORATE OR WATER QUALITY
OR GROUND WATER LEVELS AND
COMMUNITY THE PENTAGON SHALLOW
WELLS AND A PORTION OF THOSE
FUNDS BE PROVIDED FOR TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE AND TO ALLOW
PARTICIPATION IN THAT EVENT IS
COMMUNITY OR THAT THEY CAN MAKE
EXTRA WATER SUPPLIES. I WE ALSO
ECHO THE POINTS MADE BY LANE.
FOR HELP BEING- THE REAR H. IS-
FOR WATER AND YOU TO THAT- AND
REQUEST FOR. REGARDING THE
LEVEL AND ALLOCATION AND
BUILDING THERE'S ONLY NEARLY
TWO BILL FOR ENERGY NEED AS
WELL AND IN THE STATE- THANK
YOU SO MUCH BACK TO THE SENATE
FOR THEIR LEADERSHIP ON THIS.
ANTI W. STEVEN LIKE TO OFFER
OUR EXPERTISE CENTER EXTRA FROM
THE LAB ROUTE TO SUPPORT THE
SENATE AND BUDGET CONVERSATIONS
OF THE REPORT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU NEXT. THANK YOU RYAN ONE
NINETEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON SHERRIN MEMBERS
MEANING AND ASHLEY WALKER AND
I'M REPRESENTING POTTERY DAM
AND- WE CAN HANG AT THE POOL
WATER DISTRICT TODAY WE'D LIKE
TO EXPRESS THEIR SUPPORT FOR
ITEM NUMBER KILL THE SENATE
DROUGHT BUDGET PROPOSAL WE
THINK THE CHAIR OF THE PLANET
AND LEADERSHIP FOR THE PROPOSED
AND BACK THEN. WE WOULD LIKE TO
EXPRESS THEIR SUPPORT FOR THE
ONE BILLION DOLLARS IN FUNDING
FOR CUSTOMER REAR EDGES AS
WE'VE SEEN A SIGNIFICANT
INCREASE IN THE NEED FOR
UTILITY RATEPAYER AND
ADDITIONALLY WERE SUPPORTIVE OF
THE FUNDING INCLUDED FOR
RECYCLED WATER PROJECT THAT. I
NEED FOR CREATIVE WATER SUPPLY
POLLUTION IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA INCREASES I WOULD
NOTED IN THAT. HEARING THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. X. THANK YOU I
KNOW SO PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
KRISTIN OLSON ON BEHALF OF THE
FAMILY WITH DELTA MENDOTA WATER
AUTHORITY REPRESENTING TWENTY
SEVEN WATER AGENCIES ACROSS THE
SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY CALLING IN
SUPPORT AND ISSUE NUMBER TWO
THE SENATE PROPERLY PACKAGE
REALLY APPRECIATE THE SENATE
LEADERSHIP ON THAT AND THEY'RE
VERY QUICK RESPONSE TO THE
DROUGHT AND THE RESULTING NEEDS
IN OUR COMMUNITIES. THANK YOUNG.
THANK YOU NECKS. THANK YOU RYAN
ONE TWENTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THE INTERNET CHABLIS WITH
WESTERN CANAL WATER DISTRICT ON
ITEM NUMBER TWO ONE TWO ECHOES
OF THE TEXT COMMENTS WITH THE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA WATER
AGENCIES AND FULL SUPPORT FOR.
SENATOR DOLE'S- FUNDING FOR
STATES RESERVOIR THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. NEXT. THANK YOU ALL RIGHT
ONE TWENTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
RICHARD MEMBERS GREG COOK
REPRESENTING NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA POWER AGENCY IN OUR
SIXTEEN MEMBER AGENCIES IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF ISSUE TOO AND
THANK YOU FOR YOUR RECOGNIZING
AND RYING TO SOLVE THIS
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT ISSUE.
THANK YOU. NEXT. THANK YOU I
NINETY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU MELISSA ROMERO WITH
THE CALIFORNIA CONSERVATION
BOARD VOTERS TO PROVIDE GENERAL
COMMENTS RELATED TO ISSUE ONE
TO CHECK THE GOVERNMENT CAN
COLLECT FORM YOU HAVE TO BE
DEPORTED AFTER SHORT FORM CHECK
THE HEALTH SURE LACKING
ACCOUNTABILITY AND TRANSPARENCY
WITHIN THE DEPARTMENT INCREASE
EFFECTIVENESS. WE URGE THE
LEGISLATURE TO CONTINUE LOOKING
FOR REFORM THAT WILL RESULT IN
CONSIDERABLE AND LONG OVERDUE
IMPROVEMENTS IN REJECTED WORK
PERFORMANCE AND ITS ABILITY TO
PROTECT COMMUNITY IMPACTED. BY
HOW TO THE PLATE. WE WOULD LIKE
RATE THEM FOR AND PERFORMANCE
AND FOR A CORD. SAFETY AND YOU
HAVEN'T CONCERNED ABOUT PUBLIC
HOW IMPACT OF USING YOU CAN IT
I. WITHOUT A PORTABLE HOUSING.
WE ARE SELECT. AND MANAGED TO
CRAFT ONE OVER EFFORT INCLUDE
COOPERATION A CRUMPLED. WITH
ENVIRONMENT JUSTICE COMMUNITIES
WHO HAVE BEEN BY DEPARTMENT
HISTORIC. ONLY IN FOURTH
HUNDRED I KNOW SENT ESPECIALLY
AGAINST BAD ACTORS. INCLUDING
COMMUNITY HOW FOR YEARS. AND
COMMENT ON ITEMS YOU. HE'LL BE
SUPPORT HE PROPOSAL PROVIDE A
FOR YOUR ABOUT CUSTOMER. THAT
AND WE CAN HAVE I JUST. WITH
STONE DON'T AMERICAN. THAT
WATER. AND WE STRONGLY SUPPORT
DOES NOT TO PROVIDE THE RIGHT
NINE MILLION GOT MORE AND
GROWING SENIORS. ALONG WITH
ADDITIONAL FUNDING FOR OTHER
DROUGHT NEED. INVESTMENT
MOUNTAINS NATIVE BETTER KNOWN
TO BE VULNERABLE TO DROUGHT CAN
PROTECT RESIDENTS ACCESS TO
SAFE DRINKING WATER. HE'LL BE
OUT OF THE PARK BENEFIT FOCAL
TO PROVIDE WIENER FIFTY MILLION
FOR. PUBLICATION AND JOINING
NUMBER ORGANIZATION WE'VE
ALREADY HEARD FROM DAN MARKEY
CAL WHO PROVIDED RECOMMENDATION
ON BUDGET CONVERTER BUDGET
COMMITTEE COMPRISED OF MY
INVESTMENT. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU NEXT. THANK YOU I ONE FOR
SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. THIS IS
GAIL DELAHAYE WITH GROW
ASSOCIATION WE WANT TO THANK
THE SENATE FOR THE DROUGHT AN
ORDER SUPPORT. ESPECIALLY WITH-
RICK TO THE FOR HUNDRED MILLION.
INTO AT THIS THE FIVE MILLION
WATER YOU TO FISH. WHICH ALSO
IN YOUR FIFTY MILLION FORCED-
THAT THREE HUNDRED FIFTY
MILLION CIGNA WE RIP. IT IF YOU
WOULD ADDING. AMOUNT OF FUNDING
FOR SAFE DRINKING WATER- AS IT
RELATES TO THE IMPLEMENTATION
OF GROUNDWATER SUSTAINABILITY
PLANS. AND WE THANK YOU FOR THE
TWO HUNDRED MILLION OF FOR THE
WATER INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECTS.
AGAIN THANK YOU FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP IN THIS CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT FUNDING PACKAGE. MAX.
THANK YOU RUN ONE TWENTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS CHANGED
AMERICA WILL BATTLE STING
GILBERT ROBESON'S MET ON BEHALF
OF THE RANCHO CALIFORNIA WATER
DISTRICT ORANGE COUNTY WATER
DISTRICT IN THE SAN FRANCISCO
PUBLIC UTILITIES COMMISSION. IN
SHORT MEMBERS REPAIRS ALL OVER
THE STATE HAVE BEEN UNABLE TO
PAY THEIR BILLS- ABSOLUTE
MONSTER NO FAULT OF THEIR OWN
DUE TO THE PANDEMIC. THOSE SAME
REPAIRS ON THE UTILITY SERVICE
WERE NOW STARING DOWN THE
DROUGHT AND WE REALLY REALLY
WANT TO EXPRESS OUR CLIENT
APPRECIATION FOR THE SENATE
LEADERSHIP AND STEPPING UP TO
BE PROACTIVE ON BOTH PROBLEMS
AT ONCE. I LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH ALL OF YOU TO
SUPPORT THIS PROPOSAL AS IT
GOES FORWARD. THANK YOU. X.
NECKS. THANK YOU RIGHT ONE
THIRTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS JULIET
CHRISTIAN CLINTON CALLING WITH
SUPPORT FROM THE WATER
FOUNDATION FOR THE DROUGHT-
PACKAGE AND THE WATER DEBT
RELIEF PACKAGE FOR ALL OF THE
REASON- SO MANY HAVE ALREADY
EXPLAINED- FOR MANY CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITIES THE DROUGHT NEVER
ENDED. AND WILL CONTINUE TO GO
DRY IN SEVERAL PARTS OF THE
STATE THE STATE DOES NEED TO DO
BETTER THAN WE DID IN THE LAST
DROUGHT IN INVESTMENT IN
COMMUNITY IS KNOWN TO BE
VULNERABLE CAN PROTECT ACCESS
TO SAFE DRINKING WATER. WE
WELCOME FURTHER CONVERSATION
FOR HOW THE FUNDING COULD BE
COORDINATED WITH THE STATE
WATER BOARD SPEAKER PROGRAM AND
THANK YOU. NEXT THANK YOU RYAN
ONE TEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
TRICIA GERINGER WITH
AGRICULTURAL COUNCIL CALIFORNIA
EVERYTHING IN OUR OWN BUSINESS
AS DROUGHT THE STATE YOU CAN
REGARD TO ITEM NUMBER Q. I
THINK YOU CAN IF YOU ARE AND
THE SENATE LEADERSHIP OF COURSE
FOR THE LEAD ON THIS ISSUE OF
DROUGHT RELIEF. THAT IS
PROPOSED IN THIS PLAN WE
APPRECIATE AND AGREE WITH
SENATOR STAR AND MORE IS NEEDED
PARTICULARLY WITHIN ST MARK'S
AND URGE I HAVE MY SOME OF MY
COLLEAGUES GET CLOSER TO ONE
BILLION PER THINK MAP- SH
DIRECTED INTO CRITICALLY OVER
DRAFTED BEACON OF PLANNING
PROJECTS AND MULTI BENEFIT LAND
RETIREMENT COOPER. WE ARE VERY
SUPPORTIVE OF DRINKING WATER
FIND IN THIS PACKAGE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOUR THOUSAND AND
FINALLY WE ARE SUPPORTIVE OF
THE WATER USE THAT THE
EFFICIENCY DOLLARS AND LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE TO ENSURE THAT
THE PROCESSING PLANT IN
CALIFORNIA HAVE ACCESS TO
COMPETE FOR THE WATER USE THAT
THE EFFICIENCY DOLLARS. WITH IN
THE PROPOSED FRAMEWORK AND MANY
OF THOSE ARE LOCATED IN
CRITICALLY OVER DRAFTED DESCEND
AND EMPLOYING PEOPLE AND
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN OPPORTUNITY
TO SPEAK. WELCOME MODDERS. OR
ANYONE ELSE ON THE LINE. THANK
YOU I KERN HAVE NO FURTHER
THANK YOU AT THE TIME. ALL
RIGHT WE'LL THE PUBLIC HEARING
BRING. THE MATTER BACK TO THE
DAIS- DO I HAVE I WILL
ENTERTAIN A MOTION CENTER
DOLLARS. FIRST I'D LIKE TO MAKE
A MOTION TO ALLOCATE. MY I
WANTED IS RIGHT ALLOCATE
FIFTEEN MILLION DOLLARS TO THE
TO THE LAKE IRRIGATION DISTRICT
AND COMMUNITY. AND THEN SELECT
AMEND THE STAFF RECOMMENDATION
YES THIS IS A MOTION ON THE
MEMO TO THE STAFF
RECOMMENDATION ON. THE TULE
LAKE. THAT'S RIGHT PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. CASKEY I ALLEN HI
MCGUIRE RIGHT STERN. OKAY THAT
MATTER TO ME. STERN AYE. AND
SECONDLY I'D LIKE TO MAKE A
MOTION. FOUR THE STAFF
RECOMMENDATION AS AMENDED YES
SACRIFICIAL RECOMMENDATION AS
AMENDED FOR THE DROP PACKAGE SO
THIS IS ON THE STAFF
RECOMMENDATION AS AMENDED MISS
ROY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. AYE
CASKEY AYE TELLING AYE I'M GLAD
RIGHT DURRANCE HI. STERN AYE.
ABATTIS APPROVED FOR ZERO AS
AMENDED SO ON TO THE BUDGET ARM.
ALL RIGHT THIS IS A THAT THIS
CONCLUDES- ARE TODAY'S. HEARING
I LOOK FORWARD TO SEEING
EVERYBODY ON TUESDAY WILL BE
DEALING WITH THE WILDFLOWERS
PACKAGE AND THEN ACT PACKAGE.
SO- THE SUBCOMMITTEE ON-
NATURAL RESOURCES ENVIRONMENTAL
PROTECTION AND ENERGY IN THE
SENATE BUDGET FOR FISCAL REVIEW
IS BITTER. RIGHT BECAUSE EVEN
IF YOU DON'T HAVE TO. HOUSE IS
ALMOST.